Und mittlerweile die Führung auch verdient. Die Entscheidung in einer tollen Zweitligapartie dann Sekunden vor dem Abpfiff. Ralph Gunesch auf und davon, der Tunnel gegen Ötczan, St. Pauli, Hoffenheim 3 zu 1.
Natürlich, das Ganze direkt im Keimer stecken, dass das überhaupt keine Mode macht, dass das nicht salonfähig wird oder dass das abgetan wird. Das kann ja mal passieren oder dass man da weghört, weil dann wird es immer mehr und das will, denke ich, keiner, dass man aufgrund seiner Hautfarbe oder sexuelle Orientierung oder sonst was diskriminiert und auch das Übelste beschimpft wird. Ich habe schon noch richtig Bock. Ich fühle mich mit 32 auch noch nicht so alt, aber es ist halt heutzutage mit 32 und dann mit 31 diese schwere Verletzung gehabt. Es ist nicht leicht und mir geht es nicht darum, irgendwie Karriere ausklingen zu lassen, sondern wenn, dann will ich was machen, worauf ich richtig Bock habe und also das Fußball spielen. Und nicht, um irgendwie noch ein Auslaufen zu finden, sondern ambitioniert, aber nochmal ist es schwierig, mit der Hintergrundgeschichte, Alter und Verletzung da was Adäquates zu finden. Deswegen muss ich mich natürlich auch auf die Eventualität vorbereiten, dass es halt nicht mehr weitergeht am aktiven, bezahlten Profi-Fußball. Eddie, bei allem Respekt, aber du fährst nach Frankfurt, die ja momentan in keinem guten Zustand sind. Ja, Zwänger habe ich sowieso nicht. Sogar der Hosenzwang ist heute aufgehoben, aber…
Aber hier hast du auch noch gemacht, oder?
Nein, nein, nein. Nein, das habe ich dann parallel auslaufen lassen, aber dazu kommen wir gleich. Und kam dann und sagte, du sollst die Vorbereitung bei den Profis mitmachen. Also ich hätte noch ein Jahr A-Jugend spielen können. Genau, also im zweiten A-Jugend-Jahr, du sollst die Vorbereitung bei den Profis spielen. Ich hatte fünf Tage Sommerpause, weil die A-Jugend-Saison halt länger ging. Ich bin nicht ins normale Training eingestiegen, sondern ich musste erst zum Trainingslager, das waren aber auch nur drei oder vier Tage. Das erste Mal dahin und ich weiß noch, dass ich mit der Tasche, die ich gepackt habe, hätte ich zwei Wochen irgendwo verbringen können. Naja, ich habe halt gedacht, okay, das sind zwei Trainingseinheiten am Tag, dann brauchst du so und so und so viele Trainingsklamotten, wir mussten uns die Trainingsklamotten halt selber besorgen damals. So, dann kommst du dahin und wir haben vor Abfahrt nochmal in Aachen trainiert. Naja, musst du nicht, weil…
Da steht der Zeugwort mit…
Da steht der Zeugwort und du hast größere L-Ralle, ja, größere L und dann habe ich alles in L bekommen und dann lag da alles. Ich sag, ist das im Trainingslager auch so? Und ganz vorsichtig gefragt, ja klar, du hast auch Klamotten von uns. Und ich dann meinen Papa anrufe und ich sag, kannst du mal bitte die Tasche abholen, weil ich glaube, die brauche ich nicht. Und er ist mal alle Sachen aus der Tasche rausgeräumt, außer also das, was man so persönlich braucht. Und ich denke, oh, Profifußball, so ist das also. Man muss sich nicht zumindest um die Sachen kümmern. Also ich war wirklich ganz naiv da mit dieser riesen Tasche angereist, die ich gar nicht gebraucht habe. Eigentlich hätte ich nur so ein bisschen persönliches Zeug, das reicht. Alles andere, was du zum Trainieren brauchst, das bekommst du ja. Und dann sind wir nach, ich glaube, es war Waldbreitbach gefahren und es war so hart. Also körperlich so hart, also für mich halt. Es war so intensiv. Ich habe zwar alles mitmachen können, aber es war einfach hart. Und aufgenommen von den Leuten, ich meine, du kannst dir ja auch mal den Kaderparallel anschauen, also Willi Landgraf war ja damals schon eine Zweiligai-Ikone. Dann hast du Ivo Grilic kam in dem Jahr, dann kam Frank Schmidt war da, Mark Spanja. Dann hatten wir mit Rudan ein Australier, der einen genialen rechten Fuß hatte, war so ein schlampiges Genie. Josef Ivanovic, Jupp Ivanovic, ein überragender Typ, der hat, ich glaube, was sagte ich, der hat von der ersten bis zur achten Liga, in jeder Liga, glaube ich, gespielt. Oder von der zweiten bis zur achten, in jeder auch ein Tor geschossen. So ein ganz bulliger Stürmer, links Fuß, hatte vorher, glaube ich, in Magdeburg gespielt. Stefan Lämmermann, die große Alemannia Ikone, der Publikumsheld eigentlich. Also der Fabian Wohl von Alemannia Aachen. Was hatten wir noch?
Wer waren denn so die Bezugspersonen für dich? Hält man sich da an den anderen jungen Spieler, die auch eher noch ein bisschen grün hinter den Ohren sind? Oder nimmt einen da jemand unter die Fittiche? Oder ist man komplett auf sich allein gestellt?
Zu dem Zeitpunkt bin ich – also Willi war immer so ein Zwischending zwischen ich hau dir auf die Fresse und ich nehme dich ein bisschen an die Hand. Frank, du lachst, aber es war tatsächlich die Verbindung oder die Beziehung zwischen älteren und jungen Spielern war eine ganz andere, als das heute ist. Da bist du halt in die Kabine gekommen und hast die Fresse gehalten. Und dann erzähle ich euch gleich eine lustige Anekdote. Das war anders, aber Willi war trotzdem aber auch jemand, der dich mal zur Seite genommen hat und hat gesagt, pass auf, das und das und so und mach mal dies. Und dann kam Frank Schmidt, das weiß ich noch, kam Frank Schmidt am ersten Abend des Trainingslagers. Und dann finden sich ja die Plätze, wo man dann sitzt. Und das ist dann meistens der fixe Tisch fürs Trainingslager. Und dann kommt Frank zu mir und sagt alle, du darfst bei uns am Tisch sitzen. Frank war Kapitän. Frank, Sascha Hildmann, Willi Landkauf, Mark Spanier. Das waren auch so die, die immer gespielt haben. Das waren die älteren Spieler, also wirklich die großen Nummern, was du so wahrgenommen hast als Jugendspieler. Du darfst bei uns am Tisch sitzen unter der Voraussetzung oder mit der Bedingung, dass du 10 Minuten vorher am Tisch bist und einen Korb mit Brot und Butter an den Tisch bringst, weil die waren halt am Buffet. Ich war nicht 10 Minuten da, ich war 20 Minuten vorher da und habe nicht einen Brotkorb, sondern habe zwei Brotkorbe hingestellt und halt einen Teller mit Butter fertig gemacht, weil die gerne vor dem Essen dann nochmal, weißt du, einfach so ein bisschen, ein kleines Stückchen Brot mit ein bisschen Butter vorweg gegessen haben. Und dann habe ich das gemacht. Sagt das heute. Ja, natürlich Hackordnung. Dann hast du dich den runter geordnet. Auf dem Platz gab es das nicht. Aber neben dem Platz, wenn ich nicht mit beiden Händen voll vom Platz runter bin, mit Hütchen, Leibchen, Bällen und noch irgendwas auf dem Kopf balancieren, ein bisschen übertrieben formuliert, dann gab es einen Anpfiff.
Zu viel anders klingt doch das, was Basti Schweinsteiger über Olli Kahn berichtet hat auch nicht eigentlich, oder?
Basti ist ein Jahr jünger als ich. Wir waren zusammen im Trainingslager mit der Nationalmannschaft. Das ist genau die Zeit gewesen.
Und wie hast du da dann reingefunden? Also klar, du warst jetzt der Brötchenholer.
Der Brötchen- und Butterholer, ja. Herr Schmidt, ich hoffe, es hat geschmeckt. Also da wurde ich angenommen, weil ich auch keiner war, der jetzt geglaubt hat, dass er nur, weil er jetzt im Trainingslager mit ist, dass mir jetzt die Welt offen steht.
Das ist ja was Besonderes.
Ja, nein, das Gott sei Dank gar nicht. Da bin ich von zu Hause so erzogen worden, dass mir das eben nicht passiert ist und auf den Platz einfach versuche, Gas zu geben. Als Innenverteidiger, jein, viel Außenverteidiger gespielt, weil das immer noch so eine Position ist, da kannst du auch mal einen hinschieben. Und es war gut, es hat Spaß gemacht, aber es war so intensiv, dass ich am Ende der Vorbereitung völlig durch war. Völlig durch den Wind. Und dann kam meine Mutter und sagte, hier so und so, irgendeine Freundin hat dir erzählt, Eugen Hach hätte mich kritisiert. Und dann stand halt einfach nur in der Zeitung, Eugen Hach, die klassischen Interviews nach der Vorbereitung vor dem Punkt-Spiel-Start. Gute Vorbereitung, aber ich kriege den Wortlaut nicht mehr hin, aber so sinngemäß, der ist ziemlich kaputt und wir müssen da ein bisschen dosieren. Die Sache an sich ist nicht ungewöhnlich, aber dann stand zum ersten Mal was in der Zeitung über dich. Und da stand jetzt nicht drin, dass er jetzt durchstartet und die Alemannie in die Erste Liga schießt. Also war es Kritik. Also so wurde es wagen. Ja, ja, natürlich.
Und wenn Muttern mit den Damen das dann bespricht, dann kommt da halt was anderes raus.
Aber da stand halt wirklich nur drin, dass ich körperlich aktuell ein bisschen im Tief bin und sie mich da jetzt halt rausnehmen und dann ist auch alles wieder gut. Es war auch nichts anderes. Also es war wirklich nur, dass ich dann das Training für zehn Tage, glaube ich, etwas dosiert oder etwas dosiert wurde. Und dann war auch…
Nach dem Trainingslager.
Nee, nee, kurz vor, also die Woche vor Saisonstart. Ich war jetzt bei dem ersten Spiel, war ich glaube ich nicht im Kader. Das war gegen Hannover, 0-2 oder sowas. Und…
Und wie war die Saison dann?
Leider nicht gut. Leider nicht gut, weil wir einen bescheidenen Start erwischt haben. Mit einem, ich bin mir ziemlich sicher, ein 0-2 in Hannover. Und es ging dann weiter – bitte schau nach und korrigier mich – es ging weiter mit Niederlagen und dann wurde Eugen Hach entlassen. So, dann wurde Eugen Hach entlassen und dann kam Jörg Berger. Was für mich zu dem Zeitpunkt nicht gut war, wie sich das dann entwickelt hat, war eine andere Geschichte. Aber zu dem Zeitpunkt war es halt einfach nicht gut. Zum einen war die Situation nicht so dafür da, viel auf junge Spieler zu setzen. Und dann war Jörg Berger halt auch – man soll über Verstorbene nicht schlecht reden, ich versuche das ganz sachlich zu beschreiben – er war nicht unbedingt jemand, der sehr viel und intensiv mit jungen Leuten zusammengearbeitet hat. Das heißt, für mich begann zu dem Zeitpunkt keine gute Zeit bei Alemannia Aachen. Und ich habe dann noch ein Spiel von Anfang an gemacht in Duisburg als Linksverteidiger. Alemannia Aachen zu dem Zeitpunkt auswärts – völlig egal wo, eigentlich hättest du gar nicht hinfahren müssen, weil es gab regelmäßig zwischen drei und sechs Stück. Also auswärts hat nicht funktioniert bei uns, es ging nicht.
Da war dieses Spiel keine Ausnahme.
Da war dieses Spiel keine Ausnahme, richtig. Wir sind nach Duisburg gefahren, Pierre Lipaski damals Trainer, Gwieniszczyk in der Mannschaft, Marius Ebers vorne im Sturm und ich als Linksverteidiger und vor mir Oli Kajas. Olivier Kajas, ein guter Fußballer, hat auch seine Schwächen und das war halt die Rückwärtsbewegung neben zwei, drei anderen Dingen.
Das musst du ja jetzt sagen.
Olivier wird heute wahrscheinlich protestieren, aber ich bleibe dabei, ich wurde sehr oft sehr alleine gelassen. Und dann gab es halt fünf Stück in Duisburg und da habe ich dann danach auch nicht mehr so oft gespielt, also eigentlich gar nicht mehr, also bei den Profis. Um das jetzt noch ein bisschen die Zeit nochmal kurz zu erklären, ich habe bei den Profis trainiert, weiterhin, habe bei den Amateuren und bei der A-Jugend gespielt, also ich hatte wirklich Wochenenden, Freitagabend Profikaner, Samstag Amateure, Sonntag A-Jugend, Spiel. Oder zum Teil auch zwei Spiele am Tag, dass ich morgens um 10 Uhr bei der A-Jugend gespielt habe und habe nachmittags um 14 Uhr bei den Amateuren auf der Bank gesessen und habe nochmal 45 Minuten gespielt. Also das war nicht ungewöhnlich, aber das waren halt die Tage, wo die Profis frei hatten und die sind am Montag wieder eingestiegen. Das heißt, am Montag bin ich dann auch wieder bei den Profis noch Training gewesen. Und dann bin ich irgendwann zu Jörg Schmatke, der wurde dann Sportdirektor in Aachen, und sage, Herr Schmatke, verstehen Sie mich bitte nicht falsch. Du willst da ja nicht meckern, du willst ja auch keine Ansprüche stellen. Ich möchte nur darauf hinweisen, ich habe momentan keine freien Tage. Ich sage ja, da am Kader, dann bist du die halbe Nacht auf dem Rückweg unterwegs, dann Samstag U19 oder halt A-Jugend, Tjöng Amateure und Sonntag dann jeweils die andere Mannschaft oder auch zum Teil zwei Spiele an einen Tag. Und dann sagt er, ja, das ist uns gar nicht so bewusst gewesen. Ich sage, okay, ich wollte auch nur darauf hinweisen, dass wir das vielleicht ein bisschen steuern, weil das macht keinen Sinn, das macht dich kaputt. Das hältst du auch mit 18 nicht lange durch. So und dann haben wir da dann so ein paar Regelungen gefunden und dann hat das dann besser funktioniert, dass ich dann auch mal irgendwie nach dem Spiel zumindest mal einen freien Tag hatte. Und zu der Geschichte eine oder zu dem Part eine sehr, sehr lustige Anekdote. Kennt ihr den Brauch des Maibaums? Ich meine nicht den Maibaum, den man im Dorfzentrum aufstellt, sondern den, den man an am Haus seines Schwarms befestigt. Das kennt ihr. Ist es so, dass du in der Nacht vor dem ersten Mai, also auf den – hat der April 39 oder 31 Tage?
30.
Auf den 30. Nein, nein, nein, nein, nein. Du klaust ihn irgendwo. Also du gehst irgendwo hin. Das macht man natürlich nicht. Aber man sägt dann ein – was sind das für Bäume, die weißen – ist das Birken, ne, nicht Birken. Genau. Du gehst irgendwo in den Wald oder so. Es gibt auch – die kannst du auch regulär kaufen, aber eigentlich – man fährt irgendwo hin und ist halt mit mehreren Jungs und macht das dann, schmückt den mit Krepppapier, schön bunt, klärt das im Optimalfall vorher mit dem Vater deines Schwarms, so nach dem Motto du pass auf, wir tauchen in der Nacht zum 1. Mai, tauchen wir irgendwann mal bei dir auf und dann mit Kabelbindern wird er dann an der Hauswand, an der Regenrinne festgemacht oder an der Dachrinne.
Und hast du es geklärt?
Ja, vorab hatte ich es geklärt. Das Ding war nur folgendes, wir haben am 1. Mai in Wattenscheid gespielt und das war für die A-Jungen damals ein extrem wichtiges Spiel, weil sie standen mit dem Rücken zur Wand, waren Letzter und Jörg Schmatke kam zu mir und sagte, dass ich jetzt überwiegend A-Jugend spiele, weil die Jungs müssen drin bleiben. Das war die höchste Spielklasse, die Jungs müssen drin bleiben. Ich dachte, das war ein Sonntag, aber Maibaum, was machen wir denn jetzt? Das war das einzige Mal, dass ich mich komplett unprofessionell, aber mega unprofessionell. Auf so ein Spiel vorbereitet habe. Es war extrem wichtig, wenn wir das verloren hätten, dann hättest du keine Chance mehr gehabt. Wir mussten aus den letzten acht Spielen gefühlt sieben gewinnen, aber es war wirklich ganz, ganz eng. Ich bin mit meinen Jungs die ganze Nacht unterwegs gewesen. Ich habe keine Sekunde geschlafen. Dann waren wir unterwegs und haben diesen Maibaum aufgestellt und wachgehalten mit Energy-Drinks, und zwar sechs, sieben Stück die Nacht über. Das war auch komplett banane, komplett dumm damals gewesen. Wir hatten keinen Trecker. Normalerweise schaffst du es dann vielleicht. Irgendeiner hat dann schon mal mit 16, kannst du ja so eine gewisse Größe schon mal fahren. Das Jahr davor hatten wir es, hatte ein Kumpel von uns, hatte halt so einen Trecker mit Anhänger und dann konnten wir alles draufladen und sind damit über die Dörfer. Und das hatten wir in dem Jahr nicht. Was haben wir Holzköpfe gemacht? Der Opel Astra meiner Mutter hatte einen Schiebedach.
Baum rein.
Nicht rein, sondern aufs Dach und durchs Schiebedach festhalten. Und dann irgendwie mit 30 über die Dörfer und dann immer Baum geholt dahin gefahren. Zurück zur Station, Baum geholt, völlig dumm, also wirklich komplett Banane. Und hab halt wirklich keine Sekunde geschlafen. Und bin dann morgen um neun, halb zehn zum Treffpunkt. Ich war tot, ich war wirklich tot und es war halt ein verdammt wichtiges Spiel. Ja, und dann, äh, spielen wir mal gegen Wadenscheidt. Wie schon gesagt, die Herrn Altintops, schon damals überragende Fußballer gewesen. Und wir haben das Spiel tatsächlich 2-1 gewonnen. Ich hab mich so beschissen gefühlt. Ich war wirklich, es ging einfach nichts mehr danach. Gehe in die Kabine und schlaf auf der Physioliege ein, aber wirklich in Sekundenschnelle. Ich war halt schon über 24 Stunden wach, plus ein Fußballspiel. Und schlaf halt sofort ein. Und dann kommt der Co-Trainer und rüttelt an mir und sagt, Ralf, du bist kaputt. Ich sag, ja, das Spiel war anstrengend. Ja, dusch dich. Du fährst jetzt mit mir zurück nach Aachen. Du bist bei der U23 noch auf der Bank. Wahnsinn. Und ich hab dann auf der Rückfahrt geschlafen. Die 1, 5, 1, 45, wie man von Wattenschein nach Aachen fährt, war dann bei der U23 tatsächlich auf der Bank und bin da auch nochmal eingewechselt worden für eine halbe Stunde.
Aber auf der Bank nicht nochmal eingeschlafen?
Nein, ich hab dann in Aachen angekommene Bratwurst gegessen. Mit Bratwurst in der Hand, wirklich rüber, hoch zum Kunstrasen und hab mich auf die Bank gesetzt.
Aber die wichtigste Frage ist ja, hat es mit dem Schwarm geholfen?
Ja, es war halt zu dem Zeitpunkt, Karina war es, genau, ja, das war meine Freundin damals. Und sie war ja schon meine Freundin und sie war es wert. Ja, aber das war halt eine sehr, sehr unprofessionelle Vorbereitung.
Du warst ja in der Zeit in allen Jugendnationalmannschaften.
U17 bis U20 war das, ja.
Bist du im Nachhinein enttäuscht, dass da der Sprung nicht so wirklich gelungen ist in den Nationalmannschaften? Ist ja schon doof, wenn man mit diesen Jungs mitläuft. Also du hast ja schon Schweinsteiger zum Beispiel erwähnt, da waren ja noch ganz andere dabei.
Philipp Lahm war bei uns und hat zu dem Zeitpunkt, war er jemand, der immer nur reingekommen ist.
Und war aber ja auch die Zeit, wenn wir jetzt vorhin bei 2000 waren, bis zur U20, 2004, das heißt…
Nee, also jetzt sind wir bei 2001 bis 2003.
2001 bis 2003, U17 bis U20, war aber die Zeit vor eben 2004 der EM, also in diesem Naja Umbruch im deutschen Fußball sozusagen, hat dann deine Entwicklung in der Zeit, wie passt es da zusammen?
Zu dem Zeitpunkt ein bisschen stagniert und das hatte ein paar Gründe. Zum einen, ich hatte es angesprochen, dass natürlich die Förderung dann ganz bei den Bundesländern, wie es nicht mehr so gegeben war unter Jörg Berger, weil einfach der Fokus ein anderer war, dann musste ich zur Bundeswehr und das war für mich persönlich eine sehr, sehr schwierige Zeit. Damals gab es ja noch die Wehrpflicht und die Bundeswehr war für mich insofern die sinnvolle Alternative, dass ich über die Sportförderkompanie quasi weiter normal Fußball spielen konnte. Zivildienst wäre in dem Maße nicht möglich gewesen, das so intensiv weiter zu verfolgen. Ich musste die Grundausbildung ganz normal, zehn Wochen, oder was heißt ganz normal, zehn Wochen habe ich die Grundausbildung gemacht. Ich war dann auch in der Kaserne direkt in Eschweiler stationiert, das sind 15 Kilometer von Aachen weg, weil der Co-Trainer der B-Jugend war da irgendwas, irgendein Offizier, hat da ein bisschen geschoben, dass ich da meine Grundausbildung machen konnte. Und danach war ich in der Sportförderkompanie in Köln und das war das Positive, da musste ich nur einmal die Woche montags hin und den Rest der Woche schickst du quasi deinen Trainingsplan dahin, dass die einfach wissen, wo du bist und kannst ganz normal deinem Sport nachgehen. Ist gerade für andere Sportarten, für kleinere Sportarten extrem, also für die einzelnen Sportler war das sehr gut, weil du hast eine gewisse Grundverpflegung, du hast eine gewisse finanzielle Unterstützung. Der finanzielle Part war jetzt zu dem Zeitpunkt bei mir nicht das wichtigste mir gings darum, dass ich einfach Sport machen konnte, dass ich tagtäglich trainieren konnte. Aber trotzdem waren diese knapp drei Monate mit der Grundausbildung keine einfache Zeit und drei Monate sind in der Phase extrem viel und ich konnte kaum trainieren. Also unser Dienst ging auch bis 17.30, 18 Uhr und dann habe ich es halt nicht zum Training geschafft. Und da ist meine Entwicklung so ein bisschen stehen geblieben.
Hast du es damals auch schon so wahrgenommen oder ist es jetzt so die Rückschau?
Es ist die Rückschau zu dem Zeitpunkt habe ich natürlich gemerkt, dass es jetzt nicht so vorwärts geht, wie es die Wochen und Monate vorher der Fall war. Aber es war keine einfache Zeit, in der ich aber wusste, okay, das geht nur noch einen gewissen Zeitraum und dann kann ich mich wieder voll und ganz auf Fußball konzentrieren. So in den Auswahlmannschaften war ich trotzdem. Dann habe ich zum Teil sogar in der Mittelrheinauswahl bei dem älteren Jahrgang mitgespielt. Bei dem 82er Jahrgang sind wir auch in Duisburg-Länder-Pokalsieger geworden und der DFB schickt dann quasi den Länder-Pokalsieger immer irgendwo in die Weltgeschichte hin und dann bist du als offizielle Vertretung des DFBs da und hast dann eine Länderspielreise. Die erste war nach Spanien und dann haben wir erstmal gegen ein Katalanen-Auswahl-Spiel gespielt. Das ist 2-2 ausgegangen auf taktisch extrem hohem Niveau, das weiß ich noch. Und dann haben wir auf einem Nebenplatz des Camp Nou gegen die damalige A-Jugend des FC Barcelona gespielt und haben als deutscher Meister sechs Stück kassiert. Die haben uns zerlegt. Die haben uns – ich würde zu gerne einfach nochmal die Mannschaft sehen, weil irgendeiner von den Jungs, die heute da hat da hundertprozentig mitgespielt, das war – die haben uns zerstört. Nochmal, du fährst als deutscher Meister hin und kriegst sechs Stück. Das war halt die Barca-Jugend, die konnten schon ein bisschen Fußball spielen. Müsste ich mir – ich habe es immer mal versucht, also im Internet findest du nichts, ich muss mal über den Mittelreinverband gehen, vielleicht haben die noch Aufzeichnung, weil es mich einfach interessieren würde, welche Spieler da beim FC Barcelona auf dem Platz standen. Es war halt so, dass die hatten einen 18er-Kader und irgendwie 14 hatten schon Verträge für die 1.
Wie war es so in der Nationalmannschaft? Ich stelle mir das – also gerade in der Phase ist es ja eh immer, wenn viele Jungs untereinander sind, sehr besonders, sage ich jetzt mal, da bilden sich schnell auch Hierarchien. Und dann ja nochmal Nationalmannschaft, wo alle auch ja schon das deutliche Ziel Profifußball vor Augen haben, es zum Teil schon geschafft haben oder auf dem Sprung sind. Ist das eher so ein Ellbogen mäßig?
Nein.
Oder wie ging es dazu?
Nein, also da ging es sehr, sehr kollegial zu, finde ich. Es war sehr interessant, was Sebastian Kneisel und Moritz Folz natürlich erzählt haben, die zu dem Zeitpunkt die, nicht die allerersten, ich glaube der allererste war Eugen Bob, aber Sebastian war der Erste, der zum großen Verein gewechselt wurde, gewechselt hat. Basti ist damals zu Chelsea, Folzi kurz danach zu Arsenal. Das waren so die großen Namen, die da nach England gewechselt sind, halt auch die dann getroffen. Matthias Lehmann, Philipp Lahm mit Bastian Schweinsteiger als 84er, dann in Spanien, weil wir gemeinsam im Trainingslager waren, Trujkowski, müsste jetzt durchgehen, Rundio, Malik Fati.
David O'Donkor war auch noch mit dabei?
Na, David war 84er. David war übrigens all die Jahre der eine Spieler, gegen den ich spielen musste, bei Borussia Dortmund. Es war immer David O'Donkor. Und bei Schalke 04 war es Mike Hanke.
Wie oft hast du ihn nur von hinten gesehen?
Du wirst lachen, ich habe David zum Teil in der Jugend eingeholt. Ach, was ist da passiert? Schnelligkeit war jetzt keine Schwäche von mir. Vielleicht war es auch nur Glück und David hat es nicht 100 Prozent gelaufen. Ich wusste natürlich, dass er schnell ist, aber da habe ich nicht viele Probleme gehabt, gegen ihn zu bestehen. Aber die ganze Truppe von Dortmund war halt nicht schlecht. Deswegen war das gegen die immer ein schweres Spiel.
Aber dann hast du ja in der Nationalmannschaft mit diesen größeren Namen zusammengespielt und vor allem hast du ja mitbekommen, wie andere Leute in deinem Alter bei anderen Vereinen Karriere machen und bei dir lief es bei Aachen nicht so richtig.
Also die Fokussierung und auch die Ausbildung bei den großen Vereinen war halt schon eine ganz andere als in Aachen, weil der Fokus in Aachen woanders lag.
Und hast du da dann darüber nachgedacht, da irgendwie was dran zu ändern oder hast du da auch Schritte unternommen? Das muss ja sehr frustrierend gewesen sein, auch immer diese zwei verschiedenen Welten. Einmal spielst du bei den Amateuren oder bei der bei der U19 und dann läufst du wieder in der Nationalmannschaft neben Philipp Lahm, der nur eingewechselt wird, auf.
Zu dem Zeitpunkt habe ich mir da gar keine großen Gedanken. Da war so Wechselthema und so war irgendwie gar nicht präsent bei mir. Das war einfach, ich habe einfach Fußball gespielt. Wenig darüber nachgedacht, sondern einfach Fußball gespielt.
Also auch wenig überhaupt, nicht nur über Wechseln, sondern überhaupt über das Thema, wie entwickelt sich jetzt meine Karriere. Da wollte ich vorher noch ansetzen. Du hast gesagt, so diese eine Woche da mit Einladung und Flug nach Finnland und dann dem Bundesligaspiel, das war so für dich der Zünder. War denn die Überlegung, oder dass es konkret wurde, ich will dieses Profi-Fußballer-Ding steht mir tatsächlich bevor und das wird auch was. War das da zuvor schon ein Thema oder ist das dann halt einfach so passiert?
Mit 16, wenn du dann halt bei so einem Verein wie Alemannia Aachen spielst, dann merkst du, dass es zum Greifen nahe ist. Also du musst jetzt liefern, aber jetzt ist die große Chance da. Und für mich war das einfach das große Ziel. Aber auch jetzt im Nachhinein sage ich, ich habe mir da gar nicht so viel Gedanken drüber gemacht, sondern habe wirklich einfach nur versucht, jeden Tag das Beste abzuliefern. Und wo es dann hinführt, werden wir sehen.
Aber wenn du nebenher das Abi noch hast, auslaufen lassen.
Ja, das kam dann, weil kurz nach dem 18. kam Jörg Schmatke zu mir und sagte, Ralf, wir würden dir gerne einen Profivertrag geben. Jetzt im Nachhinein weiß ich, dass sie einfach noch mal einen jungen deutschen Spieler brauchten, der aus der Jugend kommt, mit Profivertrag. Da gab es ja auch so zwölf deutsche Profis. Und ich war halt derjenige, der die Quote dann erfüllt. Und das war mir dann egal. Und dann war aber der Punkt, wo ich sage, okay, jetzt musst du dich entscheiden. Setzt du auf die Karte Profifußball oder auf die Karte Schule, weil diese Kooperation und so, wie es das heute gibt, das gab es nicht. Also mein Direktor damals – Entweder oder. Ja, genauso hat es mein Direktor gesagt. Und auch, ich weiß nicht, du schaffst das sowieso nicht. Wir hatten einen Lehrer, der hat es halt damals in Anführungsstrichen nur bis zur Oberliga geschafft. Und dem kam halt nur, der schafft das sowieso nicht. Vielleicht, weil er es selber nicht geschafft hat, aber... Ja, und dann hatte ich fast symbolisch links den Profivertrag, das Angebot, und rechts die Abiturklausur. Meine Eltern waren nicht begeistert, als ich mich für den Profivertrag unterschrieben habe. Ich habe die Schule komplett, also wirklich, ich habe sie ab 12.2 komplett sausen lassen. Ich war theoretisch noch in 13.1 angemeldet, 289 Fehlstunden, 287 unentschuldigt.
Was war bei den zwei Entschuldigten?
Ich habe wirklich Vor-Abi-Klausuren, das weiß ich noch, die gehen dann irgendwie 4, 5, 6 Stunden, sitzt dann da und guckt so aufs Blatt, französisch war es, glaube ich, schreibt meinen Namen drauf, schreibt das Thema, das Datum und gibt ab. Und da ist die Regelung ja so, ich weiß nicht, ob das heute noch auch noch so ist, wenn der erste fertig ist und abgegeben hat, dürfen die anderen nicht mehr auf Toilette.
Ja, stimmt.
Ich weiß nicht, ob das heute aufgrund der Smartphones sowieso hinfällig ist, aber…
Ich glaube, jetzt ist es noch krasser.
War halt so und dann gebe ich ab und dann sagt sie, ja, aber du weißt schon, dass ich jetzt keinen mehr auf Toilette gehen lassen darf. Und es war halt nach fünf Minuten und die Klausur ging noch vier Stunden. Ich sag, ja, aber können sie ruhig, weil ich fahre jetzt sowieso nach Aachen zum Training. Ich bin jetzt hier eh nicht mehr vor Ort. Ja, okay, gut, dann war für die anderen eine normale Klausur.
Und da steht ja eh nichts drin. Also was soll ich den anderen auf der Toilette gutes tun?
Wenn ich irgendwas wüsste, hätte ich es draufgeschrieben. So und so habe ich das dann bei mehreren Klausuren gemacht. Ich muss sagen, jetzt im Nachhinein…
Aber das heißt, du hast es nicht mal probiert. Man hätte ja gucken können, ob da noch irgendwas geht. Ich meine, französisch jetzt ein bisschen schwierig, aber…
Ich kann mich in vielen Bereichen da schon ganz gut einschätzen.
Weil ich hätte jetzt gesagt, klar, irgendwie hat er nicht mehr Deprior, aber dann versucht man irgendwie, die vier zu kriegen, die man braucht, oder halt die, keine Ahnung, fünf Punkte, die es dann sind, oder sechs Punkte.
Nee, es hätte nicht funktioniert, weil es null Abstimmung gibt. Heute ist das aufeinander abgestimmt, aber es ist, wie Frank sagte, entweder oder. Und für mich hat sich zu keiner Sekunde die Frage gestellt. Für mich war klar, wohin, in welche Richtung es geht. Ich weiß natürlich auch, dass das ein Risiko war. Liebe Kinder und liebe Eltern, gebt das an eure Kinder weiter. Macht das Jahr zu Ende, das ist gut.
Sonst landet ihr im Rasenfunk, das kann niemand machen.
Aber für mich war es halt, sage ich im Nachhinein, die richtige Entscheidung. Und ich persönlich, ich, Ralph, würde es immer so machen, aber ich würde es nicht als allgemeine Empfehlung raushauen. Das muss wirklich jeder für sich selber entscheiden.
War es denn damals so, dass es überhaupt noch nirgendwo diese Verbindung gab? Kannst du das sagen? Ich meine, dass ich vor ein paar Sagen gelesen habe, dass das Bayern Jugendhaus jetzt 20 Jahre alt wurde.
Es ging los.
Und ich glaube, die haben damit ja so ein bisschen angefangen, oder?
Kölner und die Leverkusen, also ich kann natürlich nur aus meiner Region sprechen, die hatten, glaube ich, schon Jugendinternat. Aber es kam nie Angebote aus der Ecke. Das war nie Thema, dass ich nach Köln oder nach Leverkusen oder so. Und ich bin, das muss ich auch sagen, im Nachhinein auch froh, dass ich meine Kindheit und Jugend zu Hause verbringen durfte. Dass ich da noch sowas wie ein geregeltes Leben hatte, auch wenn – geregelt meine ich jetzt ein Leben im eigenen sozialen Umfeld, sprich Familie und Freunde – auch wenn ich auf wahnsinnig viele Dinge verzichtet habe, das musst du. Also Profifußball nicht nur in der aktiven Zeit, sondern auch davor bedeutet unheimlich viel Disziplin und Verzicht. Also wenn die anderen halt auf Party waren, ich habe um 22 Uhr geschlafen, wenn ich am Sonntag gespielt habe. Lag auch daran, dass ich samstags immer morgens um 5 Uhr aufgestanden bin, bin mit meinem Vater mitgefahren und habe bei ihm in der Firma gearbeitet und in den Ferien auch jeden Tag von 6 bis 16, 17, 18 Uhr bei ihm quasi mitgearbeitet. Er arbeitet in der Metallverarbeitung, ist CNC-Dreher und die haben die Programme fertiggeschrieben und wenn es dann halt so kleine Aufträge waren, habe ich wirklich nur die Metallteile ausgetauscht. Habe gewartet, bis das Programm durchgelaufen ist, die Halle gefegt, bin mit dem Gabelstapler übers Gelände geheizt, weil ich dann hinten dran sind so Auffangbecken für die Späne. Die müssen ja dann regelmäßig geleert werden. Das habe ich dann mit dem Gabelstapler gemacht. Da habe ich auch meine Liebe für die Autos, glaube ich, entdeckt. Also so kleine Arbeiten, die den normalen Arbeitsablauf etwas unterbrechen oder verzögern, die habe ich quasi übernommen. So habe ich mir das Geld für meinen Führerschein mit 16 finanziert. So habe ich mein Motorrad mit 16, da ich war der erste Jahrgang, der 125er fahren durfte, finanziert. Insofern kenne ich auch zumindest in Teilen das normale Arbeitsleben, wie es ist, morgens um 5 Uhr aufzustehen und dann 10 Stunden, 12 Stunden an der Maschine zu stehen. Das habe ich über Monate Samstags gemacht und immer in den Ferien. Es gab richtig gutes Geld für mich. Das war richtig gut. Für einen 16-Jährigen ist das gerade so Sommerferien. Das war schon recht ordentlich. Dann habe ich es beiseite gelegt, da mein Vater gesagt hat, wenn du den Führerschein mit 16 machen willst, den 125er, musst du selber zahlen.
Wenn wir schon beim Geld sind. Wir haben jetzt über den ersten Profivertrag vorhin gesprochen, beziehungsweise du hast erwähnt, dass Jörg Schmatke dir den mehr oder weniger aus logistischen Gründen vorwiegend angeboten hat. Der legt einem dann einen Vertrag vor die Nase, da steht dann drin, keine Ahnung, x Euro. Wie geht man damit um? Man freut sich und nimmt es hin, wie es ist? Du hast ja am Anfang deiner Karriere keinerlei Bezug und wahrscheinlich auch keinen Berater.
Das kam ganz kurz danach. Nachdem ich dann häufiger bei den Profis im Kader war, war es dann so, dass natürlich die ersten Berater angeklopft haben. Ich weiß noch, Norbert Flippen zu dem Zeitpunkt, eine ganz große Nummer in dem Geschäft. Da saßen wir im WIP-Zelt zusammen in Aachen und er hat mir dann auch so seine Philosophie erzählt. Und irgendwie, es passte mir nicht so. Das war sehr aufgepluster. Das war sehr groß gedacht. Für mein Empfinden damals zu groß. Deswegen habe ich das Angebot nicht wahrgenommen und hatte mich dann über Willi Landgraf mit Volker Schlappner zusammengesetzt, der Sohn von Klaus Schlappner, der den meisten sicherlich was sagen dürfte. Und er ist ganz anders an die Sache herangegangen. Wirklich ganz bodenständig, ganz solide. Und das hat mir halt gefallen und wir haben halt wirklich 15 Jahre lang da zusammengearbeitet.
Zu groß gedacht, um da nochmal anzuknüpfen bezüglich Visionen für deine Karriere.
Visionen und ich bringe dich dahin und ich mache dies. Und es war mir einfach too much. So und deswegen dann eher für Volker Schlappner entschieden. Und das war, fand ich, so eine ganz grundsolide Planung und eine Idee, die dahinter steckte. Ja und dann kam halt das Ding mit Jörg Schmatke, mit dem Vertrag. Das war, ich meine aber noch vor Volker. Und ja, was machst du? Du verfügst auf einmal über, ja jetzt nicht die Beträge, die heute kursieren, aber schon über eine beträchtliche Summe für einen 18-Jährigen, die so halt nicht normal ist. Und du machst Dummheiten.
Hast dir Sachen gekauft?
Ja auch, habe mir Sachen gekauft. Ich habe mir einen Golf 3 dann gekauft. Das war mein erstes eigenes Auto. Der Golf 3 hat, ich glaube, dreieinhalb, viertausend Euro gekostet. Und ich habe ihn umgebaut für locker sechs bis siebentausend. Zusätzlich nochmal reingesteckt. Ja, es war halt, es war damals das Tuning. Also so Golf 3, das war gerade der Wechsel zum Golf 4. Corrado, der eine oder andere könnte den noch kennen, der gute alte Corrado G36. Die Polos, das war dann eine Nummer kleiner. Die guten hatten halt einen Golf 3 VR6, das war der mit dem 176 PS Motor. Dann gab es noch, klar, der klassische BMW 3er E46. Das waren so die beliebten Tuning-Autos. Ich hatte halt den Golf 3, weil das hat mir am besten gefallen. Ich habe da unheimlich viel Geld reingesteckt. Ich habe halt wirklich alles umgebaut. Der war tief, der war breit, der war laut, der hat eine mega Anlage drin gehabt. Das einzige Karosserietal, das nicht umgebaut war, war das Dach. Ansonsten jedes Karosserietal umgebaut. Stoßstange vorne, hinten ist klar. Die Kotflügel verbreitert vorne den Lufteinlass. Dann hast du dir vom VW T3, im Seitenblech haben die einen Lufteinlass, so Luftritzen drin. Da gibt es so ein Blech, da ist das quasi schon eingearbeitet. Das bestellst du dir. Dann schneidest du in den Kotflügel, schneidest du das aus, schweißt es rein und lackierst es neu.
Aber das hast du nicht selber gemacht.
Nein, das habe ich nicht selber gemacht. Völlig Banane, als wenn das auch nur ansatzweise was bringen würde, aber es hilft halt so. Und dann haust du den K&N Sportluftfilter rein, dann eine komplett neue Abgasanlage, die Türen verändert, weil der Golf hat diese Bügel-Türgriffe und die vom Audi, wo du so drunter greifst, quasi diese Klappen, die sind ja viel cooler, weil die sind halt auch eben. Das heißt, auch da wieder wurde ausgeschnitten, eingeschweißt und lackiert.
Das war ja sogar eine Audi 80, oder?
Ja, das waren die Audi 80-Türgriffe. Also, meine dunkle Scheiben der Klassiker. Wenn ich meine Bassbox voll aufgedreht habe, hüpfte das Auto und habe da gebastelt und neue Spiegel vom M3, weißt du, diese Sportspiegel, dann mit Blinker, das waren damals die allerersten. Da gibt es tatsächlich Fotos von, die sind auf meinem Handy, die habe ich noch nicht veröffentlicht. Tief, also extrem tief, vorne und hinten eine Luma-Verspoilerung, den Tunern unter deinen Hörern wird das was sagen. Sah schon ziemlich böse aus. Böser Blick, Golf-4 Schachtwerfer, Grill ohne VW-Emblem.
Wie viele schlecht gemachte böse Blicke ich bei mir auf dem Schulparkplatz hatte, ehrlich gesagt. Weil da haben die meisten noch selber geschraubt. Und den kannst du so versauen, den bösen Blick, wenn das Spaltmaß nicht ordentlich passt.
Komplett versauen. Aber ich muss sagen, meine Werkstatt war gut. Ich hatte zuerst natürlich – der Klassiker ist, du steigst mit so einer Plastikleiste ein, die nur drunter geklebt, drunter geschraubt wird. Und später haben sie die Motorhaube verlängert. Wirklich Metallstück, entsprechend zugeschnitten und dann dran geschweißt. Das sah auch gut aus. Gold-Vier-Scheinwerfer, Grill ohne Emblem. Ja, erstes MP3-Radio damals von Sony waren die allerersten. Und das Gute daran war, du konntest die Farbe des Displays verändern.
Das kenne ich sogar. Ja, das war stark. Das hatte, glaube ich, mein Bruder später.
Dann habe ich das geholt und natürlich Sport-Sitze oder? Nein, ich hatte die, also die Sitze waren dann Serie. Ich hatte einen 1, 8 Liter mit 75 PS. Ich rede mir ein, dass durch die Auspuffanlage und den Sportluftfilter mindestens 80 PS.
Und die Displayfarbe war natürlich blau, oder? Weil das war ja Golf. Blau macht glücklich. Die Delphin-Werbung. Nee, die war mit 4.
Im 4er war sie blau, beim 3er war es grün. Aber ich hatte halt einen MP3-Radio, wo auf einer CD, ich weiß nicht, 180 Liter oder so was draufpassen. Weil damals war Napster ja noch legal. Also zumindest nicht illegal.
Ich war noch nicht offiziell illegal.
Ich möchte den… Ach Gott, das war ein Zeitpunkt.
Wir wurden noch nicht bestraft für Napster.
Nee, das stimmt.
Rechtsfreier Raum nannte man das.
Zu dem Zeitpunkt, ja.
Also ok, du hast auch manches von deinem Geld dann weniger gewinnbringend, nur lustgebringend investiert in Autos.
Ja, also der Golf 3 war nicht gewinnbringend. Aber ich hab's einfach gemacht.
Aber das war ja auch dahingehend nur der Anfang allen Übels quasi, oder?
Das war der Anfang allen Übels. Ich bin dann irgendwann hingegangen und hab mir ein Audi, das war dann mein erster Audi, ein Audi A3 bestellt. Neufahrzeug damals. Ich muss aber sagen, den habe ich immer noch. Das ist immer noch das Auto, mit dem ich jeden Tag rumfahre. Der hat jetzt über 400.000 Kilometer.
Fünftaste gepostet, ja.
Also das war eine Investition, die sich heute tatsächlich auch noch lohnt. Toi, toi, toi, dass der noch ein bisschen hält. Weil das war damals natürlich mit 19 dann, kurz vorm 20. März 2003, hat der erst Zulassung, das weiß ich, noch 32.000 Euro gekostet. Das war dann schon ein geiles Auto. Also für 19-Jährige war das ein überragendes Auto. Also Audi gab es in der Gegend dann gar nicht, also für Leute in dem Alter. Das war ganz kurz vor dem Modellwechsel zu dem neuen A3 damals, für die Kenner unter uns, der Wechsel vom 8L zum 8P-Modell.
War das nicht sogar einer der ersten A3 damals?
Doch, das war also das Facelift vom ersten A3. Der erste kam 1996 bis 2001 oder 1998 bis 2001. Und von 2001 bis 2003 war dann die PA – jetzt fange ich auch schon an wie so Konzernmitarbeiter – PA heißt Produktaufwertung, Facelift im normalen Sprache, also quasi so eine Modellpflege. Und 2, 3 kamen dann der ganz Neue, das war dann der erste, der ein bisschen eckiger war.
War das der erste, den es mit Sportback gab?
Das war dann der, aber ich habe noch den Alten genommen, weil beim Neuen gab es noch keine Ausstattung. Damals war es halt noch so, dass du beim Modell-Eichführung quasi – du hattest keine Leda-Ausstattung. Ich hatte wirklich dann meine Recaro-Sport-Sitze drin aus dem Audi S3. Ich hatte damals noch TV und Navi und ich weiß noch, willst du ein Licht- und Regensensor, was ich heute – ich finde das wahnsinnig praktisch. Natürlich kann ich das auch selber, aber es ist halt praktisch, wenn du es einmal benutzt hast. Und ich weiß noch, wie ich zu Patrick damals sagte, dem Verkäufer, ich sagte, quatsch, Licht und Regen kann ich auch selber steuern. Das ist so das Einzige, wo ich mich nachher melde und sage, ja, was heißt fehlen? Also das ist natürlich, dass ich jetzt jammere auf allerhöchstem Niveau.
So wie damals keinen elektrischen Scheibenheber oder so zu haben. So selbstverständlich ist es heute fast.
Die hatte ich dann aber schon. Aber wenn du wirklich mal mit so was unterwegs bist und das über Jahre kennst, dann ist es schon praktisch. Aber das nur als kleine Randmodizia. Und dann kam halt mein erster eigener Audi im März 2003. Und dann sind wir nach Kasachstan geflogen, um jetzt mal den sportlichen Turn zu kriegen. Dann sind wir im Mai, Juni nach Kasachstan geflogen mit der Mittelrheinauswahl, weil wir den Länderpokal gewonnen haben. Und da habe ich mich das erste Mal schwerer verletzt. Da habe ich in Kasachstan zwei Spiele gespielt. Übrigens toll, dass ich mal da war. Privat wäre ich da wahrscheinlich nie hingekommen. Und habe mir das Innenband im rechten Knie gerissen und das war für mich zu dem Zeitpunkt ein Untergang, weil es war scheiße. War einfach scheiße. Die erste schwere Verletzung in jungen Jahren und wir haben darüber gesprochen, nicht ganz einfachen Zeit. Und ich wollte dann mit der neuen Saison, sollte alles besser werden und dann startet das so. Und dann gab es ein bisschen Knatsch mit Jörg Berger zu dem Zeitpunkt und dann war halt das Ding, okay, wir leihen ihn aus. Und dann rief mein Berater an und sagte, du pass auf, ich habe, du sollst nach, ich organisiere dir mal zwei, drei Probetrainings und dann schauen wir, wie es weitergeht. Und mein erstes Probetraining, nachdem ich dann wieder fit war, war bei SVW. Damals nur W. Die waren in die Regionalliga aufgestiegen und mittrainiert, aber Trainer waren nicht so wirklich überzeugt. Dann bin ich zu Schalke 04 gefahren, habe ein Probetraining, also bei der U23 von Schalke 04 gemacht, Mike Biskins war von oben mit dabei, der hat dann so spielender Co-Trainer oder sowas gemacht. Da habe ich Mike das erste Mal kennengelernt, Kleppinger war, glaube ich, Trainer und da habe ich dann eigentlich überzeugt. Die Schalker sagten, ja, das gefällt uns. Weiß noch, wir haben da auf so einem Nebenplatz zwischen, glaube ich, jetzt im Nachhinein, meine ich, das ist der Trainingsplatz der Profis zwischen Parkstadion und Felddienstarena ist so ein Nebenplatz halt und haben dann da drauf trainiert und das lief sehr ordentlich. Die wollten mich dann halt mitnehmen ins Trainingslager und dann kam aber noch der Anruf von Harald Gärtner. Jetzt schließt sich so ein bisschen der Kreis oder da öffnete er sich. Ich soll doch auch nach Hamburg, die waren gerade von der ersten in die zweite und von der zweiten in die dritte Liga durchgereicht worden. Damals war die dritte Liga die Regionalliga Nord, war zweigeteilt Regionalliga Nord und Süd. Waren durchgereicht worden. Ja, also Harald Gärtner, Co-Trainer von Franz Gerber beim FC St. Pauli, waren durchgereicht worden in die damalige Regionalliga Nord, zweieinhalb Millionen Millionen Schulden, wir kennen alle mit Retter und bla und hier und bin dann nach Hamburg gefahren und habe dann da meine drei, vier Einheiten gemacht, noch in der Saisonvorbereitung und Harald sagte, ja, machen wir. Und dann war halt, okay, gehst du jetzt zum FC St. Pauli oder gehst du zur Schalke 04? Das war jetzt meine Überlegung, also die Überlegung, die ich hatte mit meinem Vater und meinem Berater. Ich muss gestehen und das habe ich aber schon den St. Pauli-Fans offenbart, zu dem Zeitpunkt hatte ich keine Ahnung, wer St. Pauli ist. Also ich wusste, dass es ein Fußballverein ist, ich habe zwei Jahre vorher tierisch über sie geschimpft, weil sie die Bayern besiegt haben, aber wusste nichts, um das, was den Verein und drumherum einfach auszeichnet und ausmacht. Davon hatte ich keine Ahnung, weil ich keine Berührungspunkte mit dem hohen Norden hatte. Ich wusste, dass Hamburg eine schöne Stadt ist. Ich weiß noch, als ich das Probetraining gemacht habe, rief ich meinen besten Kumpel an, der ein paar Wochen vorher das erste Mal in Hamburg war und so total verruft war. Ich bin auf der Reeperbahn, ich laufe hier gerade rum, hier sind ganz viele Frauen, so völlig… Du kommst halt vom Dorf. Ich komme ja nicht aus Aachen, das sind 15 Kilometer von Aachen. Basweiler hat 25.000 Einwohner und Setterich, wo ich danach gewohnt habe, ist halt ein Stadtteil, der hat 6, 7, 8.000 und dann kommst du nach Hamburg und läufst über die Reeperbahn und bist mal ganz wagemutig und gehst durch die Herbertstraße.
Du krasser Typ.
Ich habe mich ganz verruft gefühlt und hatte ihn halt angerufen, ich bin ja auf der Reeperbahn, ja war ich auch und war so da und hier und Sexshop, kante man ja nicht vom Dorf und habe dann überlegt, okay was machst du. Insofern, ich konnte das halt in der Dimension nicht einschätzen. Habe mich dann aber für St. Pauli entschieden.
Das waren jetzt aber nicht gerade auch die Gründe, warum du dich für St. Pauli entschieden hast.
Nein, es war einfach so, dass St. Pauli sicherer war in Form von bei Schalke hätte ich nochmal ins Trainingslager mitgemusst und dann quasi die Finale Entscheidung. So und bei St. Pauli war klar, machen wir. Dann ging es halt nur noch um die Modalitäten. Ich hatte noch zwei Jahre Vertrag in Aachen. St. Pauli sagte, lass uns mal bis zum 30.8. warten, weil die hatten halt wirklich kein Geld.
Aber der Ursprung, der Ursprungsgedanke war eine Laie oder war da schon…
Von Aachen aus eine Laie. Jörg Berger war es völlig egal. Der sagte einfach nur, guck, dass wir den loswerden. Und Jörg Schmatke hat immer darauf bestanden und das habe ich ihm immer hoch angerechnet, hat immer gesagt, nein, ich will den Jungen nur ausleihen, der hat Potenzial. Er wollte immer die Option haben, mich zurückzuholen. Nur da war St. Pauli nicht mitglücklich und mein Berater hat ihm dann anscheinend auch klargemacht, so nach dem mal, du pass auf, euer Trainer will den nicht, lass ihn gehen. So und da hat Jörg Schmatke dann in meinem Sinne entschieden – ja, Jörg Schmatke, und nochmal, da danke ich ihm auch heute für – hat er in meinem Sinne entschieden und gesagt, alles klar, machen wir. Keine Ablösesumme geflossen, Vertrag ganz normal klassisch aufgelöst, dann den Vertrag bei St. Pauli unterschrieben und da bin ich halt auch dem Verein und auch Harald Gärtner froh, weil das, was wir zuerst dann im Vertrag fixiert hatten an Gehalt, puh, das war schon war sehr dürftig und dann haben sie von sich aus, pass auf übrigens, wir haben nochmal 500 Euro draufgelegt. Das war weniger als das, was ich in Aachen hatte. Wir haben nochmal 500 Euro draufgelegt, was dann, ja, es war dann okay, sagen wir mal, es war okay. Es war nicht viel, weil das hat der Verein, das hat es einfach nicht hergegeben in der Situation, aber es war okay. Und das war für mich dann gefühlt eigentlich so der Schritt in den, okay, jetzt bist du im Profifußball, jetzt musst du, weil ich dann, ich war weg von zu Hause. Neue Stadt, neuer Verein, du bist jetzt nicht nur dieser Nachwuchsspieler, sondern… Genau.
Du musst dir auch sofort helfen, weil nicht so, dass das rosige Zeiten da waren in allen Hinsichten.
Absolut nicht. Und dann haben wir halt den August noch gewartet, weil dann mussten sie mich im August nicht bezahlen. Lief halt den August noch als Probespieler und den Transfer dann am 30.8. quasi offiziell bekanntgegeben, fixiert. Und dann war ich ab 1.9. war ich Spieler des FC St. Pauli. Am 2.9. wurde ich 20 Jahre alt. Und dann ging es eigentlich los mit der Saison. Erstmal auf der Bank, aber habe dann relativ schnell mir da einen Platz erspielt, gut erkämpft. Damals noch mit Libero unter Jörg… Franz Gerber, der ja noch mit Libero und Mannecker spielte. Die meiste Zeit Mannecker, ab und zu habe ich auch Libero gespielt. Und erst dann mit dem Wechsel zu Andreas Bergmann im Januar, Februar 2004 nach einer Niederlagenserie, als Gerber und Gärtner dann entlassen wurden, dann auf Viererkette umgestellten Innenverteidigern gespielt und dann liefen zwei, drei Jahre ganz ordentlich.
Ja, so kurz kommen wir über St. Pauli nicht rum. Du hast jetzt im Milan-Ton, da warst du ja jetzt erst vor wenigen Tagen zu Gast, kann ich auch sehr empfehlen. Die Saisonvorschau-Folge wurde auch eben über deine Zeit nochmal kurz gesprochen. Da hast du gesagt, dass du mit den Schulden angesprochen hast und dass du damals nicht mehr hättest als ein paar Bälle und irgendwie 14 Spieler. Ja, wie war denn da die Anfangszeit und wann hast du denn zum ersten Mal auch verstanden, dass St. Pauli ein etwas anderer Verein ist?
Sportlich war es schwierig, insofern, dass es nicht immer klar war, wie es natürlich weitergeht. Klar gab es die Retterkampagne und dann war ja das Schlimmste irgendwie abgewendet, aber trotzdem, die Geschäftsstelle waren irgendwie drei Container so übereinander gestellt, das Stadion in keinem guten Zustand, aber trotzdem immer voll. Die Bedingungen waren nicht unbedingt immer optimal, aber wir haben halt schnell gelernt, zu improvisieren und mit den Gegebenheiten einfach umzugehen. Da hat Holger Stanislavski damals schon einen ganz großen Einfluss gehabt, der offiziell noch Spieler war, aber aufgrund eines Innenmantrisses nicht aktiv teilnehmen konnte am Training. Aus der gesamten Mannschaft war auch nur noch Gruszka aus der Zweitligamannschaft, der dann auch in der Regionalligamannschaft noch da war. Und durch ihn habe ich eigentlich gemerkt, was in diesem Verein möglich ist. In den ersten Wochen und Monaten, weil immer wenn Grusche auf dem Platz stand, sind die Leute komplett durchgedreht, die haben ihn gefeiert wie ein Volkshelden. Und ich bin ehrlich, ich habe mir gewünscht, das auch zu schaffen. Dass wenn ich auf den Platz gehe, dass die Leute genauso abgehen, wie sie es bei ihnen tun. Und das haben wir uns alle als Vorbild genommen, weil das einfach sehr beeindruckend war. Und wir natürlich auch an der Resonanz gemerkt haben, dass die Leute am Anfang schon skeptisch waren. Aber wir, und da hat der Verein, finde ich, auch ein bisschen Glück gehabt, in der Zusammenstellung der Spieler, sehr schnell gemerkt haben, worauf es ankommt. Also wir haben beileibe keinen großen Fußball gespielt. Wenn du die Leute fragst, die damals im Stadion waren, das war zum Teil gruselig. Aber man konnte uns in den seltensten Fällen vorwerfen, dass wir nicht wollten. Dass wir es nicht zumindest versucht und gemacht haben und uns gewehrt haben. Und das erste Jahr dann den Klassenerhalt relativ frühzeitig mit dem schlechtesten Spielmann in meiner Karriere in Neumünster klargemacht – gar nicht mal so sehr, was meine eigene Leistung angeht. Sondern dieses Spiel war einfach nur gruselig. Es war so schlecht. Wenn ihr Menschen quälen wollt, dann zwingt sie, dieses Spiel zu gucken. Ich glaube, davon gibt es gar keine Aufzeichnung. Das ist so ein selbstlöschendes Tape. Das kann gar nicht auf CD gebrannt werden. Das funktioniert nicht. Das war einfach furchtbar. Und wir haben 1-0 in Neumünster gewonnen, das Tor, ich habe einen langen Ball, Freistoß von der Mittellinie, hoch und weit in 16er und Fabian Boll im Liegen mit dem Kopf, der Schulter, der Hüfte und dem Knie. Patrick Borger auf die Hüfte, der bei Neumünster im Tor stand und der Ball trudelte ins Tor. Und das waren gefühlt sechs Grad und der Regen kam quer runter und es war kalt. Und Neumünster hatte damals eine kleine Links-Rechts-Schwäche. Das war natürlich auch für unsere Fans sehr schön, in Anführungsstrichen natürlich schön. Also das ganze Spiel war auf Scheiße aufgebaut. Und so war es auch, aber wir haben es halt gewonnen. Und den ersten Draht eingehend auf die Frage, wann ich gemerkt habe, dass da mehr hintersteckt, war dann so ganz intensiv im Januar, also nach vier, fünf Monaten. Ich hatte eine rote Karte im letzten Spiel vor der Winterpause gegen Wattenscheid. Herr Witticek hat sich fallen lassen, ich bleibe dabei. In dem Fall hat Guido Winkenmann mir damals rot gegeben. Und dementsprechend war ich gesperrt. Und es hieß, Ralf, dann fahr doch mal mit den Fans im Sonderzug nach Münster. Preusen Münster. Ich so, ja, okay, mache ich einfach mal. Und saß halt da so ganz unbedarft im Zugabteil und kaum einer kannte mich.
Und wer hat das gesagt? Vereinführung?
Das kam von Christoph Hafer, kam damals dem Pressesprecher, Teammanager. Damals war ja alles eine Position. Also das war nicht so extrem aufgeteilt vom Personale, wie es heute ist. Und dann bin ich nach Münster mitgefahren und da sind wir dann auch wieder an dem Punkt, was wir eben hatten, wo ich unheimlich froh über meine Zeit als Fan in der Kurve bin. Dass ich genau weiß, auch wie Fans fühlen und was sie zum Teil auf sich nehmen und was sie empfinden und was sie eigentlich wollen. Ich kenne auch die andere Seite. Und ich saß dann da im Zugabteil etwas schüchtern, wie Mike jetzt im Nachhinein erzählen würde. Und zufällig, wie es halt so läuft, sitzt der Übersteiger neben mir und der Fanclub die Feuchten Biber. Ihr lacht, das ist der elitärste, beste und tollste Fanclub des FC St. Pauli Kosmos. Liegt auch daran, dass ich da Mitglied bin, aber das ist ein anderes Thema. Nein, die hatten mich dann angesprochen. Dann war Sandra noch, die jetzt im Aufsichtsrat sitzt beim FC St. Pauli, der Herr Hollywood. Ich weiß jetzt nicht, ob es die alle möchten, dass ich die Klarnamen nenne. Und habe halt zu denen erst einen Kontakt gehabt. Bin halt mit denen dann nie nach Münster gefahren, gelabert und dies und das. Und aus dem Kontakt ist dann tatsächlich ein größerer Kontakt in die Fanszene an sich entstanden. Und da immer mehr das Gefühl gehabt, das ist mehr als wir schauen uns 90 Minuten Fußball an, klatschen ein bisschen und fahren dann wieder nach Hause. Was aber auch dem entspricht, wie ich einfach auch erzogen wurde und was man mir dann mitgegeben hatte. Meine Lieblingsanekdote ist, dass es ein Spiel in, ich weiß gar nicht, ob es Öding war oder es müsste Öding gewesen sein. Ich stand am Zaun und wollte Autogramme noch als Kind Jugendlicher und habe gerufen und keiner kam. Und der einzige, der sich umgedreht hat, war Thorsten Fink. Thorsten Fink ist dann den Weg, das waren nur ein paar Meter, bevor er in den Bus gestiegen ist, an den Zaun gekommen und hat mein Trikot unterschrieben. Und allein dieser Weg, den er auf sich genommen hat, hat mich als kleinen Jungen einfach so unglaublich glücklich gemacht, dass ich jetzt ein Autogramm von meinem großen Idol habe, das ich mir immer gesagt habe und mir dann mein Vater das auch immer mitgegeben hat. Denk an den Moment, wie du dich gefühlt hast und solltest du mal in der Situation sein, denk einfach nur dran zurück. Und dann weißt du schon, wie du handeln musst, was du tun musst. Das sind so Momente, die mich dann für später einfach sehr geprägt haben. Mir hat es dann sehr gefallen, wie viel du eigentlich als Spieler auch neben dem Platz zurückgeben kannst. Und das gerade bei einem Verein wie St. Pauli, wo das Sportliche nicht immer das Wichtigste ist. Da sind dann anscheinend zwei Dinge zusammengekommen, die zueinander gepasst haben. Deswegen habe ich mich auch in ganz vielen anderen Bereichen immer sehr interessiert gezeigt, engagiert gezeigt und fand es immer toll, was auch immer tun zu können. Ich habe die Gespräche gesucht. Ich erinnere mich an ein Spiel gegen Kiel, das wir 2-1 verloren haben. Wir hatten vier, fünf Niederlagenfolge und die Stimmung im Stadion war komplett beschissen. Das war danach. Es passiert selten, dass beim FC St. Pauli gepfiffen wird, aber die Zuschauer hatten wirklich die Schnauze voll. Natürlich auch wieder im Kontext, was ist zwei Jahre vorher passiert. Wieder die Angst, rutschen wir jetzt wieder ganz unten rein und und und. Ich weiß nicht, ob ich es heute wieder tun würde in dem Alter, aber ich habe mich dann mit 20, ich war gerade ein paar Wochen da, habe mich auf den Zaun gestellt. Das war die alte Mekka-Ecke, da stand früher USP. Das war auf der Gegend geraden, wenn du von Platzseite aus guckst, ganz rechts. Also der Durchgang war ja so halt.
Da musste man immer vorbei, ne?
Genau. Genau. Und da bin ich dann hin und habe versucht, den Leuten klarzumachen oder habe sie versucht, wieder ins Boot zu holen. Das war jetzt nur ein paar Dutzend, die dann nach dem Spiel noch da standen, aber ich habe versucht, sie ins Boot zu holen, weil das ist so meine Philosophie des Ganzen. Am Ende des Tages, auch wenn es heutzutage Gott sei Dank keine Zäune mehr gibt, aber auf beiden Seiten des Zauns arbeiten wir in die gleiche Richtung. Wir wollen ja im Prinzip beide nur das Beste für die Mannschaft, für den Verein. Und natürlich haben wir auf dem Platz einen wesentlich größeren Einfluss darauf, ob das Spiel gewonnen wird oder nicht. Aber ich habe versucht, den Leuten einfach klarzumachen, dass man uns die Aufgabe viel, viel leichter macht und dass man uns viel mehr unterstützt, wenn man uns unterstützt und wenn man uns nicht auspfeift. Ich bleibe dabei, das vertrete ich auch weiterhin, dass in den 90 Minuten die Mannschaft unterstützt gehört. Man kann sich immer danach noch hinsetzen. Heutzutage ist es leider etwas schwieriger, an die Spieler ranzukommen. Aber den Dialog suchen und den klar machen, dass das so und so auf – bitte nicht. Aber in den 90 Minuten – und das wollte ich einfach da nochmal transportieren. Ich weiß nicht, ob das überhaupt wirklich viel erreicht hat, aber ich habe schon auch die Jahre danach so ein bisschen Rückmeldung auf dieses Gespräch bekommen. Mir ging es darum, klarzumachen, dass wir von der Mannschaft aus gewillt sind, alles dafür zu tun, dass der Verein nicht nochmal absteigt, dass wir den maximalen Erfolg haben. Das war zu dem Zeitpunkt nicht viel, aber das, was wir rausholen können, wir euch oder die Fans halt brauchen. Das waren alles so zwei, drei, vier, fünf Erlebnisse, Momente, in denen ich gemerkt habe, zum einen, was für Möglichkeiten du als Spieler über die 90 Minuten hinaus hast. Zum anderen fühle ich mich aber auch verpflichtet. Einfach aufgrund meiner eigenen Erfahrung. Weil ich weiß, wie es ist, wie man nur mit kleinen Dingen Menschen glücklich machen kann. Ihnen ein neues Fünktchen Glauben an die Sache geben kann. Wie man sich vielleicht in ganz beschissenen Momenten noch abholen kann und sagen, ey, pass auf, aber ich kann dir versprechen, wenn ich nächste Woche hier auf dem Platz stehe, dann laufen wir wieder. Und das war, glaube ich, eine Wechselwirkung von Fans, Schrägstrich-Fans-Szene und meinem Verhalten, das sich da, wie ich finde, schon eine ordentliche Beziehung aufgebaut hat.
Du saßt ja auch definitiv bei den richtigen Leuten im Zug, also an alle, die vorhin bei Mike nicht gleich wussten, wer gemeint ist. Ette, der Übersteiger, der unter anderem den Milan Ton Podcast macht. Was mich aber noch interessieren würde, das ist ja so ein Nebenaspekt noch. Du hast es wohl nur ganz kurz angerissen, zum ersten Mal von zu Hause weg in Hamburg, in eine eigene Stadt. Wo hast du denn gewohnt und wie hast du es denn geschafft, dich in der Stadt zurechtzufinden?
Ich bin also nicht ganz alleine. Meine damalige Freundin ist mitgekommen nach Hamburg. Und ich bin froh, dass sie es – also im Nachhinein jetzt – bin ich froh, dass sie – das klingt jetzt auch doof – im Nachhinein bin ich froh. Damals war ich auch froh, weil sie mir geholfen hat, mal zu leben. Also wenn ich alleine eine Wohnung hätte schmeißen müssen, das hätte niemals funktioniert. Ich habe es noch nie mal geschafft mit meinem Zimmer. Wie soll ich es dann mit einer Wohnung, inklusive Behördengänge und alles, was dazugehört? Also es war halt auch so ein Schritt ins Erwachsenwerden. Ich bin in der Zeit auch persönlich unheimlich gereift. Wo haben wir gewohnt? Ja, wenn ich das jetzt sage, dann werden alle St. Pauli-Fans die Hände über den Kopf zusammenschlagen und das passt halt mal wieder gar nicht, aber ich habe in Blankenese gewohnt. Sie wollte damals in den Hamburger Westen, was ich aber auch mitgetragen habe, verstanden habe, weil es ist, finde ich, es ist schön grün, es ist ruhig. Ich brauche diese Action, zum Beispiel der Schanze oder so etwas. Oder Eimsbüttel, das brauche ich nicht. Es ist schön, da hinzufahren, aber wohnen möchte ich lieber ruhig. Das war bis jetzt in allen Städten so, dass ich immer nicht direkt im Zentrum gewohnt habe, sondern minimal außerhalb und über die Elbschossi bist du ja in 15, 20 Minuten, warst du dann sowieso in der Stadt. Also haben wir da eine kleine Zwei-Zimmer-Wohnung gehabt. Das sind 50, 55 Quadratmeter. Und da hatte ich eine ganz, ganz große Unterstützung, was die Einrichtung angeht. Einkaufen, also wirklich so die ganz trivialen Dinge des Alltags. Natürlich hätte ich das auch irgendwann selbst alleine gelernt, aber es war trotzdem gut, diese Unterstützung zu haben. Also ich habe da wirklich so ein Soft-Opening ins Erwachsenwerden von Elternhaus mit Freundin zusammen und dann erst alleine gewohnt. Also wir haben uns dann nach anderthalb Jahren oder sowas in Hamburg getrennt, sich dann zurück nach Aachen zu ihrer Familie. Und dann habe ich halt das erste Mal dann auch alleine gewohnt.
Und das Sportliche? Du hast ja schon angerissen, wie die Ausgangssituation war und dass alles nicht ganz so einfach war. Und wie das alles in der ersten Saison zu Ende ging mit einem auf Scheiße gebauten Spiel.
Ja.
Ging ja nicht nur so weiter.
Nein, also das zweite Jahr war ein relativ durchwachsendes Jahr. Für mich persönlich ein gutes Jahr. Aber jetzt, was den Mannschaftserfolg angeht, ein durchwachsendes Jahr. Das dritte Jahr wurde dann spannend. Also das zweite können wir wirklich relativ schnell skippen. Da gibt es nur ein, zwei erwähnenswerte Dinge. Wie das Spiel gegen Chemnitz. Also auf einmal der Chemnitz-Block. Also nicht Block fahren, aber so Doppelhalter ausrollte. In rotes Viereck mit einem weißen Kreis drauf. Es fehlte halt nur noch das verfassungswidrige Symbol. Und dann wäre das komplett gewesen. Und da ist das Stadion halt komplett steil gegangen.
Also es war in Hamburg?
Es war in Hamburg im Gästeblock. Dann haben Sven Brucks, der damalige Sicherheitsbeauftragte und ich glaube Heiko Schlesemann vom Fanladen, die haben dann den Block räumen lassen. Und dann gab es halt nach dem Spiel auf der Budapester vor dem Millantor standen halt links zwei Wasserwerfer, rechts zwei Wasserwerfer. Eingekessel die Chemnitzer. Und St. Pauli-Fans wollten natürlich an die ran. Und ich bin beim Rausfahren, denke ich mir, was ist denn hier los? Weil das hatten wir halt nicht mehr richtig im Stadion, das hatten wir natürlich mitbekommen, aber das hatten wir nicht mehr richtig mitbekommen. Und parkte mein Auto an der Seite und stell mich in die erste Reihe, stehe vor dem Wasserwerfer, guck hoch und sehe meinen Präsidenten da drin. Corny Littmann sitzt im Wasserwerfer und das Ding zeigt halt auf mich. Und ich so, warte mal, das ist doch mein Präsident, was ist denn hier los? Das war von mir keine PR-Aktion. Das ist bei den Fans richtig gut angekommen. Also es gab Resonanz, aber das war für mich kein Oh, jetzt kannst du mal was für deinen Ruf tun, sondern ich wollte wirklich wissen, was ist denn da los und wieso stehen hier Wasserwerfer und mich mal bei den Fans erkundigen, was hier gerade Phase ist. Und auf einmal stand ich halt…
mittendrin.
Aber ich habe nichts abbekommen, weil es dann doch relativ ruhig war, weil die St. Pauli-Fans dann von der Polizei zurückgehalten wurden und die Chemnitzer dann in Bussen abtransportiert wurden. Das war aber ein lustiges Erlebnis. Also das war schon jetzt im Nachhinein lustig. In dem Moment fand ich das komisch, dass mein Präsident im Polizeifahrzeug mir gegenüber steht.
Wurde das später noch mal thematisiert von ihm?
Nein. Ich glaube auch nicht, dass er mich gesehen hat, aber ich kann mir die Perspektive aus einem Wasserwerfer nicht vorstellen. Ich glaube, du siehst einfach nur eine Masse vor dir. Also gerade als Ungeübter. Polizisten haben da eine andere Ausbildung. Die können dann schon auch Einzelleitender kennen. Aber als Ungeübter, glaube ich, siehst du nur eine Gruppe vor dir und nicht zwingt den Einzelnen. Es wurde natürlich thematisiert, warum Corny Littmann als Präsident in einem Wasserwerfer sitzt. Aber das war jetzt – ja, Corny war sowieso sehr kontrovers. Auch was die Wahrnehmung in der Fernsehszene angeht. Insofern gab es da eh viele Diskussionen.
Aber du hast es während des Spiels schon mitbekommen. Das ist ja immer so eine berühmte Frage. Wie viel kriegt man auf dem Platz?
Ja, doch. Das kriegst du natürlich mit, weil ich diese Doppelhalter gesehen habe.
Wird man da nicht wahnsinnig wütend auch auf dem Platz?
Natürlich. Du siehst ja sofort, worum es da geht. Nicht alle auf einmal Fans von Japan und vertauschen nur die Farben oder deutsches Rotes Kreuz oder sowas. Der Block wurde nicht geräumt. Es stand zur Debatte, weil ich sehr aktiv auch damals im St. Pauli Fanforum unterwegs war.
Unter Klarnamen?
Unter Klarnamen. Die Leute wussten, dass ich das bin. Ganz normal unter Ralph Gunesch. Auch da übrigens sehr viel Strömung aus der Fanszene immer wieder mitbekommen. Ich weiß, es ging darum, dass der Block geräumt werden soll. Das haben sie nicht gemacht. Aber Sven Brooks ist rein als Sicherheitsbeauftragter und hat zumindest die Fahnen entfernt. Das haben sie gemacht. So war es.
Brauchst du auch Eier.
Die hat Sven. Ansonsten ist in dem Jahr nicht mehr so viel Spannendes passiert. Das ging dann erst 2005-2006 los. 2005 waren wir im Trainingslager auf Kuba im zweiten Jahr. Das war auch ganz toll. Das war das Wintertrainingslager.
Habt ihr euch einen neuen Markt erschließen wollen, so wie jetzt die Bayern mit China?
Wir waren tatsächlich die erste europäische Fußballmannschaft, die auf Kuba war. Wir waren 14 Tage auf Kuba im Januar 2005 und hatten sehr viel Spaß. Also wir haben natürlich auch trainiert. Privat weiß ich nicht, ob ich jemals nach Kuba gekommen wäre. Aber auch da wieder eine tolle persönliche Erfahrung. Mal ein ganz anderes Landsystem, wie so ein Land geführt wird, wie es funktionieren kann oder auch nicht. Das vermag jetzt bitte jeder für sich selber beurteilen. Aber wenn du dann halt mitbekommst, dass Einheimische nicht mit dir reden dürfen, oder wenn sie mit dir reden, wurden sie ganz schnell von der Polizei abgeführt. Dann kriegst du halt nochmal einen ganz anderen Blick aufs Leben. Weil das sind ja Dinge, die kann sich keiner von uns wirklich vorstellen. Aber am Anfang gab es da so ein Briefing, so nach dem Motto, Leute, pass auf, hier laufen so ein paar Dinge ein bisschen anders als ihr das vielleicht kennt. Und haben es dann auch am eigenen Leib erfahren, dass Menschen, die sich mit uns unterhalten haben, auf der Straße, da kamen dann zwei und haben die abgeführt. Also wir durften da wirklich nur mit Dolmetschern unterwegs sein. Für uns bestand keine Gefahr.
Trotzdem verstörend.
Ja, es ist verstörend. Ich erinnere mich, das ist natürlich auch – und ich lehne mich nicht so weit aus dem Fenster, wenn ich sage, dass da wirklich auch Propaganda läuft. Wenn du die ganzen… Da gibt es keine Werbung, also keine Werbetafeln im klassischen Sinne, dass für irgendein Produkt geworben wird, sondern auf allen Hauswänden, am Strand die großen Werbeplakate und so, voll mit Plakaten entweder Che Guevara und Fidel Castro als die großen Väter des Landes und und und. Oder die USA als der große Feind. Ich erinnere mich an Bilder, wo du die Fahne der USA, daneben ein Hakenkreuz, und darunter hast du Bilder von Folterszenen, die wir alle kennen, die dann so mit und mit irgendwie durchgesickert sind, wo die Amerikaner in Guantánamo und was weiß ich nicht alles ihre Gefangenen entsprechend behandelt haben. Und das wurde alles genutzt zur Propaganda und das kannten wir halt. Das kennen wir ja aus Deutschland nicht. Diese öffentliche, zur Schaustellung, diese öffentliche Meinungsmache. Und das waren alles ganz, ganz neue Eindrücke. Insofern bin ich froh, da gewesen zu sein oder das mal gesehen zu haben, um auch zu wissen, wie es woanders laufen kann. So, nochmal, es ist ja kein Politikpodcast, ich will das jetzt nicht groß bewerten, aber es war wirklich ein ganz neuer Einblick auf diese ganze Sache. Du hast so verstörend eben gesagt, es verändert schon dein Weltbild.
Direkt zur Entwicklung bei, natürlich.
Du siehst, dass nicht alles selbstverständlich ist, was man selbst immer so in dem System, in dem man aufgewachsen ist, mit Meinungsfreiheit und so weiter.
Richtig, also das war beeindruckend, aber in ganz neutraler Form, weil es ganz andere Eindrücke sind, die du sonst in deinem normalen sozialen Umfeld wahrscheinlich kaum wirklich mitbekommst. Damals war ja auch das, das war 2005, da war das Internet jetzt auch noch nicht so extrem voll mit sowas, wie du heute ja auf Knopfdruck kannst du ja alles in jede Richtung bekommen. Damals befanden wir uns immer noch, finde ich, in den Anfangstagen des… Das Internet fing gerade so an, mit Inhalten gefüllt zu werden. Also das hatte noch nicht jeder für sich so entdeckt, wie einfach man viele Menschen erreichen kann. Deswegen war das das erste Mal, dass ich mit sowas in Berührung gekommen bin. Und wenn du es nur so kennst, also wenn du nie was anderes gesehen hast, dann kennst du halt nur das.
Das war 2005 im Sommer.
Im Januar.
Im Januar, hast du gesagt, im Winter. Aber das war ja trotz alledem die Saison, wo du sagtest, da war jetzt…
Ja, da ist jetzt nicht mehr so viel passiert. Wir haben zwar nach der Saison irgendwie eine geile Rückrunde gespielt, weil das eine Top-Vorbereitung auf Kuba war.
Ganz offensichtlich. Hat nicht gereicht.
Aber die große Saison kam dann da drauf.
Genau, da kam der große Erfolg auch im Pokal.
Also für uns war das ein Riesenerfolg. Wir hatten viele Spieler, die zum Pokal haben sie immer ihre Zwillingsbrüder geschickt.
Aber die guten Zwillinger.
Will heißen in der Liga hat es gar nicht so gut funktioniert.
Die guten Zwillinger in der Liga, normales Mittelfeld, nichts besonders Großes. Aber es fing ganz gut an, aber dann kam halt der Pokal.
Dann kam der Pokal mit einer bemerkenswerten B-Serie. Kriegst du noch alle Bs zusammen?
Ja, natürlich. Burghausen, Bochum, Berlin, Bremen und dann die Bayern.
Und dann war leider Schluss.
Im Halbfinale, ja. Also zunächst mal überhaupt geil. Halbfinale ist cool. Ich war dann tatsächlich auch beim Finale in Berlin. Und da, also die Enttäuschung am Abend des Spiels war schon groß. Aber als ich dann in Berlin auf der Tribüne saß und da haben wir gedacht, dieses eine Spiel noch, verdammt nochmal und du willst jetzt da unten rumlaufen. Das war schon, es war schon hart. Also das war wirklich hart, weil ich wusste, dass diese Chance wahrscheinlich war.
War das das Finale von Bayern gegen Eintracht Frankfurt dann oder war das ein anderes? Ich weiß nicht, ob ich da gerade die richtige Saison hatte.
Ja, gegen Frankfurt, ja.
Ja, Wahnsinn, wo Olli Kahn in der 86. Minute noch einen Ball aus kürzester Distanz hält.
Das war mir alles völlig egal, weil ich wollte da eigentlich unten rumlaufen. Das wäre wahrscheinlich das Erlebnis meines Lebens gewesen. Aber gut, es sollte nicht sein, aber vielleicht mal die Pokalsaison ein bisschen aufgerollt in die Liga ambitioniert rein. Und dann kam das Pokalspiel gegen Burghausen. Super warm, aber auch da in der Verlängerung das Ding gewonnen. Oh cool, weiter und dann weiter in der Liga, normal gespielt, ganz ordentlich sogar. Dann wurde Bruchum zugeteilt, Tabellenführer, kein Gegentorler, eigentlich der Aufstiegsfavorit der ersten, also der zweiten Liga. Und bei denen lief halt überhaupt nichts zusammen. Es passte einfach nicht. Das war ein Spiel, bei dem bei uns alles passte und bei Bruchum überhaupt nichts. Und es war einfach ein geiler Abend. 4-0, Florian Lechner mit einem schönen Torfloh hat halt auch seinen Zwillingsbruder geschickt, den guten Zwillingsbruder. Wir machen da immer Witze drüber, ich darf das hier auch erzählen, aber ja, es war einfach ein geiler Abend. Und dann, ja, schauen wir mal, was jetzt kommt. So, und dann kam halt Hertha. Hertha BSC, super. Uefa Cup-Teilnehmer damals, wir halt fünfter, sechster, siebter der Regionalliga Nord, kurz vor Weihnachten. Aber spielen wir einfach mal, mal sehen, mal sehen, was da geht. Gegen Pantelic, Marcelinho, Kovac, Samba und Madlung, Fiedler in Tor.
Anne-Friedrich war damals noch mit dabei. Kevin Prinz Boateng wurde eingewechselt bei Hertha und Zecke Neuendorf.
Genau, so und dann steht es nach, korrigier mich bitte, 25, 30 Minuten, 32 oder so was, steht es 2-0 für Hertha. Und wenn du dir das anschaust, wie viele ist was?
40. Okay, dann 40.
Da führt der UEFA Cup-Teilnehmer und Bundesligas, ich habe sie die Woche vorher noch im UEFA Cup im Fernsehen beobachtet, in Anführungsstrichen, ich habe sie mir angeschaut, für 2-0 beim Regionalligisten. Das Ding ist eigentlich 2-0 zur Halbzeit, vielleicht ein drittes und dann ein viertes in der zweiten Halbzeit und dann bis Ruhe. Und dann machen wir halt ganz kurz im Prinzip mit dem Halbzeit-Fiff durch Dinsay noch das 2 zu 1. Und dieses Tor hat uns wirklich am Leben gehalten. Wir sind dann aus der Kabine raus und ich habe mir das Spiel vor ein paar Wochen noch mal angeschaut, schön war das nicht, was wir da gespielt haben. Also das gegen Bochum, das war spielerisch richtig gut. Gegen Hertha, 22. Dezember, das war kein schöner Fußball. Aber wir haben mit wahnsinnig viel Energie gespielt. Wir haben uns nicht abschütteln lassen, auch nicht von einem 0-2. Und haben wahnsinnig – ja, mit Energie ist tatsächlich die beste Formulierung, weil alle anderen würden nicht passen, weil sie würden das dann glorifizieren und so schön machen. Und das war nicht schön. Und machen durch Felix Lutz in der 86. das 2 zu 2. Kurz zur Erklärung, liebe Zuschauer, die beiden haben hier ihre Tablets offen. Ich habe nichts vor mir. Ich erzähle das alles.
Sehr begeistert. Bis auf den 22.
stimmt alles bei 21. Genau, am 22. war das fettes Brotkonzert in der Arena. So war das. Wo wir dann auch alle waren. Und machen dann kurz zu Schluss durch Felix Lutz mit einem schönen Kopfball, das 2 zu 2. Verlängerung. Die Berliner haben 100% komplett abgekotzt. Das war uns natürlich egal. Dann muss ich sagen, auch da wieder, was da in dem Stadion los war, nach dem generell in der zweiten Halbzeit, das war ja das Schöne. Du musstest den Ball nur hoch in die gegnerische Hälfte schlagen und schon war das Publikum da. Also wenn man heute erst so ein bisschen lauter wird, wenn es im 16er ist, bei uns hat es schon gereicht, gegen den Bundesligisten in deren Hälfte zu sein, um die Zuschauer mitzunehmen. Und dann macht Marcelinho was mit einem Freistoß aus 30 Metern. Das 3 zu 2 kriegste den nächsten Nackenschlag. Aber auch da wieder, wir haben gar nicht nachgedacht. Wir haben in dem Spiel nicht nachgedacht. Das war uns völlig egal. Wir machen einfach unser Ding. Natürlich auch von den Zuschauern getrieben.
Ist das dann aber nicht auch so der Klassiker der Regionalligist im DFB-Bukal gegen Bundesligist? Was gibt es zu verlieren?
Ich denke schon. Und da halt von den Zuschauern entsprechend getragen. Ich erinnere mich noch, in der Pause zwischen den 90 Minuten und der Verlängerung hatten wir auf einmal Cola auf dem Platz stehen. Und ich stehe halt mit der Flasche Cola und nehme so drei Schlücke raus und Andreas Bergmann, der Trainer, guckt mich an. So nach dem Motto, trinkt jetzt hier mein Spieler gerade Cola auf dem Platz? Wir können über Cola diskutieren und streiten und das ist nicht gesund, aber für diesen kurzfristigen Energieschub, die ersten Minuten, ist das halt echt gut.
Zucker halt.
Ja, das haut sofort rein und das hat halt wirklich geholfen. Ich trinke halt Cola und weil halt gerade kein anderer da stand, drücke ich die Bergmann in die Hand und sagt, nimm mal bitte mit raus. Den Blick werde ich auch nicht vergessen, wie er mich da angeguckt hat, aber es war halt mehr so nach dem Motto hier in Bayern, sagt man, glaube ich, wenn es schön macht, wenn es halt hilft, dann machst du halt. Dann das 3-2 durch Marcellinio. Für uns aber auch kein Nackenschlag, einfach wir haben unser Ding weiter gemacht. Und dann kam wieder der Florian. Dann kam der Pokallechner und die Szene, die gibt es bei YouTube. Ich habe die DVD zu Hause und ich schaue sie mir. Ich habe sie mir wirklich sehr, sehr oft angeschaut, weil man, wenn man auf die Zuschauer auf der Nord hinter dem Tor achtet. Damals war es so, dass die Gäste waren Südtribüne in der Ecke, also zur Haupttribünenseite hin und die Nord war halt voll mit St. Pauli-Fans. Wenn man einfach auf die Zuschauer achtet, wie sie explodieren in dem Moment, wo der Ball im Netz einschlägt, ist übertrieben, weil einen kullert. Weil Flo hat das Ding mit Unterkrämpfen. Man sieht wirklich, er spielt vorher einen Pass nach außen und ist eigentlich schon auf dem Weg nach hinten humpelnd, hält sich den hinteren Oberschenkel. Irgendwie fällt ihm der Ball dann wieder vor die Füße, beziehungsweise Felix Lutz legt ihm den Ball vor und er, für einen kurzen Moment – keine Ahnung, wie ein Körper das macht – für einen kurzen Moment sämtliche Krämpfe aus seinem Körper weichen, er sich auf diesen Schuss konzentriert. Wirklich, der war nicht feste. Das war so ein Holberschuss, der noch abgefälscht wird, aber für Fiedler keine Möglichkeit, den zu halten. Geht in die lange Ecke rein und einfach diese – ihr seht es an meiner Gänsehaut – diese diese Ekstase, die dann in diesem Stadion losbricht. Und das kommt auf der DVD. Das ist halt eine Kamera 1 DVD. Nichts geschnittenes, sondern wirklich nur mit der Führungskamera, ohne Kommentar. Das kommt halt so durch. Das merkst du einfach, wie das alles explodiert. Und ich erinnere mich auch noch an die Empfindung in dem Moment, wie es ewig gedauert hat, bis dieser Ball im Tor ist. Das sind keine Sekunden.
Das dauert ewig, ja.
Einsteins Relativitätstheorie passt. Es kommt halt immer darauf an, auf welcher Seite der Toilettentür man steht, wie lange eine Minute sein kann. Die Perspektive auf dem Platz war einfach errollt und er ist drin und wie so in Zeitlupe explodiert das Stadion. Und wie ich jetzt dann auf der DVD gesehen habe, die Leute fallen übereinander her und die Bierbecher fliegen. Und eine Ekstase, das war bei uns genauso. Du weißt in dem Moment gar nicht, wohin. Ja und dann war es immer noch so, dass wir nicht nachgedacht haben. Immer noch dieses einfachen, wir machen einfach, wir spielen einfach. Wir hatten kein Konzept, wir hatten keine Idee, außer hoch und weit. Aber wir machen einfach und wir haben geguckt, dass hinten da nichts anbrennt. Ich meine, mit Pantelitsch hatte ich wirklich genug zu tun. Und dann kommt die 109. Minute, ein unfassbar dummes Falschspiel an der Eckfahne, wenn es überhaupt ein Falschspiel war. Und man kann auch sagen, die Berührung clever mitgenommen. Und dann geht Robert Palikuca zu Johnny Solentich, der den Freistoß schießt, geht hin und sagt, bring ihn auf den zweiten Pfosten. Und auch da erwähne ich wieder diese DVD, die ich zu Hause habe. In dem Moment, wo Johnny Solentich anläuft, hat wohl irgendeiner in der Nähe der Kamera gesagt oder in der Nähe eines Mikrofons, der ist drin. Der Ball war noch nicht geschlagen. Ich glaube, er hat gerade den Ball am Fuß, da sagt er, der ist drin. Und ich stand im 16er und sehe nur den Ball quasi so fliegen, okay, der ist zu weit für dich. Und sehe da nur Robert auf dem zweiten Pfosten wirklich rein fliegen mit seinen 1, 95. Schädelt das Ding rein und meine Gänse haut. Ihr seht es. Er ist einfach – frag mich nicht, was du in solchen Momenten denkst. Du weißt wirklich nicht, wohin. Ich habe auch keine Ahnung, wo ich hingelaufen bin. Ich glaube, ich bin sofort zu Lentige gelaufen, also dem Flankengeber. Ich meine auch, ich bin auch bei dem 2-2 von Felix Lutz zuerst. Ich bin nicht zu Felix, sondern zu Jimmy Dinser rausgelaufen, der die Ecke geschlagen hat. Ich glaube, ich bin zu Johnny gelaufen. Und dann waren es noch zehn Minuten. Und diese zehn Minuten, muss ich sagen, ich habe das auch später noch mal in ein, zwei Spielen gehabt, dass ich hinten drin stand und wirklich – das mag jetzt vermessen klingen, aber in dem Moment denkst du halt wirklich so, in dem Moment bist du in so einem Rausch drin.
Kommt ruhig, spielt die Bälle.
Ihr schießt sowieso kein Tor. So dieses Kampfansage. Jetzt haut mal die langen Bälle hier rein, weil heute köpfe ich sowieso alles raus. Mir ist völlig egal, wer da kommt. Da waren noch ein paar ganz heikle Geschichten mit dabei, wo ich sage, da haben wir gut Glück gehabt. Also Respekt. Also ja, es war wirklich nur noch Abwehrschlacht. Das war nicht schön. Ich habe es angeschaut. Das ist nicht schön gewesen.
Umschwöhnen geht es ja nicht. Vor fast 20.000, 3 zu 2 in der Verlängerung drehen, das ist schön.
Das war nicht schön. Das war einfach nur Wille pur. Und dann habe ich – ja, dann war der Abpfiff natürlich große Freude. Und dann habe ich natürlich ganz, ganz viele Nachrichten halt bekommen. Damals hat man noch SMS bekommen, keine WhatsApp, sondern SMS. Und ich erinnere mich noch an eine SMS von einem aus der Fanszene, ein guter Freund, eigentlich ein Hühne, so 1, 90 breit und alles gut. Und er schrieb nur, ich sitze heulend in der U-Bahn. Ich habe gerade meine Mutter angerufen und ihr gesagt, dass ich sie liebe, aber ich sitze hier heulend in der U-Bahn. Wo du dann einfach merkst, wie glücklich du Menschen eigentlich machen kannst. Das sind wiederum unbezahlbare Momente, die kannst du nicht simulieren. Das kannst du nur mit so etwas irgendwie hinkriegen.
Du kannst uns nicht sagen, wo du zum Jubeln hingelaufen bist, aber du kannst uns auch bestimmt sagen, wie danach gefeiert wurde. Das war am 21. Dezember. Du hast schon ein fettes Brotkonzert gerade erwähnt. Aber da hat man jetzt nicht mehr Trainingsbetrieb vor sich nach so einem Spiel.
Nein, aber wir wurden in der Pause zu sein. Ich glaube, wir waren tatsächlich abends nur noch auf der Schanze im olympischen Feuer. Das war so damals unser Stammlokal und am 22. waren wir von fettes Brot tatsächlich schon im Vorlauf eingeladen zu dem Konzert, in der damals hieß die Arena, glaube ich, also die kleine Halle nebenan, Colorline war das, glaube ich, noch. Genau, Colorline Arena, also diese Multifunktionshalle neben dem aktuell Volksparkstadion. Ja, du lachst, das weiß man ja nicht.
Traditionell AOL Arena.
Ja, genau. So, und da war halt das fettes Brotkonzert und das war auch noch mal schön. Mein Vater war damals auch in Hamburg, hat das erste Mal fettes Brot erlebt. War für ihn, glaube ich, auch eine interessante Erfahrung. Ja, allein zum fettes Brot fallen mir halt auch wieder ein paar geile Anekdoten ein, weil ich meine großen Helden meiner Jugend quasi – jeder kennt, glaube ich, Nordisch bei Nature und Jain. Es geht ja schon los.
Wann?
Ich war 13 Jahre alt, habe damals fettes Brot und Ärzte gehört und irgendwann mal meine damalige Freundin saß dann neben Markus und Markus ist ein Jugendfreund von Boris, eigentlich von allen dreien. Zwei davon haben ja auch eine Dauerkarte am Milantor. Ich bin nach jedem Spiel zu meiner Freundin und wir sind dann am Ende der Runde am Haupttribüne und dann sind wir halt da bei unseren Mädels gewesen. Dann habe ich Markus kennengelernt und irgendwann steht Boris vor mir, so König Boris. Die Brote waren aber lange Zeit so ein bisschen raus. Ich weiß nicht, ob es eine Pause war, aber sie waren nicht so medial vertreten. Und zu dem Zeitpunkt war es halt sieben Jahre her, oder fünf Jahre, dass ich sie wirklich aktiv gehört habe mit allen Niedern damals. Irgendwann denke ich so, Scheiße, woher kennst du den? Das kann doch nicht sein. Zwei, drei Spieltage irgendwann. Ich so, Scheiße. Das ist mir jetzt echt peinlich.
Aber er hat sich nicht vorgestellt, als König Boris.
Nein, das hat er. Es ist mir jetzt echt peinlich. Wobei es mir bei denen, auch zu der Zeit, wo ich sie viel gehört habe, eher um die Musik ging, als um die Jungs selber. Die waren jetzt nicht so optisch präsent, aber die Musik war sehr präsent. Ich meine, die einen kann, glaube ich, fast jeder auf der Zeit irgendwie auswendig. Und dann sagten sie, du, pass auf, wir haben jetzt hier ein Dings unseres neuen Albums und kommst so mit zur Release-Party auf der Cap San Diego. Das ist so ein Veranstaltungsschiff in Hamburg und ein bisschen feiern nach dem Spiel und so. Ja, und dann bin ich dahin und ich habe damals auch die Ärzte gehört und ja, ich würde dir gerne noch jemanden vorstellen. Ich so, ja, cool. Ja, das ist Bela. Ich stehe da wie so ein kleiner Junge vor dem Bela und denke mir so, wow, jetzt werden mir die Menschen vorgestellt und wollen mit mir Fotos und Fragen halt nach dem Autogramm, weil die haben mich dann auch nach einer Autogrammkarte für, keine Ahnung, so ein Nephe, was weiß ich, was gefragt. Ich sag so, ey, das sind die, die ich halt angehimmelt habe. Wegen dieser Leute habe ich Stress mit meinen Eltern gehabt. Die Eltern damals waren nicht die größten Ärzte-Fans. Und jetzt lerne ich Bela kennen und ganz entspannt. Und dann hier, das ist hier von 5 Sterne Deluxe. Und ja, geil, mein Herz schlägt schneller und wow, wo bin ich hier? Und das war so diese kindliche Freude noch. Dass Menschen, die du früher angehimmelt hast und die für dich die Stars waren, dass fast jetzt andersrum läuft und die was von dir wollen und die jetzt quasi dich supporten und dich anfeuern und so. Das waren dann so die kleinen Momente, so die kleinen Seitengeschichten, Nebengeschichten, die halt total spannend und total interessant für mich waren, weil es war für mich einfach eine Ehre. Also da steht Bela vor mir und sagt, ich freue mich, dich kennenzulernen. Ja, das sagt er tausendmal, ist mir schon klar. Aber er ist immer, wenn es geht, bei den Heimspielen und das trifft auch auf Boris zu und und und. Und jetzt auf einmal ist das halt auch so eine Wechselwirkung, wo ich dann natürlich auch gemerkt habe, sind auch alles nur ganz normale Typen und die legen sich auch auf, nachdem wir verloren haben und so. Aber als Jugendlicher siehst du diese Person ja dann doch meistens irgendwie anders. Und ja, es war toll, die kennengelernt zu haben und über die Zeit ist es dann auch bei mir dann natürlich auch so ein bisschen dieser Star-Kult, dieser Personenkult, so ein bisschen dem, okay, wir kennen uns auf privater Ebene, sind jetzt nicht beste Freunde, aber man hat halt Kontakt und wenn man sich sieht, freut man sich und redet und man kennt sich. Und coole Leute und das hat sich dann so ein bisschen relativiert. Aber das Kennenlernen war oftmals so, kleiner Fanboy steht daneben und freut sich, Bela kennenzulernen. Wie sind wir da hingekommen?
Vor allem war das nicht, ganz kurz, das muss ich noch kurz fragen, vor allem war das nicht das Release, auf dem dann schule Mädchen drauf war, das sind doch fettes Brot mit so einem richtigen, die sind da wieder so richtig zurückgekommen.
Also ja, genau, das war es.
Auch noch so eine auf die Fresse Platte, geil.
Ja, genau, das Konzert, und da habe ich gesagt, irgendwann Jungs, ganz irgendwann möchte ich mit euch zusammen auf der Bühne stehen und ja und singen.
Und das war bei dem Konzert?
Das war dann etwas später.
Als es schon Smartphone-Kameras gab?
Ich möchte nicht darüber reden. Ich möchte nicht darüber reden.
Ich habe mir vorhin schon notiert, dass ich mal bei der Antenne Aachen mal einen Antrag aufstehe.
Ich habe auch gleich den Namen gegoogelt.
Und jetzt können wir ja auch mal gucken, ob es da vielleicht, naja.
Aber wir kamen eigentlich über die Feiere nach dem Hertha-Spiel am nächsten Tag. Das Konzert war eigentlich Winterpause. Und dann kam die Auslosung bei der Bremen. Läuft ja. Ja, für uns war klar, dass wir das Spiel gewinnen.
War ja wieder mit B.
War ja kein Gegner. Wir waren die Bremer damals.
Ich gucke gerade, wer es eins zu eins geguckt hat. Irgend so ein Miku. Hab ich noch nie gehört.
Es war so scheiße kalt.
Interessanterweise hatte die von all den Mannschaften die zweite Mannschaft in der Regionalliga.
So, und dann kommt halt das Spiel gegen Bremen. Ich sage im Nachhinein, also immer wenn ich Felix treffe – Dr. Felix Brüch, den damaligen Schiedsrichter, sage ich immer Felix, also gut, dass du es angepfiffen hast, aus unserer Sicht, das Ding darfst du im Leben nicht anfassen. Vom Platz her darfst du das im Leben nicht anfiffen. Wir haben morgens das Abschlusstraining drauf gemacht. Wir hatten ja keine Rasenheizung, muss man dazu sagen. Wir hatten keine Rasenheizung, es war unfassbar kalt. Der Platz war nach dem Hertha-Spiel noch nicht mal gewalzt worden oder so. Das heißt, es war einfach ein Geläuf und das Ganze gefroren. Monat später?
Der Platz war echt schlimm, das weiß ich auch nicht.
Ich glaube, es hätte mehr Sinn gemacht, ab und zu mal eine Herde Schafe drüber zu schicken. Aber das wäre das. Und dann haben wir morgens trainiert und ich sage dir, morgens das ging gar nicht. Also 0, 0. Das war eine Kraterlandschaft, eine gefrorene Kraterlandschaft. Wenn du einen Ball einfach gerollt hast, der ist nach spätestens zwei Metern, ist der nur noch gehüpft und hin und her. Und dann gab es eine Platzbegehung. Felix Brüch mit seinen Assistenten, vielleicht war auch einer von der DFL dabei, und Klaus Alofs und Thomas Schaaf dahinter, fünf Meter dahinter. Die wollten Einfluss üben, dass der das nicht anfallt. Und die gucken sich das an und der schimpft. Und wenn sich einer verletzt und wir nicht Weltmeister werden, machen wir sie dafür verantwortlich, weil es war halt 2.6. Sind sie daran schuld? Und die haben ihn bepöbelt aufs Allerfein. Ich glaube, auch aus Prinzip, hat er sich gesagt, ist da was? Wenn ihr so kommt, dann pfeifen wir an. Hat ein paar Auflagen dem Verein gegeben und die sind dann wirklich los an die Uni und haben sich da bei irgendeinem Chemiker, was weiß ich, irgendein Zeug geholt. Das haben sie dann auf den Platz gesprüht und irgendeine chemische Reaktion, frag mich nicht, waren die ersten, der erste Zentimeter war weich. Keine Ahnung, das war warm auf einmal. Weiß es nicht, die sind ja nicht mit Bunsenbrenner, aber der erste Zentimeter oder die ersten anderthalb waren weich und dann sind sie mit der Walze drüber. Dann hast du zumindest die Unebenheiten und die Krater und so hast du nicht mehr.
Es war halt eben.
Aber das hat halt nicht lange gehalten, weil es war... plus auch noch Schnee. Aber die Auflage von Brich war halt, dass es... Weil da konntest du wirklich nicht spielen. Du hast null Stabilität gehabt. Also hast du dir nicht weiss nicht, wie viele Bänderrisse geholt. Aber so war es zumindest eben. Es war glatt, es war knallhart, aber es war eben. Und das war halt die Auflage. Ja und dann ging es los. Was für Schuhe zieht man denn an? Wir wussten natürlich, auf dem Platz haben wir eine deutlich größere Chance, als wenn die jetzt hier anfangen können, Fußball zu spielen. Du hast eben Miku angesprochen, da war ja noch der eine oder andere, wo ich gehört habe, die sollen ganz gut Fußball spielen können. Ich meine, du kannst ja gerne mal kurz die Aufstellung durchgehen.
Also geht das schon von hinten los. Rein gefahren hast Owo Mojela, Naldo, Christian Schulz, Baumann, Borowski, Frings, Miku im Mittelfeld und vorne drin Klasnitsch und Klose.
Ist jetzt gerade was nach vorne hin nicht unbedingt das Schlechteste gewesen. Nicht das Schlechteste gewesen. Und wir wussten natürlich auf dem Platz, das geht, da geht was. Wir haben es 100 Prozent angenommen. Wir hatten auch auf Holzkohle gespielt. Uns war das wirklich egal. Und was habe ich gespielt? Ich habe meine Stollenschuhe angezogen, aber habe Lederstollen drunter gezogen. Das gab es früher in den 70ern. Wir hatten aber irgendwie noch welche. Das Problem, oder für mich das Glück – und das hätte der Schiedsrichter niemals sehen dürfen – das Leder um die Schraube herum war nach wenigen Minuten auch schon völlig ramponiert und zerstört. Ich bin mehr auf den Schrauben gelaufen.
Du hattest Stahlstollen effektiv.
Ja, aber ziemlich spitze. Mit Stahlstollen hättest du auch keinen Halt gehabt. Aber dadurch, dass ich eigentlich nur eine Schraube hatte… Ja, noch mal, Gott sei Dank, toi toi toi, ist da nichts passiert. Ich hab's auch erst nach dem Spiel gemerkt.
Dann quasi Spikes.
Ja, ich hab's auch erst nach dem Spiel gemerkt. Ja, so sah das bei mir halt aus. Und viele haben dann mit Multinocken gespielt oder mit normalen Aluminiumstollen. Aber wir haben's ein bisschen besser angenommen und am Ende 3-1 gewonnen. Ich fand es jetzt emotional nicht so spektakulär wie das Hertha-Spiel, weil bei Hertha natürlich eine ganz andere Dramaturgie ist. Ein anderer Verlauf. Deswegen ist für mich auch Hertha höher einzuordnen als Berlin. In meiner persönlichen Wahrnehmung natürlich sportlich. Ich weiß nicht, könnte man das schon auf eine Stufe stellen.
Ich hab beide Spiele damals gesehen. Zumindest Werder wurde auch über 90 Minuten gezeigt. Bei Hertha bin ich mir nicht mehr ganz sicher. Das hab ich irgendwie anders verfolgt. Aber bei Werder wusste man, wenn die da anpfeifen, dann habt ihr eine Chance.
Aufgrund des Platzes, ja.
Genau. Und dann hat sich Klos in der 42. auf die Schulter gefallen, musste rausgehen. Dafür kam dann Bades rein. Und da habt ihr schon geführt. Und deswegen war quasi die Spannungskurve ein bisschen flacher. Hinten raus ging es nochmal kurz hoch. Da hat Borowski – wir sehen – Elfmeter verschossen. Ja genau, Borowski war es. Da hätte es nochmal eng werden können. Aber dann, deswegen, da war halt härter mehr so, naja, innerhalb von ein paar Minuten dreht sich das Ding halt zwei Mal.
Es war auch im Stadion natürlich war die Stimmung gut und es war laut, aber es war nicht, fand ich, nicht so explosiv wie es gegen, aber es liegt halt, es liegt auch am Verlauf, am ganzen Ablauf des Spiels. Vielleicht noch ein kurzes, wenn wir jetzt auch so in das eine oder andere Detail gehen. Die Kartensituation war auch extrem lustig. Gegen Burkhausen und Bochum waren es so, ich weiß nicht, gegen Burkhausen waren es 10.000, ich meine, ihr habt jetzt die schlauen Dings. 9.000, ja. 9.000 irgendwas. Gegen Bochum, was hatten wir, 12?
Ja, 13, sagt das Internet.
Oder so. Weil da waren halt, die Stimmung war aber sehr gut, aber es waren halt wirklich nur die da, die es wirklich interessiert, die es wollten. Und gegen Berlin waren wir, glaube ich, voll. Und gegen Berlin habe ich noch 42 Karten bekommen. Freunde und so weiter. Karten verteilt. Und dann vor dem Bremen-Spiel. Und das ist das, was ich jetzt erzählen wollte, weil das ist der Burner. Ich weiß nicht, wie man auf so eine Idee kommt. Aber gut. Begrenzte Kapazität. Millantor damals ausverkauft, glaube ich, 21, 5, 22 irgendwas in dem Bereich. Für uns Spieler, wir hatten gegen Bremen, hatten wir, glaube ich, jeder Spieler 10 Karten. Also natürlich die kaufen, aber wir hatten Zugriff auf, glaube ich, bis zu 10. Und dann bekomme ich einen Anruf von jemandem, dem ich 2003, kurz bevor ich meinen A3 bekommen habe, meinen Golf damals verkauft habe. Das war das einzige, was wir miteinander zu tun hatten. Der kam irgendwo aus dem Bereich Richtung Dortmund. 2003 das Auto verkauft. 2006 hatte er immer noch meine Nummer. Die habe ich auch heute noch. Aber er hatte die Nummer noch und ruft mich an und fragt mich wegen Tickets. Erst mal, ich würde jetzt nicht unbedingt jemanden anrufen, den ich seit drei Jahren nicht gesprochen habe.
Entsprechend überrascht hast du wahrscheinlich.
Ich war überrascht, ja. Und habe dann, weil natürlich die Anfragen dann spätestens bei Bremen, ich hätte auch 100 Leute versorgen können, ich habe immer nur gesagt, ich notiere es mir und dann melde ich mich, wenn ich weiß, wie viele Karten ich bekomme. Und zu ihm habe ich dasselbe gesagt. Und dann habe ich gedacht, um wie viele Karten geht es denn? Wenn ich euch jetzt frage, was würdet ihr in seiner Situation dann antworten, wenn ihr überhaupt anrufen würdet? Ja, also er sagt, gut wären halt 19, im Optimalfall 35, weil dann könnte mein Bruder seine Mannschaft auch noch mitbringen.
Er wollte mit seinem ganzen Team kommen.
Genau.
Da hat jemand auf dicke Hose gemacht und gesagt, ich kenne den Ralph Gunesch, ich mache da was klar.
Ja, aber was denken die Leute, dass wir, auch wenn es um Trikots oder Bälle geht, dass wir so eine Lagerhalle haben, die quasi sich von alleine auffüllt?
Die Antwort ist, sie denken nicht.
Und auch immer, ja, hier Trikots bei einem Verein wie dem FC Bayern und so, da ist das alles völlig egal, aber wir mussten die Trikots damals selber bezahlen. Wenn ich eines hergegeben habe, wurde das von meinem Gehalt abgezogen. So jetzt, zwar der EK des Trikots, aber trotzdem, auch wenn wir getauscht haben. Was denken die Leute, dass wir eine Lagerhalle haben, wo hier sind die Bälle und da die Trikots, da die T-Shirts und hier die Fahnen und dann haben wir noch ein Regal mit Eintrittskarten. Und ich habe mir auch noch gesagt, ja, ich notiere es mir und dann gucke ich mal, was ist mit dem los, der ist besoffen. Er hat aber keine 38 Karten bekommen und ich konnte aber meinen engsten Familienfreundeskreis mit Karten für Bremen besorgen. Bayern war da natürlich noch mal schwieriger.
Hat er sich aber nicht noch mal gemeldet und dann um 80 Karten gebeten.
Nein, das nicht. Dann haben wir die Bremer geschlagen.
Dann habt ihr die Bremer geschlagen, aber wir sind ja irgendwie schon bei den Bayern gelandet. Das ist eins der Zuschauerplakate, was ich mir gemerkt habe, obwohl es jetzt schon elf Jahre her ist. Bokehausen, Bochum, Berlin, Bremen, Bayern, Pokalsieg, Barcelona. Megagutes Plakat, kam dann aber nicht ganz so, war dann ein 0 zu 3 zu Hause. Hargreis und zwar immer Pizarro, aber erst sehr spät. In meiner Erinnerung war es so, dass die Bayern gar nicht so geil waren, dass sie sehr profitiert haben von einem frühen Tor, was auch mehr oder weniger aus dem Nichts gefallen ist und dann hinten raus den Deckel drauf gemacht haben. Wie ist deine Erinnerung an das Spiel? Ich vermute mal noch besser.
Also es ging schon in der Besprechung los. Es steht Andreas Bergmann vorne und versucht uns natürlich ein bisschen den Respekt vor den großen Bayern zu nehmen und sagt, Jungs, das sind auch keine Weltmeister. Ähm, Trainer?
Doch.
Ja, ihr wisst, was ich meine. Das war schon mal ein ganz guter Einstieg in die Besprechung. Was war da alles an Weltmeistern auf dem Platz, sagen wir mal kurz?
Ja, das müsste man mal gucken, weil das war ja 2006. Das waren ja amtierende Weltmeister, dann nur die Brasilianer.
Ja, wieso? Lucio 2002, Sanyol, Frankreich?
Ach so, ich dachte amtierende Weltmeister.
Ach so, nee, nee. Und wir halt, Trainer, so und so. Aber gut, war halt ein guter Einstieg. Aber nein, wir wussten natürlich, was da auf uns wartet. Ich durfte in dem Spiel leider nicht auf der Innenverteidigerposition ran, weil Trainer kam zu mir am Vormittag und sagte, ich weiß, du möchtest lieber Innenverteidiger spielen. Aber wir hatten damals ein großes Problem auf der linken Seite. Also das war, wir hatten da nicht wirklich jemand. Und dann sagte er, ich brauche jemanden, der Salihamidchen stoppen kann. Ich habe an dich gedacht, du spielst heute links. Na gut, weil das war halt nur so meine Ausweichposition, nicht meine Lieblingsposition. Toll, jetzt spielst du gegen die Bayern und musst auf die linke Seite ran. Aber gut, gegen Brazzo zu spielen ist auch eine schöne Aufgabe, kann ich euch sagen. Ja, und habe halt auf links gespielt. Und du hast natürlich gemerkt, dass da Fußballer auf dem Platz stehen. Also wirklich Fußballer, ne? Ein bisschen überspitzt formuliert, wir waren die Abteilung, also wir haben das gemacht, was der Ball wollte. Und auf der anderen Seite waren die, wo der Ball das gemacht hat, was der Spieler will. Das ist halt der Unterschied zwischen uns gewesen. Und das hatte bei uns insgesamt nicht so viel mit gepflegtem Fußball zu tun, sondern das war auch wieder nur Energie und Haubuck und gib ihm und mach ihm. Aber wenn wir mit St. Pauli als Drittligis gegen Bayern spielen, was willst du denn machen? Eben, ja. Jetzt kann ich anfangen zu glauben, dass du die jetzt an die Wand spielen kannst. Und eigentlich war das Spiel nicht schlecht von uns. Und dann kam halt dieses Ding von Hargreaves. Und das war halt, sage ich, wenn das später fällt. Wer weiß was, also in einem von 20 Spielen gewinnen wir vielleicht. Aber wer weiß, was passiert, wenn die halt nicht in der, sagst du mir?
15.
In der 15. schon 1-0 führen durch einen Distanzschuss von Hargreaves. Ach, Achim, an guten Tagen hältst du den auch. Für die Bayern halt beruhigend. Natürlich haben wir sie auch in der zweiten Halbzeit hinten reingedrängt. Und Oli Kahn hat auch, ja, das war jetzt natürlich mehr so das klassische Lob des Gegners, aber er sagte, dass er lange nicht mehr so einen Druck gespürt hat, auch von außerhalb wie hier am Millantor. Alles schön und gut, aber das muss man dann auch im Nachhinein auch anerkennend sagen. Ich habe zu keinem Zeitpunkt das Gefühl gehabt, dass die Bayern nicht so nachlegen können, wenn sie wollen. Da steht halt ein Ballack vor dir auf dem Platz und dann frisst du dich in diesen Zweikampf und hast noch nicht mal das Gefühl, dass der 100 Prozent gibt. Weil reicht auch mit 80. Natürlich waren sie uns qualitativ haushoch überlegen. Aber trotzdem haben wir, finde ich, alles reingeworfen, was unsere beschränkten Mittel zu dem Zeitpunkt hergegeben haben. Und dann kommt – Pizarro kam, glaube ich, rein und dann haben sie in der – Hilf mir – 89. 92. oder sogar beides Nachspielzeit.
84. und 89.
Oder so. Halt ganz spät den Sack zugemacht mit zwei Kontern. Also wir haben wirklich zweite Halbzeit waren wir größtenteils in deren Hälfte. In der Hälfte, nicht vor dem Tor, in der Hälfte. Und ja, dann kamen halt – nahmen die zwei Konter zum Schluss und Deckel drauf. Und natürlich haben wir uns geärgert in dem Moment, aber wir sind auch nicht so vermessen gewesen zu sagen, das hätten wir auch gewinnen können. Nein, das gewinnst du in der Situation in einem von 20 Spielen. Ansonsten nehmen die das einfach auch zu ernst, da sind sie zu sehr Profi. Also ich glaube diese Zeit, Festenbergs, Kreuth und so damals, ich glaube nicht, dass das den Bayern heute in der heutigen Zeit nochmal passieren dürfte.
Ne, drötet sich zumindest nicht an. Das war so das Highlight deines vorerst letzten Jahres bei St. Pauli, denn dann ging es jetzt zwischendurch mal zu Mainz.
Ja, das kam auch völlig überraschend. Im Jahr davor war es noch so, dass ich für ein Jahr verlängert hatte für die Saison 2526. Das hatte ich mit Stani dann geregelt, der war zu dem Zeitpunkt Vizepräsident. Und dann kam so ab März, April eigentlich, ja, wir würden gerne verlängern. Und da kam dann aber mein Berater ins Spiel, der sagte, du, pass mal auf, du hast jetzt hier zwei sehr, sehr ordentliche Jahre gespielt. Wir gehen den Schritt in die zweite Liga.
Ich habe gerade auch nochmal geguckt. Du hast eigentlich die drei Jahre in die drei Saisons in St. Pauli ordentlich Spielzeit gehabt. Jedes Mal so 30 Spiele plus.
Genau.
Also das heißt, tatsächlich war das dann auch deine Fußfassung?
Ja, mein Fußfassung, mein Stabilisieren im bezahlten Fußball. Und dann sagte mein Berater halt, du, pass auf, es wird jetzt Zeit, den nächsten Schritt zu gehen. Ich war kurz vor dem 23. Geburtstag. Und eigentlich war die zweite Liga das Ziel. Eugen Hach war damals Trainer in Oberhausen. Das war, weil er und mein Berater kannten sich halt schon seit sehr langer Zeit. Das war eine mögliche Option. Und dann meldete sich Energie Cottbus, die damals im Aufstiegsrennen ganz weit vorne waren. Sie sind am Ende als Zweiter oder Dritter aufgestiegen. Damals gab es ja noch keine Relegation. Und ich war sogar dann in Cottbus. Der hat mich eingeladen, ich soll mir das Ganze mal vor Ort anschauen. Und haben erste Gespräche geführt. Und waren eigentlich relativ weit fortgeschritten.
Was heißt denn immer dieses relativ weit fortgeschritten?
Dass du schon ziemlich konkret über Zahlen und Laufzeiten sprichst. Also, dass nicht mehr Grundsätzliches abgesprochen wird, sondern dann geht es wirklich um, verdienst du jetzt Summe X oder Summe Y? Sprechen wir über zwei oder drei Jahre. Und sonstige Klauseln wie festgeschrieben Ablöse.
Um da auch vielleicht gleich mal ein bisschen den Schwenk in die allgemeine Thema Profikarriere. Ist es denn da so, also Gespräche nehmen wir mal an, da fängt der Berater an, sagt, da ist eine Möglichkeit, spricht der Berater mit dem Verein. An welcher Stelle kommt da in der Regel der Spieler?
Sehr früh eigentlich. Er sagt, pass auf, ich habe mich mit Oberhausen und mit Cottbus unterhalten. Das und das ist das Stadion. Was denkst du denn? Wo hast du ein gutes Gefühl? Klar, das ist mir erst später bewusst geworden. Natürlich wäre Cottbus auf vielen anderen Ebenen vielleicht nicht unbedingt das, was sich ein St. Pauli-Fan für seine Spieler wünscht. Da gibt es ja auch die eine oder andere, oder gab es aktuell immer noch, auch wenn der Verein sehr intensiv daran arbeitet, Problematik im Fanbereich. Das habe ich zu dem Zeitpunkt aber noch gar nicht so wahrgenommen. Ich glaube auch, dass diese ganzen Thematiken 25, 26 noch nicht so präsent waren, wie sie es heute sind. Falls mich jetzt ein Hörer korrigieren möchte oder ein Hörer tut das gerne, aber ich glaube, das ist dann auch viel eigene Lebensblase, dass man sich damit schon sehr intensiv beschäftigt hat. Das mag sein, aber ich glaube, in der großen Wahrnehmung war das noch gar nicht so sehr Thema. Für mich war es einfach nur eine Möglichkeit, in die Bundesliga zu wechseln. Noch zweite Liga, aber es war immer die Option in die erste Liga, weil Cottbus wirklich oben mitschwimmt. Das war Ende April, das heißt, es war wirklich kurz vor der Entscheidung. Dann sind sie tatsächlich aufgestiegen. Dann war es wirklich nur eine Frage der Zeit, weil ich saß zu Hause und war mir klar, die wollen dich haben. Also der Wechsel, wenn ich zusage, funktioniert. Vertrag bei St. Pauli lief aus. Der Wechsel funktioniert und die Daumen gedrückt. Oh, du kannst in die erste Liga wechseln. Und eigentlich 48 Stunden vor dem Fix machen, rief mein Berater an und sagte, ich habe heute einen Anruf von Christian Heidel bekommen. Ich sagte, oh, das ist sehr interessant. Ja, die sind sehr interessiert an einer Verpflichtung, aber Jürgen Klopp würde dich gerne vorher noch kennenlernen. Okay, gut. Wie? Ja, die melden sich bei dir und dann klärt ihr das. Und dann rief mich – ich weiß nicht, ob Heidel mich anrief oder der Teammanager Axel Schulz. Ich glaube, Axel rief mich an. Axel rief mich an und sagte, du, pass auf, Klopp ist irgendwie die Tage in Hamburg, weil er fürs ZDF was drehen muss. Er war damals der WM-Experte. Musste irgendwie so ein paar Vorbeiträge und Trailer und so ein Kram drehen. Und trifft dich mit ihm bitte am Flughafen. Dann schrieb Klopp mir eine SMS, dann und dann treffen wir uns am Flughafen. Okay, gut. Dann bin ich zum Flughafen gefahren und habe mich da in einem Restaurant vor dem Sicherheitsbereich, oben ist ein Restaurant mit Klopp getroffen. Wir haben uns da eine halbe Stunde hingesetzt und einfach unterhalten. Ganz normal, ganz trivial, nichts Spezielles. Er wollte einfach einen persönlichen Eindruck. Sie hatten mich – das habe ich dann alles so im Nachhinein erfahren – hatten mich über mehrere Monate intensiv beobachtet. Da war Pete Kravitz, der jetzt auch in Liverpool einer seiner Co-Trainer ist, war zu dem Zeitpunkt Chefscout bei Mainz 05, hatte mich häufiger oder häufig oft beobachtet. Und ich passte quasi in deren Profil, weil sie einen jungen Innenverteidiger gesucht haben, als Backup für Noweski und Friedrich. Ich war komplett nervös, weil du jetzt auf Jürgen Klopp triffst. Und dann, hallo Herr Klopp, und ja ja, sag Kloppo zu mir. Ich bin aber das ganze Gespräch über beim Sie geblieben. Ich habe einfach nur ein wirklich cooles, entspanntes Gespräch geführt. Ich bin nach Hause gefahren und eigentlich vom Heimweg, vom Flughafen nach Hause, das waren so – damals war die A7 noch frei – 20, 25 Minuten bis nach Blankenese raus. Rief mein Berater an, ja das geht klar. Wie jetzt? Klopp hat halt direkt danach Heidel angerufen, hat gesagt, passt, machen wir. Und der hat halt meinen Berater angerufen und hat auch gesagt, machen wir. Und dann hatten sie halt – das läuft dann so, dann sprechen sie alle über die Zahlen, dann kriegst du so ein Vertragsangebot zugeschickt. Und dann gibt mein Berater mir die Zahlen durch und dann bin ich erstmal ruhig. Weil halt von der dritten Liga in die erste Liga, das spürst du dann. Es ist als absolute Zahl, war es jetzt nichts übertrieben übermäßig jetzt reich. Aber in Relation zur dritten Liga war das jetzt so, wow.
Und da hat sich wahrscheinlich in den drei Jahren auf St. Pauli auch nicht so viel entwickelt, oder?
Ganz wenig, ganz wenig, ganz wenig.
Beim zweiten Vertrag dann, der für die Saison 2, 5, 2, 6 minimal, jetzt auch nicht übertrieben viel. Das wurde dann erst tatsächlich in der ersten Liga interessant. Und ich dann so, fang jetzt aber nicht an zu verhandeln, oder? Sagt er, wieso? Ich sag, reicht. Mehr will ich gar nicht. Passt schon so. Bist du dir sicher? Ja, also ich war mir wirklich dann, wenn ich die Wahl hatte zwischen Mainz und Cottbus, ich war mir bewusst, ich möchte nach Mainz. Und ja, dann war es die Aufgabe meines Beraters halt in Cottbus anzurufen und eigentlich den schon fast fixen Transfer, weil wir waren uns auch über die Zahlen einig. Wobei du als Drittligaspieler nicht anfängst zu verhandeln. Also wenn der Erstligaclub kommt, dann fängst du nicht an zu verhandeln. Insofern ging das relativ zügig. Aber wir waren uns einig. Wir hatten halt wirklich nur um Bedenkzeit gebeten. Und in diese Bedenkzeit ist Club World reingegreetscht. Und hat das dann quasi für sich entschieden. Ja, und dann Ralph Wechsel nach Mainz. Ja, und dann puh, das Abenteuer Erste Liga begann.
Aber was habt ihr denn in dieser halben Stunde? Ging es da auch um Sportliches?
Ja, es ging auch um Sportliches, weil er dann auch… Ich werde mich… Der eine Satz, ja… Ich habe ihm den gut vorgelegt, er hat ihn verwandelt, muss ich sagen. Habe ich ihm halt genau das erzählt. Sagt er, wie war das denn beim Bayernspiel? Warum hast du denn links gespielt? Also die wussten wirklich… Zu dem Zeitpunkt war ich erstaunt, dass sich so jemand mit mir beschäftigt. Also das erwartest du halt in der Form nicht. Und der wusste halt wahnsinnig viel. Ja, in dem Spiel war es dann so und in dem Spiel hast du ja das. Und ich so, wow, hast du mir zugeguckt? Also nicht gesagt, aber so gedacht. Das erste Mal, ey, du wirst dir wirklich wahrgenommen. Das kannte ich halt in der Form nicht. Ja, heute weiß ich natürlich, wie das mit dem Scouting und so läuft. Aber da war ich zu dem Zeitpunkt noch sehr, sehr naiv und unbedarft. Und dann habe ich ihm nur gesagt, habe ich ihm genau das gesagt, was Andi Bergmann zu mir sagte. Ja, ich suche einen, der Salimitsche stoppen kann. Und dann sagt, klopft zu mir, warum haben sie dich genommen? Er ist halt auch nicht auf den Mund gefallen. Er ist auch sehr, sehr schlagfertig. Und ja, wirklich sportliche Fragen. Und hat dann auch von Anfang an auch klar kommuniziert, pass auf, ich habe Noweski und Friedrich, beides Nationalspieler zu dem Zeitpunkt. Manu war ja auch deutscher Nationalspieler. Noweski drei Jahre hintereinander, mazedonischer Fußballer des Jahres und, und, und. Also schon gestandene Fußballprofis. Aber die hatten Thomas Spodok vorher. Der ist dann, ich glaube, der hat dann sogar aufgehört. Und ja, wir suchen einen Jungen, den wir quasi aufbauen können dahinter. Ich habe gesagt, warum mache ich? Du kannst ja nicht dann in die Erste Liga wechseln und so. Ich bin jetzt hier, jetzt bin ich der neue Innenverteidiger und mir gehört die Bundesliga. Und das war eine Rolle, die ich halt angenommen habe. Und es dauerte auch gar nicht lange, bis ich dann wirklich…
Warst du 23?
Ja, kurz vorm 23. Also ich bin quasi immer zum Saisonstart ein Jahr älter geworden. 2. September, irgendwann im August war ja dann Saisonstart. Kurz vorm 23. bin ich in die Erstliga gewechselt und muss sagen, es ging schon in der Vorbereitung los, dass ich das Gefühl hatte, das schaffst du nie. Warum?
Wegen dem Niveau.
Ja, das Niveau war einfach, es ging alles doppelt so schnell und doppelt so intensiv und die technischen Ansprüche waren höher und und und. Und ich habe wirklich am Anfang richtig, richtig kämpfen müssen, um das mitzugehen, weil es halt eine komplett neue Erfahrung war. Das war halt wirklich im wahrsten Sinne des Wortes eine andere Liga.
Vom Sprung her noch mal so wie in Aachen bei der ersten Vorbereitung mit den Profis oder noch mal ein größerer Sprungengefühl?
Ja, aber halt auf anderer Ebene, technisch, taktisch und vom Tempo her gar nicht mal so sehr die körperliche Robustheit. Also intensive Zweikämpfe gab es in der Regionalliga mehr als alles andere, also mehr als Fußball. Aber das Tempo war halt ein ganz anderes. Ich erinnere mich an viele Situationen, wo ich zum Beispiel als Innenverteidiger stehe und in einem Trainingsspiel hauen sie drei Bälle über mich drüber und Michael Turk steht da und schiebt den Ball ein. Und irgendwann hat Kloppo mich zur Seite genommen. Also das muss ich sagen, er war nicht nur einer, der gefordert hat, sondern auch gefördert. Und sagte, Ralf, auf dem Niveau musst du die Bälle besser antizipieren. Ich nenne jetzt einfach nur mal ein konkretes Beispiel. Er sagte, du siehst doch, wenn der Innenverteidiger oder wenn der Sechser oder so schon andeutet, den langen Ball zu spielen, dann musst du dich schon entsprechend positionieren. Das hat er mir zweimal gesagt und dann habe ich das umgesetzt. Und dann sind die Bälle halt nicht mehr so leicht über mich drüber geflogen, sondern dann habe ich das Spiel besser gelesen. Das ging halt einfach schneller. In der Regionalliga hast du dann oftmals noch Zeit gehabt, da zu reagieren. So, wenn Manu Friedrich einen perfekt getimten, langen Ball auf Tor spielt und der dann seinen Fuß hin hält, dann hast du keine Zeit zu regieren. Entweder du hast es in dem Moment auf dem Schirm oder der Ball ist drin. Wenn du die Muvache hinter dir hast und der zwei Dinger kassiert und dich einmal durchschüttelt, dann weißt du, dass du das nächste Mal vielleicht anders reagieren solltest. Da habe ich sowohl von Klopp wie auch von Manu wie auch von Nicole Schöne, Marco Rose auf links wirklich viel gelernt, weil ich da auch ihre Unterstützung hatte. Das muss man sagen, also der Teamgeist, der Spirit innerhalb der Mannschaft, die Stimmung war richtig gut und dann kam tatsächlich das erste Bundesligaspiel, weil sich Manuel Friedrich bei einer Länderspielreise verletzte und dann hieß es Endverteidigung Noweski-Gunesch auch da wieder in Cottbus. Es gibt halt schöne Geschichten in diesem Sport und ich habe in Cottbus mein erstes Bundesligaspiel gespielt. Ich war so nervös. 0-2 verloren, aber ich war am Anfang – oder beim Wahrmachen – ich war so unglaublich nervös. Das könnt ihr euch gar nicht – das war noch nie vorher so extrem der Fall. Als das Spiel dann losging, ging es, war es okay, aber in der Vorbereitung zum Spiel, das war unglaublich. Und dann auch wieder so eine Sache. Dann ist das Spiel und dann kommt Kloppo am nächsten Tag zu mir und sagt, das war ja dein erstes Bundesligaspiel. Irgendwie vom Gefühl her hast du doch schon 50. Also ich weiß nicht, er sagte einfach, wie du dich dann so auf dem Platz präsentierst und wie du dich gibst. Überhaupt nicht wild und hektisch, sondern eher so jemand nach dem Motto, ja der hat schon ein bisschen was erlebt und kann das schon so alles einordnen. Ich hatte zu den Zeiten etwas über 100 Spiele, wenn ich jetzt auch die Oberliga bei Alemannia Aachen zusammenrechne, im Herrenfußball. Das dürften so 140 oder so etwas gewesen sein mit der Regionalliga dazu. Also schon viele Spiele im Herrenbereich unterwegs gewesen, aber auch der Bundesliga. Genau dasselbe sagte Otto Addo, der damals in Mainz spielte. Der kam ein bisschen später, weil er mit Ghana noch bei der WM war und irgendwann nach zwei Wochen fragt er mich, wie alt bist du eigentlich? Ich sag ja, ich bin 22.
Also wie jetzt?
Ich sag ja, 22. Wieso? Du gibst dich hier wie so ein 7- 28-Jähriger, der schon, weißt du, ich sag…
Das sind doch schöne Komplimente.
Ja, das war halt nicht so wild und ich mach jetzt einfach, sondern immer versucht so ein bisschen bedacht an die Sache heranzugehen. Ich hab das gar nicht auf dem Schirm gehabt, dass das ja dein erstes Bundesligaspiel war. Ich sag, doch, Kloppo, das war mein erstes Bundesligaspiel. Ja, aber das nur als kleine Randnotiz.
Wie war es denn so unter Jürgen Klopp? Ich mein, jetzt natürlich wissen wir alle, was aus ihm wurde.
Ja, ein wahnsinnig authentischer Typ. Also er ist genauso, wie ihr ihn wahrscheinlich jetzt beschreiben würdet, wie ihr ihn wahrnehmt über die Presse und über das, was ihr seht im Stadion, im Fernsehen. Genauso ist er wirklich auch in der tagtäglichen Trainingsarbeit. Unheimlich versessen, sehr, sehr motivierend, aber er wird fuchsteufelswild, wenn du es halt nicht so machst, wie er es vorgibt. Also er gibt dir einen Plan mit und verlangt, dass du diesen Plan halt auch zu 100 Prozent umsetzt. Weil ansonsten wird er fuchseig. Was ich von ihm aber auch neben den ganzen fußballerischen Komponenten gelernt habe, er ist – und die Einstellung finde ich sehr, sehr gut, weil er auch nach Niederlagen natürlich sehr beärgert ist und auch keine gute Laune hat in dem Moment, aber in der Besprechung. Ich habe auch Trainer gehabt, die unausstehlich werden, wenn sie verloren haben. Er jemand ist, der sagt, pass auf, wir haben ein Spiel verloren. Wir analysieren das jetzt und nehmen das mit, was uns das Spiel mitgibt, aber wir lassen uns nicht schon für das nächste Spiel dadurch negativ beeinflussen, weil sonst bestrafen wir uns doppelt. Wir sind bestraft durch die Niederlage und wenn wir uns jetzt auch noch zu lange damit beschäftigen und uns davon runterziehen lassen, bestraft es uns doppelt, weil wir dann auch mit einem schlechten Gefühl ins nächste Spiel reingehen und das machen wir nicht. Und das war eine Sache, die ich halt von ihm gelernt habe, da Schlüsse daraus zu ziehen, aus Niederlagen die richtigen Schlüsse, aber sich nicht doppelt davon bestrafen zu lassen, weil die Niederlage an sich ist schon schlimm genug. Dann brauchst du nicht das auch noch ins nächste Spiel mitnehmen. Er war sehr schnell jemand, der den Turn ins Positive bekommen hat, der dich direkt wieder positiv aufs nächste Spiel vorbereitet hat. Einfach, um auch da wieder mit Spaß an die Sache heranzugehen.
Wie hat sich die Trainingsarbeit unterschieden, jetzt so bei all deinen Stationen bisher und dann landest du bei Klopp? War das auch mit der ersten Liga insgesamt was anderes als noch vorher in der Regionalliga oder hingen das immer eher mit der Trainer-Persönlichkeit zusammen, die du hattest?
Insgesamt die Trainingsbedingungen sind natürlich deutlich professioneller geworden. Ich hätte jetzt fast gesagt, meinen ersten Athletiktrainer hatte ich in Mainz, das stimmt nicht ganz. Bei St. Pauli hatten wir in den letzten Monaten auch mit Pedro González einen Trainer, der rein für die Athletik verantwortlich war. Da habe ich auch das erste Mal an einer, wie soll ich sagen, an einer Koordinationsleiter trainiert, Anfang 2006. Aber so wirklich konzeptionell, dass es für verschiedenste Bereiche verschiedene Trainer gibt, das war dann erst in Mainz der Fall. Wir hatten bei St. Pauli einen Physiotherapeuten, irgendwann mal ab und zu einen zweiten in Mainz Fest 3 plus Arzt, der zweimal die Woche vor Ort war. Wir hatten einen großen Physioraum hinten der Whirlpool, als Entmüdungsbecken und und und. Das kannte ich bis dahin alles gar nicht. Es war alles neu, aber angenehm. Das war vorher das Stabilisieren, das Fußfassen im Profifußball. Und das war so, dass ich das erste Mal den Eindruck gewonnen habe, wie das denn laufen kann. Und jetzt war das bei Mainz zu dem Zeitpunkt noch nicht das Beste, was es in der Bundesliga gibt. Aber es war durchaus ordentlich.
Das ist ja die bittere Ironie, dass ihr hinter Cottbus gelandet seid.
Ja, das war dann natürlich… Der Abstieg war nicht schön oder die ganze Saison, das Ergebnis der Saison war nicht so schön. Die Hinrunde lief für mich persönlich, ehrlich gesagt, besser. Ich hatte es angesprochen, Manuel hatte sich dann verletzt. Vielleicht noch eine kleine Geschichte. Ich durfte in der Vorbereitung gegen den FC Liverpool ran. Wir hatten unser letztes Vorbereitungsspiel vor Bundesliga-Start. Das letzte Testspiel, da sucht man sich ja dann immer noch einen starken Gegner und die Liverpooler kamen gerade aus dem Trainingslager zurück. Wir haben einen Zwischenhalt in Mainz gemacht und sind dann weitergeflogen. Wir haben gegen Liverpool gespielt, Freitagsabend. So ein Noweski hat sich nach 15 Minuten oder so das Nasenbein gebrochen und dann durfte ich aufs Feld. Ihr könnt euch vorstellen, wie nervös ich war, weil Liverpool war halt auch mit allem angereist. Also wirklich Peter Quauchera, Alonso, Kerweger und und und. Die haben alle gespielt und Peter Quauchera war halt mein Gegenspieler. Und ich habe halt in diesen 75 oder 70 Minuten, die ich gespielt habe, habe ich halt kein einziges beschissenes Kopfball-Lull gewonnen. Weil der Typ ist nicht nur groß, der kann auch springen oder konnte zu dem Zeitpunkt auch noch springen. Bis die Muvache irgendwann zu mir kam bei so einer Unterbrechung, sagt Ralph, nicht hochgehen. Lass den Ball zwei Meter dahinter und wenn er dann irgendwas macht, dann kannst du draufgehen. Aber du gewinnst sowieso kein Kopfball-Lull. Aber man steht halt da und denkt sich, dich schaffe ich auch noch. So und in dem Spiel, es gibt zwei Momente in meinem Leben, den zweiten erzähle ich später, es gibt zwei Momente in meinem spieler-fußballerischen Leben, wo ich gemerkt habe, also es gab mehrere Momente, aber das sind so zwei ganz einfregsame, warum es gewisse Fußballer weiter schaffen als andere. Gerard hat auch in diesem Spiel, ist jeden Zweikampf angegangen, als wäre es der letzte seines Lebens. Das hat geknallt an allen Ecken und Enden. Der ist jeden Zweikampf, jeden einzelnen, völlig egal, wo auf dem Platz, mit 100 prozentiger Intensität ist er den angegangen. Also es war wirklich so auffällig, dass es beeindruckend war und das kriegst du auf dem Feld nochmal ganz anders mit als im Stadion oder vor dem Fernseher. Es war brutal, wie intensiv der selbst so ein Spiel angeht. Eigentlich hätte er – oh mein Gott, die waren alle müde. Wir haben am Ende 5-0 gewonnen, die waren kaputt, die hatten ein hartes Trainingslager hinter sich. Das Ergebnis darfst du ja nicht als Maßstab nehmen. Eigentlich hätte er auch sagen können, lass mich hier die Halbzeit zu Ende spielen und dann lass mich auswechseln. Hätte er sowieso gespielt. Also ich glaube, in der Position von Gerard hätte es nichts geändert. Aber der hat die 60 Minuten oder wie lange er gespielt hat, hat er zu 100 Prozent durchgezogen, dass du als Gegenspieler einfach sagst, Respekt. So läuft das also. Das Zweite, da kommen wir dann im Jahr 2010 drauf. Ja und dann das erste Bundesligaspiel, dann kam das erste Bundesliga-Heimspiel gegen Werder Bremen. Die Bremer vorher, freitagsabends – du lachst schon, weil du das Ergebnis da wahrscheinlich siehst – zwei Wochen vorher gegen den VfL Bochum 7-2 gewonnen. Das erste Jahr von Diego gewesen. Kannst du bitte nochmal die Aufstellung raussuchen. Und dann geht das Spiel los und dann geht es stets nach – hilf mir kurz.
Ich werde das Endergebnis noch nicht spoilern.
Nach 21 Minuten steht es 0-3. So können wir mal die Aufstellung kurz durchgehen.
Du wirst ja nur entlastet werden.
Fritz, Mertesacker, Naldo, Womé, Baumann, Frings, Diego, Vranjes, Hand, Klose. Ist jetzt nicht so das Allerschlechteste. Gerade im Mittelfeld, obwohl mit Peer und Naldo hast du schon mal ganz gute Innenverteidiger. Womé, links, Fritz rechts, Baumann, Frings, Mittelfeld, Diego davor, mit Vranjes, Hand und Klose. Und wenn ich gesagt habe, das schaffe ich nie in der Vorbereitung, habe ich mich gegen Bremen – ich glaube, so fühlt man sich, wenn man einfach nur überfordert ist. Ich habe Rechtsverteidiger gespielt, ich war, habe ich Innenverteidiger, rechts – warte mal, zeigen wir mal kurz – auf unserer Seite. Nee, Rechtsverteidiger. Manu und die Kolsche haben gespielt. Völlig überfordert mit der Situation. Ich erinnere mich an Situationen im Mittelfeld, wo ich auf Diego drauf gehe und ich einfach nicht weiß, wo der Ball ist, weil es zu schnell geht. Die haben die Kugel da laufen lassen, das war halt ein gutes Jahr von Werder. Wie schon gesagt, zwei Wochen vorher in Bochum 7-2 gewonnen. Die haben den Ball laufen lassen, dass du gar nicht wusstest, wo bin ich denn jetzt? Wo ist denn der Ball? So und die Ironie an der ganzen Geschichte ist, dass Klopp nah am Spiel zu mir kommt und sagt, du warst heute bei uns der beste Mann am Platz. Das hat nach hinten halbwegs vernünftig funktioniert und hat nach vorne viele Aktionen zumindest angeschoben. Die Leistung war isoliert vom Ergebnis, war wirklich nicht schlecht, nur bringt dir das halt nicht so viel, wenn du sechs Stück kassierst. Nach dem 3-0 macht Mimoun Asoua das 3-1 mit einem Freistoß.
Ja, der 74.
Genau, der 74. und dann hat es aber leider gleich wieder nachgelegt.
Chris im Gegenzug, Chris im Gegenzug, Chrisou gleich nochmal, der vierte ist und der fünfte ist und der sechste ist. Das war ein spannendes Heimspiel.
Aber eben keine ganz so erfolgreiche Saison.
Insgesamt nein, es war natürlich mit dem Abstieg dann nicht gut, gar nicht gut. Für mich persönlich lief es in der Hinrunde auch deutlich besser als in der Rückrunde. Habe ich kaum noch gespielt, war zum Teil gar nicht im Kader die ersten Wochen, hatte mich in der Wintervorbereitung auch noch verletzt, also lief nicht so optimal. Und dann kam noch mal so ein kleines persönliches Highlight beim Spielen gegen den HSV, dass wir 2-2 gespielt haben – für mich persönlich ein ganz besonderes Spiel.
Wie lange dauert es, bis man diese Rivalität zum HSV antizipiert als St. Pauli-Spieler? Also bei dir wissen wir ja alle, alle, die den Rasenfunk oder andere Formate hören, die wissen das schon, dass sich da so…
Oder müssen einfach nur bei Twitter folgen, ich glaube, das kommt unmissverständlich raus.
Aber du hast ja eigentlich mit der Rivalität nichts zu tun gehabt.
Nein, aber ich habe das bei St. Pauli relativ schnell angenommen.
Durch die Fennähe auch?
Durch die Fennähe, dadurch, dass ich halt auch selber weiß, wie es als Fan ist. Plus, dann gibt es da noch ein Erlebnis und da gehen wir nochmal kurz zwei Jahre zurück. Da haben wir mit St. Pauli beim HSV gespielt in der Arena gegen die zweite Mannschaft. Und dann hing ein riesengroßes Plakat über die Nord- oder Ost- ich weiß nicht, welches in dem Stadion die Heimkurve ist – und ein ganz großes Plakat, das war am Samstagnachmittag. Und tut uns leid, sind gerade Bundesliga-Gucken. Ist halt nicht schlecht, weil das gibt natürlich dem Stadtrivalen voll eine mit.
Aber war für uns – Auch relativ kreativ.
Ja.
Also ich finde es jetzt gar nicht so…
Ja, aber war für uns – ich will nicht sagen demütigend, aber es war schon – es hat uns getroffen. Und da haben wir uns halt auch gesagt, wenn wir hier irgendwann mal in diesem Laden spielen und der ist voll, dann werden wir gewinnen. Das war damals schon – uns hat das gepusht, in dem Moment natürlich extrem bitter, aber uns hat es gepusht. Und da haben wir auch vor dem Derby genau darüber gesprochen, mit den Jungs, die damals dabei waren. So und deswegen – ich hatte das relativ schnell angenommen. Deswegen für mich ein besonderes Spiel. Die Hamburger zu der Zeit eigentlich mit einem ganz ordentlichen Kader.
Kader war nie das Problem bei mir.
Habe relativ gut zu tun mit von der Fahrt und Co. Hab in der Innenverteidigung gespielt und muss sagen, ich war gut. Das muss ich so sagen. Ich habe mich wirklich richtig, richtig gut gefühlt. Und das war auch – Aussage Jürgen Klopp – mein bestes Spiel. Er hat gesagt, damit hast du da auch nochmal ein Zeichen gesetzt. Weil die Wochen davor lief es halt nicht so, aber da anscheinend überzeugt. Und die Woche darauf war ich aber trotzdem nicht im Kader.
Hat er das auch begründet?
Nein, da überhaupt nicht.
Insgesamt waren es neun Spiele in der Saison?
Neun Spiele. Wahrscheinlich so 25 Mal oder so im Kader. Neun Spiele.
Und warum ging es da nicht bei Mainz weiter? Denn du warst ja auch als Aufbauspieler geplant. Also es hatte jetzt ja niemand von dir erwartet, dass du 20 Spiele machst.
Richtig. Es war aber auch so, dass sie im Winter Neven Subotich geholt haben.
Ja, richtig.
18 Jahre.
Stimmt.
Ich weiß nicht, ob er überhaupt schon 18 war.
Stand zumindest.
Okay, dann gerade 18, kam aus der USA, hatte vorher irgendwie nur auf dem College ein bisschen Fußball gespielt, hatte damals schon physisch unglaubliche Voraussetzungen. Also der war auch wirklich physisch top vorbereitet für Profifußball. Es fehlte natürlich ein bisschen die Erfahrung, aber das war dann, wenn wir jetzt schon einen Schritt weiter gehen, war wahrscheinlich auch ein Grund, warum man mich hat gehen lassen, weil sie Neven hatten. Plus St. Pauli war parallel aufgestiegen und Stani hat mich, der dann in der Zwischenzeit Trainer war. Also so oft wie in den Tagen habe ich mit ihm noch nie telefoniert und gesprochen. Der also täglich drei Mal ist noch untertrieben. Der wollte mich halt um jeden Preis wieder haben. Und ich hatte das Gespräch mit dem Verein gesucht bzw. mit Kloppo, war aber nicht so wirklich zustande gekommen.
Das Gespräch schon?
Das Gespräch schon, ja. Und das war für mich dann so – kann sein, dass ich es vielleicht damals verzehrt wahrgenommen habe. Ich will jetzt nicht sagen, dass ich alles richtig gemacht habe. Soweit gehe ich nicht. Aber irgendwie hatte ich das Gefühl, man will mich nicht zwingend halten. Also nach dem Motto, es ist ok, dass er da ist, aber wenn er jetzt geht, dann ist das auch ok. Und auf der anderen Seite halt bei Stanni und bei St. Pauli genau das Gefühl, wir wollen dich unbedingt und du musst zurück und wir brauchen dich und und und. Sodass wir halt diesen Wechsel angestrebt haben. Und ich bin Christian Heidel heute auch noch froh und dankbar, dass sie mir da keine großen Scheine in den Weg gelegt haben, sondern wir das ganz ganz sauber und korrekt über die Bühne gebracht haben. Auflösungsvereinbarungen, da gab es auch keinen Streit mit irgendeiner, weiß ich nicht. Dadurch, dass ja noch ein 2-Jahres-Vertrag aufgelöst wird, könnte man ja noch über Abfindungen und so weiter nachdenken. Jetzt werden wahrscheinlich einige schimpfen, ja, aber du wolltest doch wechseln, aber glaubt mir, in dem Geschäft gibt es durchaus auch sowas. Aber das war auch nicht unser Bestreben, es ging wirklich darum, diesen Transfer sauber über die Bühne zu bringen und das haben wir mit beiden Parteien ganz ordentlich hinbekommen. Ich bin generell froh, dass all meine Wechsel, es waren Gott sei Dank nicht so viele, aber die Wechsel alle ganz korrekt und sauber immer über die Bühne ging. Ich bin nach keiner, der Theater will und habe auch Verhandlungen nie öffentlich geführt. Und dann war halt der Wechsel, weil sie hatten dann auf der Position sowieso schon… Wen hatten sie noch verpflichtet? Hilf mir kurz.
Roman Neustetter?
Nee, Roman kam aus der U21 hoch.
Also das ist der Kader?
Das ist der Kader. Nee, das ist ja drauf. Wie heißt der denn? Der dann später bei… Hokeland, genau, Tim Hokeland. Tim Hokeland hatten sie noch geholt. Insofern waren sie dann in der Defensive entsprechend besetzt. Und dann war für mich auch nicht klar, aber das war für mich ein weiteres Zeichen. Okay, gut, dann streben wir diesen Wechsel an und der hat dann funktioniert. Trotzdem habe ich sehr, sehr viel in diesem Jahr gelernt und mitgenommen, weil es einfach die Erfahrung, erste Liga, ja, die nimmt ja halt keiner.
So und dann wieder St. Pauli. Den Aufstieg dann ja leider nicht miterlebt, aber jetzt folgt so die längste Zeit für insgesamt dann jetzt 108 Spiele und auch Tore geschossen, unter anderem das im Intro gehörte.
Tore habe ich auch in der Regionalliga geschossen, Max. Gegen Arminia Bielefeld und damals hießen sie KFC Öding, war ja dann – oder heißen sie ja dann auch heute noch.
Kriegst du noch alle Gegner bei deinen sechs Toren zusammen?
Ich habe – hilf mir kurz. Die sechs Tore, die mir hier angezeigt werden.
Genau, bei St. Pauli. Ja genau, jeweils drei in den beiden Zeiten bei St. Pauli.
Ansonsten mit eigenen Toren, oder was? Also in der ersten Zeit war es Ödingen, Bielefeld und Braunschweig. Das waren die ersten drei Tore. Nicht chronologische Reihenfolge, aber das waren die ersten drei Tore. Braunschweig übrigens damals von Heuza verpfiffen. Allein darüber könnte ich jetzt noch was, aber das lassen wir dann mal. Der hat uns in zwei Spielen damals beschissen. Also die drei und dann habe ich in der zweiten Zeit, ich habe gegen Hoffenheim getroffen.
Genau, das war das, was wir gehört haben.
Ich habe ein Eigentor beim FSV Frankfurt, ich habe ein Eigentor bei Borussia Dortmund. Ich habe 80.000 Menschen glücklich gemacht. Ich war jetzt nicht so glücklich, aber die waren glücklich.
Das war der Fan in dir.
Ja, selber getroffen in meiner zweiten Zeit bei St. Pauli.
Wahrscheinlich haben die wirklich die Eigentore noch. Ich habe hier noch… Ach so, Uerdingen hattest du schon genannt. Dann haben die wohl die Eigentore dazugezählt. Das ist ein bisschen zynisch, wie es ist, Fußballdaten.de.
Ich habe Mainz, zweite Mannschaft, ein wunderschönes Tor. Max, wirklich ein wunderschönes Tor. Schade, dass es davon keine Aufnahme gibt.
Und ich dir jetzt einfach glauben muss, wie schön war es?
Es war wirklich schön. Ich habe den Ball am eigenen Sechzehner gewonnen und bin durchgelaufen und habe ihn reingeschossen. Am eigenen Sechzehner den Ball gewonnen, Konter. Nein, wir reden tatsächlich von einem Spiel in der zweiten Mannschaft, Mainz 05. Am eigenen Ball den Sechzehner gewonnen, bin losgelaufen. Das war ein Konter. Und hatte nur noch zwei Abwehrspieler vor mir und zwei Stürmer. Also meine zwei Stürmer und zwei Abwehrspieler.
Und hat sie natürlich nicht abgegeben.
Natürlich nicht. Die haben das clever gemacht. Die sind beide nach außen raus.
Und die Abwehrspieler mitzogen.
Die haben die Abwehrspieler mitgezogen und ich bin in der Mitte durch und hab ihn reingeschossen. Ja, aber ich weiß nicht.
Nee, es war tatsächlich transfermarkt.de sagt, auch nur ein Treffer Fußballdaten hat die beiden Eigentore noch dazu gezählt.
Na wenigstens. Ja, ich hab sie erschließlich selber erzählt, wenn auch ins falsche Tor. Ja, dann kam die Saison, die erste Zweitligasaison, in der wir auch sehr, sehr viel lernen mussten. Wir mussten nämlich lernen, dass es in der Zweitliga anders zugeht. Es ging los mit einem Auftaktspiel gegen den ersten FC Köln, wo wir eigentlich nicht die schlechtere Mannschaft waren, aber Köln hatte Patrick Helmes. Und wir angerannt und gemacht und getan und Köln hat die Tore geschossen. Ganz entspannt. Die haben uns machen lassen. So war es übrigens ein Jahr später, als Union Berlin aufgestiegen ist. Die sind zu uns ans Millantor gekommen und haben ein überragendes Spiel gemacht. Und wir haben die Tore gemacht. Richtig, lass die Jungs mal austoben und wir schießen die Tore.
Davor habt ihr übrigens die erste Runde vom DFB-Bukal gegen Leverkusen gewonnen.
Richtig, gegen Bayer Leverkusen 1 zu 0 in der 85. und 86. Minute. Ziemlich spät. Da durfte ich gegen Manuel Friedrich spielen.
Den, den du aus Mainz dann noch kanntest.
Den ich aus Mainz kannte, der zu dem Zeitpunkt tatsächlich einer meiner engsten und besten Freunde war. Wir haben auch heute noch einen ordentlichen Draht, einen guten, nicht mehr so intensiv wie zu der Zeit. Aber damals waren wir wirklich sehr, sehr eng befreundet, waren fast jeden Tag essen. Ich konnte nur bei seiner Golfleidenschaft nicht mithalten. Das war nie so Mainz. Aber gut, das war Manuel. Sehr spannende Saison, viele Aufs und Ups. Und wir mussten halt wirklich schnell lernen, was Zweite Liga bedeutet, dass das halt nochmal was anderes ist. Und haben dann nach hinten raus den Klassenerhalt mit einem 4-2 gegen Erzgebirge Aue klargemacht. Eigentlich eine relativ unspektakuläre Saison. Ansonsten, wir waren nie wirklich in Abstiegsgefahr. Aber es hat trotzdem gebraucht, bis wir es dann rechnerisch klargemacht haben. Es müsste irgendwas… Ja, 29. oder 30. Spieltag oder sowas. Und wir sind dann am letzten Spieltag nach Mainz gefahren. Das ist die Saison gewesen, oder?
Das ist die Saison gewesen, ja.
Wir haben dann in Mainz gespielt. Und wir hatten halt schon vorher die Flüge nach Mallorca gebucht. Wir sind dann von Frankfurt ausgeflogen. Und ich war verletzt. Ich hatte mir im Spiel davor keine Ahnung, was ich mir geholt hatte. Ich bin halt privat runtergefahren und auf einmal Mainz musste halt gewinnen für einen Aufstieg. Wir haben es dann nicht geschafft. Aber wir haben dann halt fünf Stück kassiert. Das war keine schöne Kabinenansprache nach dem Spiel. Wobei Stani da relativ ruhig geblieben ist. Er hat gesagt, Leute, ich habe euch versprochen, dass ihr das dürft und so. Aber er hat dann ein bisschen nach dem Motto, Leute, wenn ich euch was verspreche, dann muss von euch auch ein bisschen was kommen. Die Leistung war halt nicht schön, aber vielleicht so als Erklärung. Das ganze Jahr hast du Spannung, dann fällt das alles von dir ab. Und beim anderen geht es noch um Aufstieg. Natürlich musst du dir nicht zwingend fünf Dinge einschenken lassen. Aber Gott sei Dank, das Ergebnis hat auch relativ schnell dann auch keinen mehr interessiert. Weil alle einfach froh waren, dass die Saison vorbei ist. Wir spielen ein weiteres Jahr Zweite Liga und jetzt geht es weiter.
Und dann schön auf Malle und gefeiert. Das ist ja ein Standardritual bei sehr vielen Vereinen. Ich habe schon…
Mittlerweile tatsächlich nicht mehr.
Nicht mehr?
Das hat sich sehr gewandelt. Das war vor vielen Jahren noch ganz, ganz anders. Also zu der Zeit kannst du sagen, dass 10, 12, 13, 14 Zweitligisten waren auf Mallorca. Heute kannst du sie an einer Hand abstellen.
10, 12, 13, das heißt ja alle, die nicht abgestiegen sind.
Im Prinzip war es so. Im Prinzip war es so, dass sich die komplette Zweite Liga und ab und zu auch mal ein bisschen was aus der ersten Liga auf Malle getroffen hat. Und das hat sich heute komplett verschoben. Es ist heute noch eine Hand voll. Und wenn du zu der Zeit mit 15, 18, 20, 25, wir sind zum Teil mit über 30 dahin geflogen, inklusive Betreuerstab, Staff und und und ohne Trainer, sind das heute 5 bis 10 pro Mannschaft.
Und wo feiern die Mannschaften dann heute? Macht man es bloß nicht mehr auf Malle, weil jeder ein Smartphone hat und ein Foto macht?
Entweder gar nicht mehr.
Das kann doch nicht sein.
Doch, doch, doch. Der Part hat sich schon ein Stück weit verschoben. Ja, dass man dann nach der Saison auseinandergeht quasi. Die Kölner fliegen nach Las Vegas. Auch ganz okay.
Ja, hast du vor allem halt deine Ruhe. Du bist ja vor allem in Ruhe.
Andere fliegen nach Ibiza. Also das, ja. Aber so dieses klassische Ballermann-Ding hat sich verändert, verschoben.
Interessant. Und wie war, wie ist denn eigentlich so das Profi-Leben jetzt dann? Wir sprechen jetzt die ganze Zeit schon darüber, dass du auch dann Bundesliga gespielt hast, zweite Liga. Wie ist es denn als Bundesligaprofi? Das macht man eigentlich die ganze Zeit. Trainieren?
Trainieren.
Autos tunen lassen.
Nein, das war ja mit 18 so. Das habe ich ja dann später tatsächlich nicht mehr gemacht. Das waren dann immer Autos, die – ich habe ja immer erwähnt, ich habe meinen A3 ja immer noch. Der wird auch bei mir bleiben, bis er auseinanderfällt. Aber ich habe dann natürlich – was heißt natürlich? Aber ich habe dann auch immer noch andere Autos quasi dazugehabt, die ich meistens dann eher mehr gefahren bin als mein A3. Da habe ich dann wirklich über – als aktueller Bundesligaprofi hast du über das Audi WIP-Programm halt die Möglichkeit, die Fahrzeuge so acht bis zehn Monate zu fahren und dann kannst du dir ein neues bestellen. Und da habe ich wirklich modelltechnisch mal ein bisschen durchprobiert, aber das waren dann halt – auf deine Frage einzugehen – das waren dann Autos, die musst du halt dann nicht mehr wirklich tunen. Also dann nimmst du halt – ich hatte Q7, A5.
Das heißt, du bist dann viel gecruist oder was? Oder das habe ich mich vorhin schon gefragt, als du von deinem getunten Golf erzählt hast, sowas will man dann ja auch zeigen. Bei mir in der Heimat hat das Bedeutung, man stellt sich an die Schelle.
An die Tanzstelle? Nein. Nein, das habe ich nicht gemacht. Das habe ich nicht gemacht. Was ich tatsächlich, weil du jetzt das Gruseln ansprichst, was mich wahnsinnig entspannt und das mache ich heute auch noch gerne, ist gerade an schönen Sommerabenden…
Über die Autobahn mit 180?
Nein, das kommt vor. Autobahn, dann sind es aber nicht 180. Aber einfach über die Dörfer fahren bzw. über die Landstraßen. Gute Musik, Klimaanlage aus, Fenster auf, auch nicht aufdrehen, damit du alle Nachbarn wachmachst, sondern wirklich einfach nur, dass du mit guter Musik abends eine halbe Stunde, eine dreiviertel Stunde durch die Gegend fährst. Nicht durch die Stadt, sondern wirklich über die Landstraßen, Bundesstraßen und einfach nur… Ja, einfach nur cruist. Das habe ich in Hamburg auch oft gemacht. Das war so… Ja, ich kann dabei wahnsinnig gut einfach auch abschalten und entspannen.
Und daher kommt ja auch der Felgenralle. Ich meine, das wissen natürlich alle, die dir auf Twitter folgen, aber wir haben ja Hörerinnen und Hörer, die das noch nicht tun.
Das kam… Es geht ganz schnell. Als ich zu St. Pauli gewechselt bin, das erste Mal, habe ich über meine Leidenschaft für Autos erzählt und es gibt Presseerzeugnisse, die arbeiten gerne mit Schlagzeilen und dann hatte ich den Namen weg mit Pressesprecher und dem ein oder anderen Spieler, die sich Gedanken darüber gemacht haben, habe ich akzeptiert, angenommen und irgendwann…
Zur Marke gemacht.
Zur kleinen Marke gemacht, genau.
Was war das damals für eine Mannschaft, in der du da bei St. Pauli gespielt hast in der zweiten Phase? Gibt es so wichtige Bezugspersonen, mit denen du damals viel zu tun hattest und die auch wichtig für die Mannschaft waren?
Extrem wichtig für die Mannschaft waren Holger Stannislawski und Andri Trulsen als Trainer und Co-Trainer. Das war eine ganz, ganz besondere Konstellation, weil Stanni dann im zweiten Jahr seine Lizenz machen musste und deswegen Trulsen offiziell der Cheftrainer war, aber gehört haben wir auf Stanni. Also natürlich haben wir auch auf Truller gehört, aber Truller – also ja, Spitzname Truller, Andri Trulsen – natürlich haben wir auch auf Andri Trulsen gehört, aber für uns war klar, dass Stanni der Chef ist. Aber Trulsen war bei den PKs, weil er halt auf dem Papier der Chefin war. Er hatte den Fußballlehrer schon und es war aber auch ein schwieriges Jahr, weil Stanni halt von – er war nicht da Montag, Dienstag, Mittwoch, Donnerstag.
Da haben wir so eine Reihe an Trainern, das hat mit Stanni angefangen.
Fünf Stück, die quasi einen Job im bezahlten Fußball hatten und ihre Trainerlizenz angefangen haben und Stanni war der Einzige, der seinen Job bealtern hat. Alle anderen, die anderen vier haben im Laufe der Saison ihren Job verloren, weil es wirklich schwer ist. Wenn der Chef nicht vor Ort ist, ist das extrem schwer. Und das muss man auch sagen, da war es wichtig, dass wir keine Arschloch-Truppe hatten, sondern eine Mannschaft, die das zu 100 Prozent angenommen hat und die versucht hat, das so gut wie möglich zu lösen und aufzufangen. Weil der Verein hat jetzt nicht irgendwie noch einen zusätzlichen Co eingestellt. Wir hatten Trulla und wir hatten KP, also Klaus-Peter Nehmet, den Torwart-Trainer, der dann so ein bisschen mit dem Co gemacht hat. Und ansonsten war das auch Selbstcoaching. Fabian Boll, Bruns, Ebers, Morena, meine Wenigkeit, Carsten Rothenbach. Das haben wir alle irgendwie so zusammen geile Truppe aufgefangen, um da keine Probleme entstehen zu lassen. Und Stani hat seine Lizenz auch oftmals aufs Spiel gesetzt, weil er nach Niederlagen zum Beispiel gesagt hat, wenn wir sonntags gespielt haben, ich kann jetzt nicht von meiner Mannschaft weg. Und war dann Montagmorgen noch beim Training oder bei der Besprechung und hat entsprechend natürlich, weil du musst montags morgens um 8 Uhr wieder in Köln sein bei den Vorlesungen und was weiß ich, was die da alles haben beim Unterricht. Und das hat er alles sausen lassen und die haben da natürlich auch ihm quasi zugearbeitet und vielleicht auch mal ein Auge zugedrückt, was sie bei einem anderen, der jetzt keinen Job hat, nicht tun würden. Aber die sind ja auch bedacht, dass ihre Leute natürlich die Jobs behalten. Und das war für ihn ein riesiger Aufwand. Da ist wirklich ganz krasser zeitlicher Aufwand, auch physisch. Und das haben wir alle zusammen dann hingekriegt.
Das ging ja gut. Eine Frage habe ich vorhin noch vergessen beim zweiten Wechsel zu St. Pauli. Laut Autogrammkarte bist du beim Wechsel von Mainz zu St. Pauli ein Zentimeter gewachsen, aber auch fünf Kilo schwerer geworden. Was war denn da los?
Ja, also die Gewichtsangabe auf den Autogrammkarten und auch im Internet, das ist ewig auf 76, 77 stehen geblieben. Und ich hatte dann halt irgendwann meine 3, 80 Kilo und irgendwann dann angepasst.
Okay, das finde ich jetzt etwas unspektakulär.
2003 war ich noch unter 80 Kilo und das ist dann erst so, mit der Zeit auf Kampfgewicht war, irgendwas zwischen 83 und 86. Das ist halt so eine Schwankung gewesen. Also wenn es nicht mehr als 86 waren und das sind es heute auch nicht, wobei heute im Morgen 86, 2 waren, aber ansonsten, ja du lachst, ich stehe jeden Morgen auf der Waage. Das hat sich halt nicht verändert.
Ist es dann eine smarte Waage? Ja, alles andere hätte mich jetzt auf den Falsch dreißen. Du hast mal gesagt, ich weiß gar nicht mehr genau wo, ich habe so viel über dich gelesen, dein technisch bester Mit- und Gegenspieler auf die Frage hast du geantwortet beim Gegenspieler mit Raoul. Ja. Wann hast du gegen den gespielt?
Ja, das war dann 2010 im Bundesliga-Jahr.
Und bester Mitspieler, David Heulet.
Ja, David Heulet, der es dann auch in die Premier League geschafft hat. Ein überragender Fußballer, also was seine Fähigkeiten angeht, so ein kleiner Dribbler, großartig am Ball, die Aachen-Fans werden heute noch schimpfen. Wir haben das letzte Spiel am Tivoli, ich glaube, 3-1 gewonnen und Timo Achenbach, ich glaube, der sucht heute noch den Weg aus dem Stadion raus, wenn mich nicht alles täuscht. Der hat den so eingedreht, also wirklich, der hat den so eingedreht, dass Achenbach von seinen eigenen Mitspielern in der Woche drauf aufgezogen wurde mit dem Spiel. Matze Lehmann hat uns das erzählt, der dann zu uns wechselte. Das war so ein geiles Spiel. Jedes Mal, wenn ich einen Ball gewonnen habe, habe ich nur David gesucht, weil ich wusste heute macht der Junge alles. Und der war halt der direkte Gegenspieler von Timo Achenbach. Er ist so ein bisschen über rechts gekommen und Timo spielt ja hinten links. Der hat den wirklich schwindlig gespielt. Wie schon gesagt, ich glaube der läuft heute noch auf dem Gelände des alten Tivolis rum und sucht den Ausgang irgendwie auf die Straße.
2007 bis 2010 kann man sagen bei St. Pauli. Erstmal die ersten beiden Jahre waren so super stabil, was das Sportliche angeht, oder? Beide Jahre komplett im Mittelfeld verbracht.
Das war auch nichts anderes, das war das Saisonziel. Im zweiten Jahr, das dürfen wir jetzt natürlich nicht unter den Tisch fallen lassen, das Spiel gegen Hoffenheim.
Wichtigster Treffer war, so erzählen es sich die Geschichtforscher, das 3 zu 1 kurz vor Schluss.
Nein. Also die ganze Saison war eigentlich ordentlich und vielleicht auch da eine Anekdote, warum das mit Stani halt so gut funktionierte zu dem Zeitpunkt. Er hat immer unseren Ton getroffen, immer unseren Ton gefunden und was ich den Jungs auch sagen muss, Stani und Trulla haben Trainingseinheiten, da kriegst du das kalte Kotzen und da würdest du am liebsten ihn dir schnappen und vor die Wand hauen.
Inwiefern?
Ekelig. Ekelig intensiv. Seien es jetzt die 1000 Meter Läufe, halt 11 Stück oder die 800 Meter Läufe oder die Konditionseinheiten mit dem Medizinball, nicht viele. Also es war schon ein sehr moderner Ansatz. Aber ich finde, und das sage ich auch heute noch, ab und zu darfst du das auch mal einstreuen, damit die Jungs auch mal lernen, über den Punkt hinauszugehen. Das Trainingswissenschaftliche vielleicht, würde jetzt ein Sportprofessor, der dann anfängt, den Laktat zu messen, der würde dann sagen, oh, jetzt kommen wir in einen gefährlichen Bereich, wo ich aber sage, natürlich, aber die Jungs müssen auch mal lernen, richtig zu kotzen und mal über den Punkt hinweg zu gehen. Weil sie, wenn du immer kapitulierst vor dem inneren Schweinehund, so nach dem Motto, ja, bis hierhin und nicht weiter, es ist eine Willensschulung. Und das haben wir nicht oft gemacht, nicht viel, aber wir wussten, es kommen die 1000-Meter-Läufe, es kommen die 800-Meter-Läufe und es kommen die 200-Meter-Läufe. Das waren so drei ganz, ganz wichtige Einheiten, auch für Stani. Natürlich hätten wir, konditionell, hat uns diese eine Einheit, wird dich jetzt nicht auf ein neues Level katapultieren, aber einfach auch für den Mannschaftsgeist enorm wichtig, weil du dich da auch gemeinsam durchquälst. Gemeinsam durchquälst, durchquälen ist das richtige Wort. Also an die Läufer unter uns, also die 1000 Meter unter 3, 15, unter 3, 20, das Ganze 10- bis 12-mal hintereinander mit maximal zwei Minuten Pause. Danach weißt du, was du getan hast. Die Einheit geht nur 45 Minuten, aber die sind knackig. So und das Ganze auch mit 800 Metern nochmal veränderte Zeiten. Und die 200 Meter Läufe, das war eine Geschichte. Die Einheit ging 25 Minuten maximal, aber danach warst du halt, du warst durch. Wir sind an, haben wir oft im Trainingslager gemacht. Das war so eine ganz normale, die 400 Meter Bahn, die Runde, kennen wir alle. So zwei Mann zusammen und dann stellt sich einer an die Mittellinie und einer an die andere, auf der anderen Seite an der Mittellinie. Dann läuft der erste los, Vollgas, meistens die 200 Meter in so 26, 27 Sekunden. Das ist, oder 26 bis 28, das ist annähernd Sprint, also annähernd Vollsprint. Die schnellsten Bundesligaspieler Oberme, Young und Co. laufen die 100, ich würde sagen unter 11, 10, 10, 8, 10, 9. Dann bist du schon ganz weit vorne von Bundesligaspielern. Ansonsten bewegst du dich irgendwo bei 11, 5 bis 12, auch wenn wir 100 nicht messen. Aber das ist so grob der Bereich. So und dann rechnen wir das mal hoch. Das heißt, wir sind bei 13, 13, 5, 14 Sekunden auf 100, das Ganze zweimal. Und dann klatschst du ab, dann läuft dein Partner los. Und in der Zeit musst du aber wieder quasi auf die andere Seite, weil der läuft ja dann die 200 Meter Runde und kompliziert die Runde und schlägt dann ab. Du hast zwar dann auch 28 Sekunden Erholung – Entschuldigung, zum Schluss waren es wahrscheinlich 30 Sekunden auf die 200, aber hast du zwar die Möglichkeit, dich zu erholen, aber du musst trotzdem, das sind – Du gehst übers Feld. Das sind, das dürften vielleicht 80 Meter sein, also mit Gehen ist da halt – Wenig. Mit Gehen ist da halt relativ wenig, sondern du musst auch im guten Trabtempo rüber, weil dann kommt er. So und das Ganze machst du siebenmal und das Ganze machst du zweimal oder sogar dreimal. Dann nach den 200 Meter Läufen weißt du halt genau, was du getan hast und dadurch, dass du ja in der Gruppe losläufst, du willst ja auch nicht – Er hat keine Zeit, er hat nie eine Zeitvorgabe gemacht. Aber wehe, du bist der Meinung, du könntest hier ganz entspannt mal gar nichts machen.
Ja, das heißt, das Training mit Stani war durchaus – Hat es in sich?
Es hat es in sich.
Nicht immer, aber wenn er die harten Einheiten aufgerufen hat, dann…
Ja, das war schon – Es war intensiv, aber das musste auch mal sein und da habe ich zum Beispiel auch, dann weiß ich noch genau, Fabian Boll ist danach hingegangen, hat seine Uhr ausgezogen und hat sie eben wirklich vor die Füße geworfen und hat nun gesagt, einen Scheiß kannst du alleine machen und ist reingegangen und Stani stand da nun und hat ihn ausgelacht. So, aber dann war eine halbe Stunde später, war auch alles wieder gut. Also, wenn sich ein Spieler über sowas nicht aufregt, weiß ich nicht, aber genau das wollte er ja. Genau das wollte er ja. So, und andersrum, wenn ein Trainer dann anfängt beleidigt zu sein, weil ein Spieler mal sowas macht, dann sag ich auch, Junge, dann hast du kein Gespür für das Ganze. Der soll das ja bitte nicht in einem normalen Training machen oder in einer normalen Besprechung, aber nach so einer Geschichte, er stand da wirklich nur so armeverschränkt und lachte ihn einfach nur aus. Und ich glaube, wenn du Boller gelossen hättest, hätte er ihm eine Aufweige gegeben und der hat sich dann halt selbst zusammengerissen und ist einfach nur reingegangen. Und da sage ich, da merkst du dann, ob so eine Verbindung zwischen Trainer und Mannschaft auch funktioniert und das war immer gegeben. Es waren alles Läufe, alles Einheiten und das meine ich auch, das hat gepasst, sie haben auch den Ton der Mannschaft getroffen. Es war immer so, dass ich gesagt habe, alter Schwede, ich habe das jetzt geschafft, aber ich könnte keinen Lauf mehr. Also im Prinzip genau richtig, dass du schon vorher eigentlich sagtest, ich kann nicht mehr diese 1000 Meter Läufe, 10 Stück oder 11 Stück. Die ersten beiden Läufe sind hart, weil du ins Tempo reinkommen musst. Dritter, Vierter, Fünfter, Sechster, Siebter, läufst du durch, du bist drin im Rhythmus, du hast die körperliche Konstitution dafür. So, aber dann beim Achten, Neunten, dann fängt es schon an weh zu tun, weil natürlich die körperliche Ermüdung dazukommt. Dann gibt es nochmal eine halbe Minute Pause, was vielleicht gut – eine halbe Minute mehr Pause, was vielleicht gut klingt. Aber wenn du einmal halbwegs runterkommst und dich dann wieder antreiben musst, dann – also das kennt jeder wahrscheinlich unsere Hörer und Hörerinnen, die ähnliches mal gemacht haben. Aber sie haben dann immer diesen Punkt getroffen, dass du sagst, das habe ich jetzt geschafft, ich bin in der Zeit geblieben. Boah, reicht jetzt wirklich auch. Dann haben wir ein Spiel in Oberhausen gehabt, Freitagsabends. Ein Oberhausen im Oktober oder November – ich weiß es nicht mehr – wo du echt weißt, Stadion – boah, wir können jetzt drüber streiten, ob einem solche Stadion gefallen. So, Platz nicht gut, Mannschaft unangenehm, Wetter scheiße. Und dementsprechend war auch die Stimmung in der ganzen Woche vorher. Und dann kommt er morgens zum Training, am Montag oder Dienstag. Und es war halt der klassische Hamburger Sommertag im Oktober, November mit Regen und fünf bis sieben Grad und kalt und dunkel und grau und überhaupt. Und dann sitzen wir, wir saßen immer, bevor wir rausgegangen sind, im Besprechungsraum, zwei, drei Worte gesagt und dann in den Schuhraum, Schuhe anziehen, raus. Und dann kam er in zivil rein. Und wir wussten, wenn der Trainer in zivil in die Kabine kommt, ist immer irgendwas. Meistens waren es keine guten Sachen. Dann steht er in zivil vor uns und dann steht er so da vor uns, guckt uns an und sagt so Jungs, ich bin heute Morgen aufgewacht. Habt ihr auch keinen Bock? Und wir gucken alle nur und es traut sich nicht. Ich meine, keiner hat sich getraut, irgendwas zu sagen. Und war Ebbe so einer der Ersten, der so ja, ist jetzt nicht unbedingt so das beste Wetter. Wisst ihr, was wir machen? Ihr geht jetzt raus, spielt eine halbe Stunde Kreis, in der Zwischenzeit gehe ich rüber. Da war direkt am Trainingsgelände so eine Pommesbude. Gehe ich rüber, hole uns eine Schüssel Pommes und ein Blech Currywurst und dann essen wir Currywurst und dann machen wir morgen früh weiter. Und du hast so bei jedem war von jetzt auf gleich von, boah, heute ist aber auch nicht so mein bester Tag zu…
Er läuft. Er läuft.
Ja, aber so hat er immer wunderbar in die Mannschaft reinfühlen können, was sie gerade braucht. Und für uns war das halt so ein Moment, wo wir, wo uns das wirklich gut getan hat. Und zwar besser als jede taktische Trainingseinheit, die wir je hätten machen können. Und du hast jetzt gerade nachgeschaut, sind nach Oberhausen gefahren, hast du das Datum parat? Ja, 16.10. So, 16.10. Er sagte auch, Leute, das Spiel ist auf Scheiße aufgebaut, das Wetter wird Scheiße, der Platz ist Scheiße, der Gegner ist Scheiße, also Scheiße im Sinne von total unangenehm. Wir bereiten uns jetzt diese Tage entsprechend darauf vor und dann fahren wir da hin und gewinnen. Und genau so war es auch. Dann haben wir diese Trainingsanleihen – das war ja keine Trainingsanleihen, wir haben ein bisschen 5 gegen 2, 6 gegen 2 gespielt und danach zusammen Currywurst gegessen mit Pommes – aber am nächsten Tag wussten wir dann, ey, pass auf, das kam jetzt vom Trainer, jetzt sind wir dran. Und haben ganz konzentriert, ganz fokussiert gearbeitet. Es gab nie eine Diskussion, wer dieses Spiel gewinnt in diesen 90 Minuten.
Gut, in der zweiten Halbzeit 0-1 gedreht, aber trotzdem am Ende.
Ja, aber das meine ich mit, wir hatten ein Bewusstsein auf dem Platz und das erinnert dich an das Ding gegen Hertha und das war das Bewusstsein. Scheißegal, was heute passiert. Scheißegal, was heute passiert. Wir gewinnen dieses Ding.
Currywurst mit Pommes – wäre das im heutigen Fußball noch möglich oder war das auch schon damals eine krasse Ausnahme?
Ist nicht nach außen gedrungen. Ob das heute möglich wäre, ist schwierig.
Oder wie hast du dich damals ernährt? War das für dich auch eine krasse Ausnahme oder konnte man sowas zwischendurch schon immer einschieben? Ich meine, heute lesen wir von Spielern, die sich laktosefrei ernähren, die ganz bestimmte Dinge, wie Glutamat, weglassen zum Beispiel.
Heute sind aber auch die Tests von Seiten des Clubs viel extremer wahrscheinlich.
Ja, es ist natürlich alles viel, viel verwissenschaftlicher. Wie habe ich mich ernährt? Also ganz generell habe ich von Fastfood und darunter fällt jetzt für mich die ganzen – dürfen wir Namen nennen – Burger King, McDonald's, Subways und Co. habe ich schon, weiß ich nicht, 2005 abgeschworen. Schmeckt mir einfach, also gibt mir nichts, gibt mir wirklich keine Energie, das habe ich am eigenen Körper gespürt. Finde ich geschmackstechnisch auch total uninteressant und deswegen findest du mich auch nicht in diesen Läden. Von daher war das nie Teil meiner Ernährung, meine Sünde ist halt Pizza, aber auch da Anfang der Woche ja, aber sobald es dann zum Spiel hingeht, wurde es quasi immer vorbildlicher.
Weil es energetisch sonst auch schwierig ist?
Das spürst du einfach. Wenn du körperlich in dem hohen Maße gefordert bist, spürst du ganz, ganz schnell, was deinem Körper gut tut und was eher nicht.
Ist das schon der Zeitpunkt, an dem wir über die Nutellapizza reden?
Das können wir ja ganz kurz abhandeln.
Wie kam es denn dazu eigentlich?
Genau, wie kommt man auf die Idee, eine Salami-Pizza mit Nutella zusammen zu essen?
Also ich glaube, es kommt aus meiner Kindheit, dass ich da irgendwann mal ein Nutella-Brot – Was ist das für eine Kindheit? eine sehr glückliche, ein Nutella-Brot, Nutella hat mir schon immer geschmeckt, dass ich irgendwann mal Salami drauf gepackt habe. Ich glaube, es war wirklich einfach nur ein Experiment und jeder, der es mal probiert hat – und Max, ich habe schon unfassbar viel…
Süß und salzig, klar, das ergibt schon Sinn, aber…
So, und im ersten Moment klingt das vielleicht nicht so, aber es schmeckt halt so. Und die Pizza-Geschichte ist dann quasi die Weiterentwicklung, weil ich dann gesagt habe, warte mal, was auf einem normalen Brot schmeckt.
Schmeckt mit Käse überbacken und heiß noch besser. Das ist eine einfache Grundregel des Lebens.
Richtig. So, und habe einfach mal zu…
Eigentlich nur Bacon.
Zu einer Pizza habe ich mir ein Glas Nutella daneben gestellt und habe mal ein bisschen quasi als Dip… also es ist jetzt nicht komplett bestrichen, sondern steht halt als Dip daneben. Und dann nimmst du mit dem Messer so ein bisschen was und dann machst du es auf das abgeschnittene Stück Pizza drauf und es schmeckt. Genauso auch wie Balsamico-Creme.
Also das finde ich jetzt den Vergleich mit Balsamico-Creme, da habe ich mich jetzt gerade auf meine Zähne…
Nein, nein, dann auf die Pizza. Auf die Pizza, ja.
Ich kann es mir auch sehr gut vorstellen. Es ist nur nicht das, was ich so erwartet hätte bei einem Profisport.
Ich würde es deinen Zwillingen einfach mal anbieten.
Ja, du meine Zwillinge, die nehmen… da kann ich hier diesen Tisch mit Nutella bestreichen und die Zwillinge sagen, das ist mega lecker. Das ist jetzt nicht das Thema, ehrlich gesagt. Kann man sich vielleicht halt auch erlauben, wenn man viel Sport macht und…
Das ist natürlich auch…
dann verbrennt man die Kalorien.
Also ich weiß zum Beispiel im Trainingslager, da laufe ich den ganzen Tag mit so einer Puls-Uhr herum und dann verbrennst du in den zwei Einheiten auch mal ganz entspannt. Also über den Tag von morgens acht bis abends null Uhr, das waren inklusive Trainingseinheiten, das geht an vier, viereinhalb, fünftausend Kalorien. Also da kann man einiges essen und also nur mal auch ein Vergleich, damit man da mal so einen Richtwert hat. Ich habe mal, wir mussten oder wir haben uns jeden Morgen gewogen, das war schon zu Ingolstädter Zeit und in der Sommervorbereitung hatten wir einen extrem warmen Sommer in Ingolstadt, das war unter Marco Kurz und habe mich morgens auf die Waage gestellt, habe mitnotiert, mitgerechnet, was ich in der Vormittagseinheit trinke, wie viel und habe mich nach dem Training auch wieder nur in meiner Sporthose, also nicht, dass jetzt irgendwie Klamotten noch da sind, sondern wirklich nur die Sporthose barfuß auf die Waage gestellt und habe halt den Vergleich gehabt und habe 3, 5 Liter Wasser getrunken während dieser Trainingseinheit, ich habe sieben dieser 0, 5er Flaschen getrunken und habe trotzdem ein Kilo weniger gehabt nach dem Training als vor dem Training. Also nur, um mal den Vergleich zu haben, was wir in einer Trainingseinheit, die ging relativ lang, zweieinhalb Stunden, für den Umsatz haben. Ja, das ist jetzt zum allergrößten Teil Flüssigkeit, aber wenn du halt dann dann Nachmittag nochmal so eine Einheit machst, dann kommst du halt auf einen ganz ziemlich hohen Kalorienumsatz.
Wie verändert sich das Verhältnis zu deinem Körper über die Zeit hinweg? Also du musstest ihn ja gerade beim Schwung von Jugend in den Profibereich und dann auch von der Regionalliga in die Bundesliga musst du ja jeweils immer nochmal ein neues Level erreichen. Bei Handballen ist es ja so, ich glaube, Kretschmer hat das mal irgendwann erzählt, dass er quasi nur noch danach geht, welcher Körperteil ihm am wenigsten weh tut. Wie ist das als Fußballer?
Na ja, am Anfang, mit 2021, wenn wir Freitags abends am Middlantor gespielt haben, war ich halt bis 4 Uhr auf dem Kiez oder bis 5, dann habe ich 3 Stunden geschlafen und dann war ich um 10 Uhr fit beim Training. Die Schlusszeit mit 29, 30 gespielt, brauche ich zwei Tage. Und zwar ohne Feiern, sondern wirklich nach dem Spiel nach Hause und entsprechender Ernährung und trotzdem spürst du es zwei Tage. Das merkt der Körper schon. Dieser Prozess wird natürlich durch die hohe Belastung über einen längeren Zeitraum ein Stück weit beschleunigt. Ich glaube, bei euch ist es nicht anders. Mit 20 kannst du auch drei Nächte durchfeiern und heute spürst du, wenn du mal nicht vor 23 Uhr ins Bett gehst.
Ich könnte jetzt hier sofort einladen. Das hat aber auch mit diesen beiden Trib-Trafs hier zu tun, die jetzt gerade umbesitzt hier stehen.
Und das ist bei uns nicht anders. Also was ich früher konnte, das würde heute nicht funktionieren. Ich habe es ja zum Schluss gemerkt, wenn ich 19 Minuten gespielt habe, habe ich zwei Tage das noch gespürt und am nächsten Tag noch ein Spiel spielen kann. Dementsprechend entwickelst du natürlich ein ganz anderes Bewusstsein dafür, wie du mit deinem Körper umgehst. Dazu gehört auch Ernährung, dazu gehören aber auch Dinge wie Schlaf, dazu gehören Dinge wie Krafttraining, Dinge wie Vorbereitung, wie Nachbereitung, Whirlpool und so ein Kram, das war nie Thema. Und dann irgendwann mit 4.25 Uhr saß ich eine halbe, dreiviertel Stunde nach dem Spiel noch in dem Ding, weil ich einfach wusste, es tut mir gut und ich komme da wunderbar runter. Und es hilft mir, mich noch schneller, also im Rahmen des Möglichen noch schneller zu erholen. Also das Gefühl oder das Körpergefühl verändert sich enorm, einfach aber auch, weil du natürlich – und da ist Ernährung ein sehr gutes Beispiel – spürst, was tut dir gut und was ist eher hinderlich.
Wie hat sich denn da der Fußball verändert? Ich war erstaunt, dass ich irgendwann – aber das ist jetzt schon ein paar Jahre her – aber irgendwann war das eine Meldung, dass quasi noch in der Kabine Pasta gereicht wird nach dem Spiel, damit die Spieler sofort wieder Kalorien zuführen und so weiter, so wie man es bei der Tour de France ehrlich gesagt schon früher mitbekommen hat. Wie hat sich das denn entwickelt in der Zeit, in der du Profi warst?
Ganz, ganz, ganz, ganz extrem. Also wie ich schon gesagt habe, das ist viel, viel wissenschaftlicher geworden. Es ist viel, viel individueller, viel, viel überwachter, viel gesteuerter.
Inwiefern überwachter?
Es wird halt genau geguckt, wer was ist. Du wirst jeden Morgen gewogen. Es gibt regelmäßige Körperfeldanalysen, es gibt regelmäßige Blutbilder, es gibt regelmäßige Leistungstests. Es gibt mittlerweile eine tägliche Trainingskontrolle. Die trainieren jetzt alle mit diesen Westen, also nicht nur ein Pulsgurt, sondern diese Westen, die halt wirklich alles in Echtzeit messen. Der Trainer kann theoretisch am Spielfeldrand stehen oder der Athletiktrainer und sagt, oh, das passt heute bei dem gar nicht, den nehmen wir jetzt mal raus. Du siehst Live, Herzfrequenz, Tempo, negative Beschleunigung – also das sind alles Parameter, die sind genauso wichtig wie unwichtig.
Und sprechen wir da von allen Bundesligisten oder ist das jetzt nur irgendwie das Top-Niveau?
Nein, das geht schon durch die Bundesliga durch. Das ist mittlerweile einfach der Standard, dass da eine unheimlich hohe Überwachung stattfindet und dass nur die Gewichtung ist eine andere. Es gibt Trainer, die lassen es zu und es gibt Trainer, die fordern es aktiv und beziehen das in ihre Aufstellung auch mit ein.
Okay, ja gut, das ist wie der Leistungspfahl bei Pro Evolution Soccer, das kann ich wieder sehr gut verzeihen.
Aber das ist dann auch immer schwierig, du musst das dann immer in Relation setzen, weil ich kenne genug Spieler, das sind die totalen Trainingsweltmeister. Auf dem Trainingsplatz denkst du dir Wahnsinn und sobald das Bundesligaspiel losgeht, fragst du dich halt, wieso hast du jetzt deinen kleinen Bruder geschickt? Genau, so ein ganz prominentes Beispiel, das weiß er aber auch, Colin Kwaner. Der junge spielt jetzt Premier League, ich freue mich unglaublich für ihn, weil er eine geile Entwicklung genommen hat. Aber als ich mit ihm in Ingolstadt zusammengespielt habe, auf dem Trainingsplatz, habe ich mir gedacht, aber es ist ja Wahnsinn, den hast du nicht eingefangen, der ist halt brutal schnell, das ist seine Stärke. Aber der hat das in einem von zehn Bundesligaspielen nur gezeigt und ansonsten wirklich abgetaucht. Das hat er dann bei Union, hat er dann einen großen Schritt gemacht und jetzt der Wechsel zu Hartersfield und Aufstieg und Premier League, alles wunderbar und ich freue mich total für ihn. Aber das war für mich so ein Beispiel, wo das, was im Training zu sehen war, nicht zu dem passte, was er auf dem Platz gezeigt hat. Das wusste er selber. Ich erzähl dir jetzt hier kein Geheimnis. Ich. Ich erzähl jetzt hier nichts Schlechtes über jemanden. Das war zu dem Zeitpunkt sein großes Problem. Nicht, dass er es nicht kann, sondern dass er es dann in der Dings nicht gezeigt hat. Und das meine ich mit den Relationen setzen. Die Frage ist natürlich, was für Wert hat einer, wie macht einer dies das? Aber es zählt auch der Eindruck auf dem Spielfeld.
Ja und ja, der Kopf, das ist ja gleich so das nächste Thema. Es hilft dir ja nichts, wenn du den perfekt gebauten Körper hast. Du musst es irgendwie ja doch immer noch auf den Platz bringen.
Das stimmt.
Hat sich denn da auch was verändert? Also man weiß ja von Trainern, dass allein kognitive Übungen gemacht werden zum Teil, dass du da deine Koordinationsfähigkeit, deine Antizipation, deine Reaktionsschnelligkeit, vor allem bei Torhütern, wird das jetzt inzwischen gezielt trainiert? Wie hat sich das verändert?
Auch enorm. Wobei ich sagen muss, ich glaube immer noch nicht, dass das so den Stellenwert hat, den es haben könnte oder vielleicht auch haben sollte. Das vermag ich nicht zu beurteilen, weil ich selber damit noch nicht so viel zu tun hatte, in meiner aktiven Zeit. In dem Bereich habe ich eigentlich kaum mit irgendwelchen Leuten mal gearbeitet. Klop hat damals 26, 27 zur Rückrunde zwei Mentaltrainer quasi ins Boot geholt. Aber das war auch mehr so ein, ja, da ging es aber nur um den Kopf, ums Reden, ums Mental-Coaching. Das haben die dann gemacht. Ja, vier, sechs Augengespräche. Das war es aber auch. Aber wirklich jetzt klassisches Training in dem Bereich. So gut wie gar nicht. Ich jetzt. Es mag sich verändert haben, es wird sich sicherlich auch noch weiter verändern, aber da gab es bis jetzt relativ wenig. Halte ich für durchaus sinnvoll, weil das noch ein Bereich ist, in dem halt noch nicht so viel gemacht wurde. Wie schon gesagt, im physischen Bereich sind wir glaube ich mittlerweile an einem Punkt angelangt, wo die Steigerungsfähigkeit nicht mehr so groß ist, wo nicht mehr so viel Potenzial ist, wie jetzt, wenn du den Vergleich, ich sage mal, 2000 zu 2010. Das ist ein unfassbar großer Sprung, aber ich glaube der Sprung von 10 zu 20 ist nicht mehr so groß. Das allgemeine Tempo wird oder ist jetzt schon auf einem Level, wo ich sage, also wenn wir jetzt noch mehr schnelle Spieler haben, dann können wir auch parallel noch eine 100-Meter-Meisterschaft ausspielen, weil dann hast du ganz, ganz viele Sprintertypen auf dem Feld. Aber halt der mentale Bereich, der Bereich im Kopf und der ist halt wirklich auch entscheidend. Und ganz kurz noch ein Beispiel, um das vielleicht mal einzuordnen. Was glaubst du, wenn ich den Namen Insagi nenne, wenn wir jetzt die Trainingswerte nehmen oder die Laufwerte, dann fällt er bestimmt nicht auf, weil er der fleißigste und beste und allen vorneweg läuft. Aber trotzdem musst du einen Insagi vorne immer im Sturm stehen haben, weil der weiß halt, wohin er laufen muss.
Absolut. Und ist er schon das perfekte Beispiel, weil gerade Milan ja mit dem Milan Lab in dem Bereich schon sehr früh unterwegs war.
Schön, sehr schön. Der erste Aufstieg in die Erste Liga mit dem FC St. Pauli. Oh, das war ein wildes Jahr. Das war ein wildes Jahr, für mich ging es scheiße los. Ich habe die ersten Spiele nicht gespielt. Wir haben zu Hause gegen – das ist zum Beispiel auch so ein Beispiel. Das ist ein interessantes Jahr, da kann man ein bisschen drüber sprechen. Es ging los mit Ahlen zu Hause 3-2. Da wird ein Spieler eingewechselt in den 86. Der hat danach keine Sekunde mehr gespielt. Und trotzdem sage ich, der hat eine der wichtigsten Figuren, eine der zentralsten Rollen in unserer Mannschaft in dem Jahr gehabt. Nils Pichino. Zeig mir, wann er eingewechselt wurde. Genau, wann wurde er eingewechselt?
Ich habe noch nicht die richtige Saison.
Er hat auf jeden Fall 13 Minuten.
Ja, dann war es die 78. Nils Pichino wird eingewechselt zum Schluss als Stürmer gegen Ahlen. 77. 77. Er wird eingewechselt und schießt halt in der 90 plus 1 oder so. Hilft mir bitte. Schießt er das 3 zu 2.
2 zu 1, aber…
Stimmt, 2, 1. 3, 2 war… 2, 1. Initialzündung. Der hat danach keine Sekunde mehr gespielt. Aber dieses Tor, sein Auftritt, war mitentscheidend für unseren Aufstieg, weil du einfach geil in die Saison kommst. So, dann fährst du zum KSC.
Richtig? Aachen.
Stimmt, Aachen. Genau, Aachen und dann KSC. Fährst nach Aachen. Genau. Eröffnung Tivoli. Die haben sich mit nichts anderem beschäftigt als der Tivoli-Eröffnung. Und kriegen fünf Buden. Und nach dem 3-0 sitzen wir auf der Bank, Timo Schulz, Florian Lechner neben mir, Eger auch, gucken uns an. Siehste? Und genau deswegen sitzen wir hier und die auf dem Platz. Völlig ohne Neid. Völlig ohne negative Stimmung. Einfach nur Jungs. Deswegen stehen die gerade auf dem Platz. Und das war für uns in dem Moment auch in Ordnung. Also das war die Stimmung halt innerhalb der Mannschaft. Das haben die Trainer hinbekommen, dass wir – natürlich saßen wir da nicht gerne, da müssen wir ja nicht drüber sprechen. Aber wir haben die Rolle akzeptiert und gleichzeitig wussten wir, hey, irgendwann sind wir dann dran. So, dann haben wir das Heimspiel gegen Duisburg, das war ein 2 zu 2 und dann fährst du Freitagabend zum KSC. Erstes Auswärtsspiel 5-0 gewonnen, zweites Auswärtsspiel 4-0 gewonnen. Und bis da – Geil. Das läuft. Und dann – ich weiß jetzt nicht mehr, was dann das nächste Spiel war – aber dann ging es halt los, dann hatte sich Fabio Morena schwer erkrankt, hatte eine Hirnhautentzündung und das war dann quasi mein Moment, wo ich dann gebraucht wurde und dann kam halt das Spiel beim FSV Frankfurt, wo ich Matzehain das Ding unhaltbar in Winkel schieße und dann aber trotzdem das Spiel noch gewinne. Dann hat Stani mich erstmal wieder rausgenommen, weil es halt ein ziemlich bescheidener Auftritt war. Oder ein unglücklicher Auftritt von mir war in der ersten Halbzeit. Die zweite Halbzeit war okay, aber die erste Halbzeit war gar nicht gut. Mein Gegenspieler hat mich auch doof aussehen lassen beim ersten Tor und dann das zweite Tore mache ich selber. Also es war ziemlich scheiße. Wir haben dann auf der Bank gesessen gegen Lautern und ab da habe ich dann gespielt. Also nach Lautern habe ich dann wieder gespielt. In Bremen? Genau, das war das. Und dann, wir waren einfach im Rhythmus drin und das war auch wichtig, dass wir das erste Spiel gewonnen haben. Dann fährst du nach Koblenz und zunächst einmal muss ich über das Aachenspiel nicht sprechen ohne auch das zu erwähnen. Das war dann natürlich, da hatten wir diesen sehr, sehr unglücklichen Zwischenfall mit dem einen Fan, der von der Tribüne gefallen ist. Das war das Spiel, wo natürlich im Prinzip die Freude darüber auch schon kommt, also getrübt ist, untertrieben. Es war alles weg, weil das sah ziemlich scheiße aus. Ich stand direkt da, als er runtergefallen ist und bin dann schnell reingelaufen, weil ich halt wusste, dass der Hohtrainer, der Aachener Christian Schmidt, mit dem ich ja selbst noch zusammengespielt habe, der damals schon Medizin studiert. Und ich wusste, dass er jetzt fertiger Arzt ist und bin halt sofort rein und hatte ihn rausgeholt und dann kam auch noch die Sanitäter, also die haben sich dann um alles gekümmert. Aber das war halt der äußerst negative Umstand bei dem Spiel. Glücklicherweise, wenn ich das richtig in Erinnerung habe, gibt es keine allzu schweren Folgeschäden für den jungen Mann. Also der hat das dann irgendwie noch Glück im Unglück gehabt. Zurück zum Sportlichen, dann waren wir aber rein sportlich total in diesem Flow drin. Das lief einfach. Sondern fährst du nach Koblenz 6 oder 7, was haben wir, 6?
5 und 1.
5 und 1? Nein, im Rückspiel waren es 7. 5 und 1 in Koblenz, wo du dann mit einer Selbstverständlichkeit einfach auf dem Platz stehst. Heute passiert sowieso nichts. Dann schießen die Alten Tor, dann schießen wir 2. Ist doch egal. Diese Selbstverständlichkeit, dieses Selbstvertrauen, dieses sehr, sehr positive Gefühl, das hat uns wirklich über die ganze Saison getragen.
Ihr habt schon auf viele Spiele klargewonnen. Überhause gegen FCA 3-0, in Fürth 4-1.
Ja gut, das war dann zum Schluss.
Das war dann zum Schluss, aber insgesamt haben wir einen Haufen soeben ergeben.
Das war das entscheidende Spiel. Es war permanent, wir und der FCA waren so auf 2 und 3, das war das erste Jahr der Relegation, waren so ein Punkt vor, ein Punkt zurück, Punkt gleich. Also es gab selten, dass sich eine Mannschaft deutlich abgesetzt hat. Und dann kam das Heimspiel gegen Augsburg, 30. oder 29. was war das? 30. Und das war ein klares 3-0. Ich habe da nicht mehr gespielt, weil ich hatte mir gegen Oberhausen einen Innenbandriss im rechten Knie zugezogen. Und dann gewinnen wir dieses Spiel aber wirklich klar und deutlich. Die Augsburger keinen Stich gemacht, überhaupt keinen Stich. Und da war uns klar, alles klar, jetzt bringen wir das Ding zu Ende. Jetzt passiert da nichts mehr. Und dann war das Ding in Fürth. Und das war ganz groß. Das war auf ganz vielen Ebenen ganz, ganz groß. Wir haben uns mit der ganzen Mannschaft oder mit den Jungs, die halt nicht im Kader waren, hatten uns dann so einen Bus gemietet und sind morgens um 7 Uhr in Hamburg losgefahren. Ich als Fahrer, weil die anderen relativ schnell nicht mehr hätten fahren dürfen, sagen wir es mal so. Und mit einem Rast an vielen Tankstellen und Fastfood-Buden und dann gibt es eine Fastfood-Kette, da kann man sich so Patronen mitnehmen und ein Teil des Buses war besetzt mit Königen. Ein ganz großer Spaß. Das erste Sixpack – ich glaube, wir waren noch nicht mal auf der Autobahn, da war das schon leer. Wir mussten das Spiel halt nur gewinnen. Dann waren wir aufgestiegen bzw. wir waren drei Punkte vor Augsburg, da hatten wir 18 Tore besser, also nach normalen Maßstäben aufgestiegen. Das war eine sehr, sehr amüsante Fahrt. Wir haben Witze gemacht nach dem Motto, weil unser dritter Torwart, Patrick Borger, saß auch im Bus. Wir haben Witze darüber gemacht nach dem Motto, weil jetzt müsste nur der Anruf von Stani kommen, weil er wusste, dass wir halt. Auch kommen. Und dann kommen wir in Fürth an und dann verletzt sich Matze Hein tatsächlich, aber während des Spiels. Also da war dann kein Wechsel mehr möglich. Aber es war halt, wenn das jetzt beim Warmachen passiert wäre und es hätte geheißen, Palli, du musst mal runter von der Tribüne. Den hätten wir mit zwei Mann stützen müssen. Da war nichts mit Fußballspielen und auch die Fans bei uns im Block. Wir waren halt im Fan-Block und da kam die auch so mal. Was ist denn? Hat der schon, ich sag, ja kann sein, dass der schon eine Cola getrunken hat. Ich weiß es nicht genau. Also wir haben uns da einfach dazwischen gemischt. Es war wirklich großartig. Die Fahrt war einfach Wahnsinn. Und dann kommen wir da an und dann läuft auf einmal David Hasselhoff in der Kabine und wir so, was ist denn hier los? Völlig Banane. Looking for Freedom. Aufklärung war die, dass Ebbe nicht mehr schlafen konnte mittags. Und hat dann die komplette Mannschaft geweckt, weil Ebbe war der DJ, Marius Ebers, und hat unsere Musikanlage auf den Flur gestellt und hat Looking for Freedom auf voller Lautstärke laufen lassen. Und das Lied war dann irgendwie so unser Aufstiegslied.
Das ist auch ein lässiger Move, wenn man selber nicht schlafen kann, erstmal alle anderen wecken. Das ist ehrlich gesagt so, wie es meine Kinder auch machen.
Und vor allem mit dem schlimmsten Lied. Zumindest nicht mit dem besten.
Wir können jetzt darüber streiten, aber ich finde das Lied gut. Vielleicht auch, weil ich natürlich jetzt ganz viele positive Dinge damit verbinde. Aber das lief dann auf allen Aufstiegsfeiern, das lief das Wochenende drauf gegen Paderborn im Stadion. Und das ist tatsächlich unser Aufstiegslied.
Und jetzt Hand aufs Herz. Hast du auch da dann keinen Tropfen Alkohol getrunken?
Keinen Tropfen. Seit Mai 2003 habe ich keinen Tropfen Alkohol mehr getrunken.
Bei keiner der Aufstiegsfeiern?
Keinen Aufstiegsfeiern, kein Silvester, kein Geburtstag, keine Hochzeit, kein gar nichts, irgendwas. Dieser eine Abend – kurz zur Erklärung – es war ein Abend, an dem ich es aber so dermaßen völlig unfassbar übertrieben habe, dass mich das wahrscheinlich auf ewig geheilt hat.
Ja, geil eigentlich. Das ist total gut, weil man kriegt ja alles perfekt mit. Ich kann mich auch noch an einen Geburtstag erinnern, wo alle dachten, ich trinke Kuba Libre, was mein Lieblingscocktail ist. Dabei war es einfach nur Cola mit Limetten. Das war der beste Trick meines Lebens. Und ich konnte dabei zugucken, wie alle auf einmal haben sie immer lauter gesprochen. Irgendwann haben die sich immer so angebrüllt und haben mitten im Satz das Thema gewechselt. Das war sehr, sehr lustig, mal zu gucken, wie das so ist.
Kannst du dir vorstellen, wie ich mich fühle? Und warum die meisten Partys für mich irgendwann zwischen eins und zwei einfach auch zu Ende sind?
Ja, das kann ich sehr gut verstehen. Aber man kann ja dann mit einer Fahrgemeinschaft mit Fahrern Urlaub bilden. Das ist dann ja auch nicht das Schlechteste. Wie wird dann so ein Aufstieg – wo wurde der Aufstieg dann gefeiert, wenn es sonst schon immer an den Ballermann ging?
Erstmal in Fürth. Okay, unsere Zuhörer aus Nürnberg und Fürth werden jetzt wahrscheinlich lachen.
War das nicht total schlimm, dass diejenigen, die mit dem Bus angereist sind, dann schon ordentlich einen im Tee hatten? Die hatten ja eine Art Aufstieg.
Kannst du mir glauben, die anderen haben das sehr, sehr schnell aufgehoben. Ja, und wenn du…
Na gut, nach 90 Minuten Profifußball reicht ja wahrscheinlich auch eine kleine Apfelschorle, die ein bisschen zu lang in der Sonne stand, damit du…
Wollte ich gerade sagen, wenn du 90 Minuten Fußball hinter dir hast, geht das auch sehr, sehr schnell. Und ja, es ging in der Kabine weiter, dann im Hotel, und dann haben wir irgendwas in der Altstadt gesucht und hatten dann so eine Bar oder so ein, weiß ich gar nicht mehr, gefunden. Und dann kam noch Billyskopf dazu, der zu dem Zeitpunkt in Fürth spielte. Und ja, dann haben wir halt ein bisschen Aufstieg gefeiert.
Für die es ja auch um nichts mehr ging. Also die sind im goldenen Mittelfeld der Tabelle gelandet. Das heißt, da konnte man da ein bisschen…
Das war halt Fürth zu der Zeit, ja. Und im Prinzip durchgemacht bis zum nächsten Morgen. Und eigentlich wollten wir ja mit dem Bus… Ich hatte den Bus hin- und zurückgemietet. Und habe mir nur gedacht, ey, wenn ich jetzt hier die ganze Nacht durchfeiere, ich kann morgen früh nicht auch noch 700 Kilometer zurückfahren. Also und hatte… hatte einen privaten Kontakt zum damaligen Autovermieter und habe ihm nur geschrieben, ich sage, sag mal, kann ich das Ding nicht hier irgendwo am Flughafen abstellen und dann lass uns mal den Vertrag quasi umschreiben auf One Way. Und dann buchen wir für uns alle auch noch, weil auf der Maschine war noch Platz. Klar, stell hin und dann könnt ihr da zurückfliegen, weil ich hab keinen Bock. Ich bin nicht geschlafen und dann musste ich noch mal 700 Kilometer fahren. Also musste nicht sein. So und dann zurückgeflogen und dann sind wir in Hamburg empfangen worden bei klassischem Hamburger Sommer, sprich Regen und haben frei bekommen bis Donnerstag. Sollten Donnerstag wieder alle fit sein. Das Problem war nur, dass am Donnerstag eine große Party in Hamburg war und viele der Jungs halt Donnerstag auch noch mal feiern waren. So wir haben am Montag haben wir im Olympischen Feuer da, unserem Strammerestaurant, haben wir die Glasfront zugeklebt und gefeiert inklusive, weiß ich nicht, auf dem Tischen, auf dem Tresen, also wirklich den Laden einmal auf links gedreht. Dienstag dann ein bisschen ruhiger, so ein bisschen. Mittwoch war dann schon, hat sich das ein bisschen zerstreut. Donnerstag sind nur noch die ganz harten Feiern gewesen. Und dann hatten wir am Samstag schon das, hatten wir Samstag oder Sonntag, weiß ich gar nicht mehr.
Letzter Spätag ist immer Sonntag.
Haben wir am Sonntag dann gegen Paderborn zuhause gespielt. Haben auch, sind auch in Führung gegangen, aber irgendwie zeigte sich dann in der zweiten Halbzeit so ein bisschen die Müdigkeit, dass das nicht unbedingt die professionellste Vorbereitung der Saison war auf dieses Spiel. Eigentlich schade, weil die Schale bzw. die Meisterfelge wäre halt greifbar gewesen, weil Lautern parallel gegen Augsburg gespielt hat. Ich glaube, unentschieden und wir mit einem Sieg quasi hätten Meister werden können. Haben es dann aber verpasst, gegen Paderborn zu gewinnen und haben dann im Stadion weitergefeiert. So und dann haben wir im Stadion gefeiert und dann sind wir mit dem Doppeldeckerbus auf den Kiez gefahren und das war unglaublich. Also das war wirklich Wahnsinn. Auf der Reeperbahn, weiß ich nicht, die Polizei sprach von irgendwas über 100.000 Menschen, ich kann das schwer einschätzen, wie viel das dann wirklich waren. Auf jeden Fall Reeperbahn oben und unten gesperrt und alles voller Menschen. Spielbodenplatz, drum herum, die ganzen Seitenstraßen, alles war voll. Unglaubliche Bilder, unglaubliche Empfindungen, wenn du dann auf diesen Balkon des Theaters kommst und schaust raus und siehst gar kein Ende der Menschenmassen. Das war dann auch wieder so ein Moment, wo ich sage, dafür machst du das Ganze also. Sehr, sehr schöne Empfindungen einfach. Aber viel interessanter war einfach dieses Gefühl, dass du jetzt Bundesliga spielst, erste Liga mit diesem Verein.
Und hat sich ja für dich wahrscheinlich auch ganz anders angefühlt, weil zum einen dieser Verein und zum anderen du hast die ja quasi mit nach da oben.
Ja, ich hatte schon dann – die Hälfte mir kurz – wie viele Spiele habe ich gemacht? 22, 20, 21, 21. Ich habe also da auch so meinen kleinen Teil dazu beigetragen. Dann tut so ein Aufstieg einfach sehr, sehr gut. Und ja, es war insgesamt einfach ein tolles Gefühl. Und dann startete das Unternehmen erste Bundesliga.
Wie war das dann jetzt nochmal zurück zu sein in der ersten Liga? Was hatte sich da verändert im Vergleich zur Mainzerzeit?
Eigentlich nicht so viel. Ich war halt einer der wenigen, die schon mal ansatzweise wussten, wie es in der ersten Liga abgeht. Ebbe hatte gespielt. Gut, dann kam Asamoah noch dazu. Aber ansonsten war es relativ überschaubar, was an Jungs, die die erste Liga schon kennen. Es war alles nochmal eine Stufe größer, weil das mediale Ding halt nochmal größer war als 2006. Aber ansonsten, ja, wir wussten halt, dass wir jetzt natürlich deutlich mehr im Fokus stehen und dass es nicht leichter wird. Auch für mich persönlich.
War es ja dann noch. Richtig. Ja, hinten raus dann auf dem 18. Tabellenplatz gelandet, aber eigentlich sehr vielversprechend gestartet. Eine gute Hinrunde und dann in der Rückrunde.
Mehrere Dinge, die da zum Tragen kommen. Erstmal allgemein oder sollen wir erstmal über meine Situation sprechen? Machen wir erstmal allgemein.
Ja, genau. Erzähl mal auch so ein bisschen, was man vielleicht darüber über den Abstiegskampf auch lernen kann jetzt. Denn das hat mir ja häufiger das Mannschaften in so einen negativen Strudel reingeraten. Und dann und in der ersten Hinrunde noch gerade als Aufsteiger über den Erwartungen spielen. Und dann aber irgendwann in der Rückrunde geht was verloren oder…
Am Anfang wirst du ja nicht ernst genommen, aber du bist halt der Neue, du bist der Neuling und man kennt dich noch nicht so und und und. Wir haben tatsächlich gut angefangen. Ich habe die ersten Spiele auch noch nicht mal im Kader. Und dann haben wir uns ein bisschen – oder was heißt ein bisschen – wir haben ordentlicher Ergebnisse geliefert. Nach hinten raus, dann auch nochmal mit Niederlagen gegen Mainz und den FC Bayern aus der Hinrunde. Und dann kam eigentlich der beste Rückrundenstart. Wir waren vor dem Spiel beim BVB die beste Rückrundenmannschaft. Wir haben aus fünf Spielen elf Punkte geholt, also drei Siege, zwei Unentschieden. Wir haben Köln, Gladbach und – wen haben wir noch besiegt? Ach so, natürlich. Das überlege ich dann da. Ich wollte es eigentlich nur von euch hören. Und dann den HSV besiegt. Das war auch geil, dass das Ding verlegt werden musste, weil die ihren Rollrasen nicht zeitnah oder rechtzeitig verlegt haben. Der Hamburger Sommer hat dem dann ein Strich durch die Rechnung gemacht, deswegen musste das verlegt werden. Also da eine geile Phase gehabt und dann sind wir nach Dortmund gefahren, wo ich ja ein Tor erzählt habe für die falsche Mannschaft. Und da ging es dann eigentlich los. Und das war aber losgelöst – bleibe ich dabei – das war losgelöst vom Derby. Viele Leute sagen, das Derby war der Auslöser. Nein, das hat damit nichts zu tun. Und dann viele Leute erzählen, ja, und das mit Stani, weil es war nicht klar, ob er bleibt. Das war so ein bisschen Hick-Hack über mehrere Wochen und dann, ja, ich gehe nach Hoffenheim. Und nein, das hat er überhaupt nicht reingespielt. Und wenn, dann nur unwesentlich. Weil, wenn man sich das Ganze mal sportlich anschaut, wir haben in diesen Wochen haben wir in Dortmund Bastian Ucipka verloren, Knöchelbruch. Wir haben in Nürnberg Carlos Zambrano verloren mit seinem Sehnenabriss im Oberschenkel. Das kam erschwerend hinzu. Aber du hast, solange die Viererkette stand und wir waren eingespielt, das waren Carlos und ich im Zentrum, das war auf der rechten Seite Markus Thorand. Es war nicht seine Lieblingsposition, aber er hat sie, in dem Konstrukt hat er sie richtig gut gespielt. Und wir haben links Bastian Ucipka gehabt, der damals schon wahnsinnig viel Potenzial hatte, mit unseren Sechsen davor, Matze Lehmann und Boller. Das stand. Wir haben da wirklich sehr, sehr gut gespielt. Und jetzt brechen dir halt immer wieder Spieler weg, die schon die beiden Langzeitverletzten. Und dann selbst die, die dann reingekommen sind, dann hat Tore sich verletzt. Also Markus Torrand hatte sich verletzt. So, dann musstest du die ganze Zeit hin und her schieben. Der FC Bayern und wahrscheinlich sieben, acht, neun andere Bundesligavereine, zehn, elf fangen das auf, dass sie zumindest nicht unten reinrutschen und nur noch verlieren. So, aber wenn du einen Umstand brauchst, dass alles zu 100 Prozent passt, wie es bei uns halt der Fall war, die Namen mögen jetzt sogar, behaupte ich, fast austauschbar sein. Also ob ich da jetzt über einen längeren Zeitraum spiele oder vielleicht Tore im Zentrum und ein anderer rechts, mir geht es jetzt gar nicht nur um die Namen. Aber wir hatten eine Kombination gefunden, die funktioniert hat und dann fällt die komplett auseinander. So zwei fallen ganz raus und das, was dann quasi ersetzend reinkommt, bricht auch immer wieder weg. Wir haben es danach nicht mehr geschafft, eine Viererkette über zwei Spiele zu retten, weil wir die ganze Zeit wechseln mussten. Das ist einfach ein Umstand, der dir so viel Qualität kostet, dass eine Mannschaft, wie wir, das halt nicht auffangen kann. Und dann kommst du halt auch in diesen… Richtig, in Wolfsburg. 2-2 war es, glaube ich. Und das war für mich einer der Hauptgründe, einer der entscheidenden Gründe, warum wir nach hinten raus einfach nichts mehr geholt haben. Weil, aus sportlicher Sicht, weil es da dann einfach nicht mehr gepasst hat. Weil wir haben den Laden nicht mehr dicht bekommen. Und als FC St. Pauli in der ersten Liga, ja, es muss halt wirklich nahezu… Ja, muss halt nahezu alles optimal laufen. Und gerade im Defensivverbund war es das nicht mehr. Weil mit Carlos und Basti zwei Säulen uns komplett weggebrochen sind. Und alles andere war dann immer wieder so ein… Die Jungs hatten auch keine Möglichkeit, in den Rhythmus zu kommen. Wie schon gesagt, dann war Markus Torand noch weg. Dann kommt Kalle Rothenbach aus einer Verletzung raus. Dann kommt Jan-Philipp Kalle aus einer Verletzung raus. Dann verletzen sie sich wieder. Dann müssen sie auf Positionen spielen, die vielleicht nicht ihre 100%ige Optimalposition ist und dann war ich einer derjenigen, die konstant gesprungen sind. Das war vor dem letzten Spiel. Das letzte Erstleger-Spiel war in Mainz. Das letzte Spiel am Bruchweg. Dann kommt Stani zu mir und sagt, ich habe mal nachgeguckt. Rechter Verteidiger fehlt dir noch bei uns. Also ich habe links, ich habe halb links und halb rechts. Ich sage richtig. Da weißt du was? Das Spiel zu heute.
Ja, stark.
Weil ich brauch dich auf rechts. Weil wir keinen Rechtsverteidiger an dem nachmittag. Und so lief das dann wirklich über einen längeren Zeitraum. Also nach dem Motto, okay, wir haben heute Mittwoch oder Donnerstag. Jetzt müssen wir mal gucken, wen haben wir denn fit zur Verfügung und wie basteln wir daraus eine Defensive. Und das funktioniert halt auf dem Niveau für einen Verein wie den FC St. Pauli sehr schwierig.
Kann man das dann eigentlich noch genießen, erste Liga zu spielen oder ist das so ein bisschen vergiftet durch den Abstieg dann? Du bist ja in den Stadien, in denen du eigentlich spielen willst. Ich meine, du jetzt schon zum zweiten Mal, aber viele aus der Mannschaft ja zum ersten Mal. Und du hast ja auch mit einem sehr, sehr guten Aufstieg das geschafft. Das war ja nicht irgendwie glücklich reingerutscht, sondern mega gute Offensive gehabt. Die hättet noch Meister werden können, hast du ja alles erzählt.
Ja, was heißt genießen? Also grundsätzlich haben wir schon jedes Spiel genossen. Aber wenn ich nur an das Spiel beim FC Bayern denke, wo nach fünf Minuten müssen wir eigentlich führen, weil wir eine riesengroße Chance haben, aber dann führen nicht wir, weil Finn Bartels in dem Fall den Ball übers Tor schießt und dann haut Altintop das Ding aus 22 Meter in Winkel. Und du fragst dich, weil das Spiel war dann schon eher auf Augenhöhe. Natürlich hatte der FC Bayern die besseren Fußballer, aber das waren halt andere Voraussetzungen als noch fünf Jahre vorher im DFB-Pokal. Und es klappt halt trotzdem nicht aus verschiedensten Gründen. Weißt du, dann kriegst du noch eine beschissene rote Karte. Gut, Thomas Kessler, das war halt wirklich eine Notbremse und dann machen sich es 2-0 und es 3-0. Und du ärgerst dich einfach, weil du weißt, mit ein bisschen mehr Glück wäre hier halt mehr drin gewesen. Ja, genießen. Natürlich habe ich es genossen, dann unten auf Schalke im Tunnel zu stehen oder im Tunnel in Dortmund zu stehen und gehst halt raus und blickst nach links und siehst halt diese gelbe Wand und spielst gegen Dortmund und da hat Klopp seine Mannschaft halt auch ganz clever eingestellt, weil er wusste natürlich, dass wir unter der Woche gegen den HSV gewonnen haben. Du hast halt wirklich gemerkt, es geht darum, uns nicht ins Spiel kommen zu lassen. Leute, die haben unter der Woche gespielt, die sind euphorie HSV, die kennen das nicht, geht von Anfang an drauf. Und ich habe auch das jetzt, eine Anekdote, eine Geschichte aus der Zeit, ich bin nach dem Spiel oder vor dem Spiel, nach dem HSV-Spiel, vor dem Dortmund-Spiel, bin ich zu Asa gegangen, also Gerard Asamoah. Ich sagte, wir brauchen dich am Samstag, weil es war nicht ganz klar, ob er fit wird oder nicht. Ich sagte, ich brauche dich da vorne, ich brauche diesen Anspieler, der aber auch Spieler bindet. Wenn Asamoah da steht mit seinem Kreuz, dann weiß ich, dass Subotage und Hummels zu tun haben. Den spiele ich an, der stellt den Körper zwischen, der verschafft uns mal Luft. Er konnte nicht, also seine Verletzung hat es nicht zugelassen und dann hat Richie Sucuta-Paso gespielt, auch jemand mit viel Potenzial zu dem Zeitpunkt, aber halt noch einfach sehr jung, keine Erfahrung. Den haben, muss man halt so sagen, da haben Neven und Mats ihn aufgefressen. Und dann hast du ihn angespielt und das war ja auch die meiste Saison. Das kommt noch dazu, das wollte ich auch noch erwähnen. Und dann kam der Ball postbendens zurück. Das war im Hinspiel genauso. Mein Hinspiel war mein erstes Spiel dann für St. Pauli in der Bundesliga. Die haben ein Vollgas-Fußball gespielt. Ich habe gedacht, wir wären drei Mann weniger. Und dann kommt, weiß ich nicht, wer auf dich zukommt. Kagawa kommt mit dem Ball auf dich zu und Götze hinterläuft und in deinem Rücken verschwindet Barrios. Und du weißt jetzt, ja, was machen wir jetzt? A, B oder C? Weil eigentlich alles drei der Zonk. So, gegen Mainz auch. Das war auch das Tucheljahr, die gefühlt hatten die drei Mann mehr. Dann fährst du nach München, dann verliert irgendeiner das direkte Duell und dann läuft Ribery mit Vollgas auf dich zu und Müller läuft im Rücken weg und links bietet sich Schweinsteiger an und du stehst da und guckst so deinen Innenverteidigerkollegen an, so nach dem Motto, wie lösen wir das jetzt? Ja, du kannst es natürlich genießen und das war auch schön, das war auch toll, du hast Raul angesprochen, er kannte dich aus dem Fernsehen. Der Junge hat 75 Champions League Tore oder so etwas. Du spielst gegen Van Nistelrooy, auch wenn er im falschen Trikot gespielt hat. Im Nachhinein sind das tolle Momente, die du mitgemacht hast, in dem Moment ist es einfach ein knallharter Job. Wir haben gerade über das Bayern-Spiel gesprochen, bevor wir zum Derby kommen. Da war die andere Szene, wo ich gemerkt habe, warum gewisse Spieler dann doch weiter schaffen als andere. Und zwar geht es um Bastian Schweinsteiger. Basti kenne ich noch aus der Jugend. Und wir haben in der 86, 87, einen Zweikampf an unserer Eckfahne mit ihm. Steht 3-0, ein Mann weniger, wir hatten ja die rote Karte von Kessler, ein Mann weniger und ich habe einen direkten Zweikampf mit ihm an der Eckfahne und der Ball geht ins Aus und der Linenrichter entscheidet oder der Assistent entscheidet, Einwurf St. Pauli. Und der regt sich auf, als hätte ihm gerade ein glasklares Tor geklaut. Und so im Vorbeigehen sage ich, ey Basti jetzt mach mal halblang zwei Minuten vor Schluss und ihr führt 3-0 mit einem Mal mehr, ist auch mal gut. Und dann dreht er sich um und schreit mich an, das ist mir scheißegal, ich will diesen Drecks-Einwurf. Wo ich sage, okay gut, wir können jetzt darüber streiten, ob dieser Einwurf jetzt zwingend wichtig ist. Aber es geht um die Denke dahinter, dass jede einzelne Situation – und das ist das, was ich auch auf Steven Gerrard eben meinte und erzählt habe – jede einzelne Situation zu 100 Prozent durchziehen. So und das ist halt der Grund, warum Basti vielleicht zwei, drei Schritte weitergekommen ist als viele andere.
Und wenn du es vorher schon tausendmal gemacht hast, dann schaffst du es nämlich auch im WM-Finale 2014. Vielleicht möchtest du noch über die Derby sprechen? Ich habe da so den Eindruck, du würdest sprechen, dass ihr gegen den HSV umgeschlagen wart in eure Bundesliga-Saison.
Ja, im Hinspiel haben wir – das war das Heimspiel – habe ich nicht gespielt, war ich auch nicht im Kader. Da war das Middlantor die paar Minuten, die wir geführt haben. Das war absolut Wahnsinn. In dieser Dauer so laut habe ich das Middlantor, glaube ich – Wo warst du da dann? Ich habe unten im Innenraum gesessen mit all den Jungs, die auch nicht im Kader waren. Das waren leider auch die, die damals bei dem Spiel – wir sind jetzt Bundesliga gucken – auch dabei waren. Da stand noch keine Rücksicht darauf genommen. Wir waren nicht dabei und haben uns das angeschaut. Die paar Minuten waren unglaublich. Dann kam einer der besten Fußballer, den der HSV in den letzten Jahren hatte, das muss man klar sagen, Petric, mit dem Ausgleichstreffer. Aber das Rückspiel war natürlich groß. Das war ziemlich groß. Die ersten Minuten waren für mich Kopfballtraining, weil der HSV viel mit langen Bällen gespielt hat. Mit Carlos hatten wir mit Van Nistelrooy gut zu tun. Erstaunlicherweise bin ich jemand, der sehr schnell Handschuhe anzieht. Gerade was meine Finger angeht, bin ich da sehr empfindlich. Wenn ich mal kalte Finger habe, kann es mich auswechseln, weil dann bewege ich mich aus Prinzip nicht mehr. Aber in dem Spiel, es war kalt, es war wirklich kalt, es war mir alles egal. Ich war wirklich vom, ich ziehe jetzt meine Fußballschuhe an und gehe raus, war ich komplett im Film. Also nicht nur ich, wir waren alle einfach im Film, weil es halt für uns mehr war als ein Bundesligaspiel. Und das hat, glaube ich, auch den Unterschied ausgemacht. Wir wussten, auf der anderen Seite stehen maximal drei Spieler, die es annähernd auch verstehen. Frank Rost im Tor, weil er einfach Profi durch und durch und von Ehrgeiz zerfressen. Ich sage es nicht gerne, David Jarolim, weil er auch durch und durch HSVer ist und durch und durch Profi. Und vorne von Nistelroy, weil voll gut Profi. Der kennt das Klassiko, aber der weiß einfach was, also ohne, dass ich das jetzt mit dem Klassiko vergleichen möchte, aber der weiß, was ein Derby bedeutet. Aber ansonsten war uns durchaus klar, für die anderen ist das ein normales Bundesligaspiel. Was ich auch keinem zum Vorwurf mache, überhaupt nicht. Weil es geht um drei Punkte. War aber unsere Chance. Und ja, der Genoss. Das war nicht schön. Also auch da wieder. Das war nicht schön, was wir gespielt haben. Aber wir haben uns in alles reingeworfen. Wir haben mit wahnsinnig viel Energie gespielt. Ich glaube, das Tor von Assa ist auch so ein bisschen ein Sinnbild fürs ganze Spiel, wie er da seinen Körper reinwuchtet und weiß gar nicht mehr wen quasi mit – See Roberto war es – war sie mit ins Tor reinwuchtet. Das kann man auch so ein bisschen als Sinnbild für das Ganze nehmen. Und in den letzten Minuten kam auch bei mir wieder dieses – und das habe ich Carlos auch gesagt und er war halt genauso drauf wie ich – Kommt halt. Kommt. Spielt die Bälle alle hoch rein. Wir köpfen sie alle raus. Und das hat dann auch gut funktioniert. Alle Bälle rausgeköpft. Immer war ein Fuß zwischen Beenen. Überragendes Spiel als Torwart gemacht. Und dann gewinnst du so ein Ding 1-0.
Wie schließt man denn so eine Saison ab? Also irgendwie ist man ja, egal wie eine Saison läuft, erstmal ist man ja froh, dass es vorbei ist.
Nach den Wochen, die dann folgten, mit nur einem Punkt aus zehn Spielen, willst du wirklich irgendwann, dass es nur noch vorbei ist? Wie schließt du es ab? Keine Ahnung. Ich habe ungelogen. Ich bin nach Hause gefahren, habe mich auf die Couch gelegt und habe vier Stunden die weiße Wand angeguckt. Das war... Ja, komplett leer. Das war nach dem Bayern-Spiel, weil dann sind wir ja nochmal nach Mainz gefahren, aber nach dem Bayern-Spiel war es ja dann auch rechnerisch fix.
1 zu 8, also das war ja richtig...
Das kam halt noch dazu.
Ich wollte gerade sagen, wie wirkt da die Höhe noch rein, aber wenn es dann...
Haum noch. Das spielt mit rein, aber eher aus dem Aspekt, dass du natürlich für Stani dir einen anderen Abschied gewünscht hast zu Hause. Aber den Bayern tat es ja fast leid. Sie haben sich die Spiele nach dem Spiel fast schon entschuldigt.
Ich kann mich an die Szenen nach dem Spiel erinnern.
Das war das einzige Spiel in der Rückrunde, in dem ich nicht gespielt habe. Ich weiß nicht, ob man das so sagen kann, aber nach dem 4. oder 5. habe ich auch gesagt, jetzt komme ich nicht auf die Idee, mich einzuwechseln. Denn in den Momenten kannst du auch nichts mehr richtig machen. Dir tut jeder einzelne Mitspieler leid, weil du die Situation einfach kennst, wie bitter das ist, wie hart. Aber du selber kannst da auch nichts mehr retten. Ich bin einfach nach Hause gefahren und wirklich froh, dass es dann rum war. Wobei dann halt für mich eine sehr schwere Zeit begann. Ein paar schwere Wochen. Weil? Weil Stani den Abschied nach Hoffenheim bekannt gegeben hat. Mein Vertrag lief aus. Und dann war halt die Frage, wie geht es denn weiter? Neuer Trainer André Schubert, Helmut Schulte als Sportdirektor, konnte schrägstrich wollte nicht entscheiden, wie es mit mir weitergeht. Ja, wir müssen gucken und was der neue Trainer sagt und hier und da. Und ich war jetzt da schon sieben Jahre da. Und hin und her. Und ich bin nach New York geflogen in Urlaub, ohne zu wissen, wie es weitergeht. Auch telefonisch gab es da, ja, wir müssen gucken und wir wissen noch nicht, wir müssen noch planen und und und. Und ja, dann meldete sich ein anderer Verein, die mich halt haben wollten. Wie sprichst du sie aus? Genau, die meldeten sich dann.
Wo hatten die damals gespielt? Das ist Vierteliga. Vierteliga, ja.
Die meldeten sich ja, wir haben mitbekommen, wie das so bei dir gerade abläuft.
Wer hat sich da gemeldet?
Das weiß ich nicht mehr. Das ist wirklich schon…
Nicht Ralph Rangnick, Kim Zell?
Nein, nein, nein.
Nee, nee, nee.
Damals war Pakul-Trainer. Irgendeiner seiner Assistenten, Kaderplaner, was weiß ich, was die alles haben. Und ja. Ja, und dann haben wir ja mitbekommen, wie das bei dir ist und wir haben ja dieses Projekt und wir wollen mittelfristig auch in die zweite Liga und dann schnellstmöglich in die erste Liga. Und mit deiner Erfahrung – ich war kurz vor dem 28. Deine Erfahrung hätten wir gerne hinten drinnen und Vertrag und dann vielleicht auch Anschlussvertrag bei – du weißt also quasi dem Unternehmen, das dahinter steht und…
Ich meine, gut, vielleicht wussten die natürlich, dass du dich einmal in der Maibaum-Nacht mit Energy-Drinks wachgehalten hast, aber ansonsten – glaubst du, dass die überhaupt auf dem Schirm hatten, dass das vielleicht für dich auch aus nicht-sportlichen Gründen gar nicht in Frage käme?
Also grundsätzlich, wenn wir bei Fußballverträgen über nicht-sportliche Gründe sprechen, sprechen wir wahrscheinlich über das Finanzielle – so, in erster Linie.
Das meinte ich jetzt gar nicht, aber in dem Aspekt.
Ja, ich weiß, was du meinst, aber ich meine nur, um das vielleicht auch mal zu erklären. Also, wenn ich meinen Bankberater, der würde mich wahrscheinlich schlagen, wenn ich ihm heute erzählen würde, was ich damals abgelehnt habe.
Hättest du besser verdient als in der ersten Liga?
Ich hätte deutlich besser verdient als in der ersten Liga. So, also, näher deutlich ist übertrieben, aber ja, ich hätte besser verdient.
Vor allem für die Relation fährt die erste Liga, ne?
Es ist dann schon – also, ich muss gestehen, du sitzt da am Telefon und der nennt dir die Zahlen und das ist ohne Verhandlung. Also, es ist jetzt nicht so, dass das – sondern einfach nur, pass auf, das ist mal so unsere – jetzt im Nachhinein weiß ich, dass es deren – das war so deren fixes Dings für die Liga, so fixes Salary für die Liga. Das haben sie dann ihren Top-Leuten, in Anführungsstrichen, bezahlt und überlegst und denkst du dir so, warte mal, ich verdiene in der vierten Liga mehr als in der ersten Liga bei St. Pauli. Gut, bei St. Pauli hast du jetzt keine Unsummen verdient, aber trotzdem war es halt erste Liga. Ich verdiene in der vierten Liga mehr als in der ersten. Wie ich schon gesagt habe, inklusive Anschlussvertrag für danach, und, und, und. Aber erstaunlicherweise bin ich nie ins Grübeln gekommen. Das war für mich zu keinem Zeitpunkt ein ernsthaftes Thema. Ich wurde auf der anderen Seite vom Verein in der Zeit, sagen wir mal, unglücklich behandelt von St. Pauli, weil halt hingehalten und keiner hatte die eierne Entscheidung zu fällen. Vor allem, eigentlich waren wir so weit, dass wir gesagt haben, wir verlängern, nur als Standi dann gesagt hat, er geht nach Hoffenheim, ist alles auf Eis gelegt worden. Dann fragst du dich halt schon, jetzt sind halt sieben Jahre, vergisst man die jetzt so schnell, dass jetzt der Sportdirektor nicht hingehen kann und sagt, pass auf, du bist hier einer der Jungs, die wir halten wollen, du bleibst. Und ich habe dann ein tatsächliches Bewerbungsgespräch mit André Schubert gehabt, haben uns im Mannschaftshotel getroffen und saß zwei Stunden da mit ihm, wie ich mir denn gewisse. Dinge vorstelle und wie das denn ist, wenn ich mal auf die Bank muss und wie ich denn – Das ist exakt, ja klar, finde ich super, auch kein Problem – Ja, aber – Was erwartet er da?
Siehst du dich in fünf Jahren?
Ja, in die Richtung ging es halt tatsächlich. Und nochmal, auf der anderen Seite hast du dann – Ein Angebot da liegen, das – Und warum kam es nicht wirklich in Frage?
Natürlich kommst du mit St. Pauli von einem Verein, wo einem auch gewisse Werte beigebracht werden und der steht ja auch für eine gewisse Art und Weise, wie man dieses Fußballgeschäft versucht, mitzuspielen, ohne sich sämtliche Fingerspitzen schmutzig zu machen. Aber auf der anderen Seite hast du ja auch eine private Zukunft, für die du vorsaugen musst. Du hast finanzielle Aspekte und ja auch eine Perspektive. Du wächstest ja nicht zu einem Vierteligisten, der in der vierten Liga bleibt, sondern es war ja schon damals abzusehen, jetzt nicht unbedingt genau die Geschwindigkeit. Aber du wusstest ja auch, naja, zwei Jahre dann da bin ich vielleicht schon wieder in der zweiten.
Ich würde mich als idealistischen Realisten oder als realistischen Idealisten bezeichnen. Du hast die Werte angesprochen, die du natürlich über eine lange Zeit bei St. Pauli einfach nicht nur mitgelebt, sondern auch mitgetragen und mitentwickelt hast. Und deswegen habe ich nicht ernsthaft darüber nachgedacht, dieses Angebot anzunehmen. Aus verschiedenen Aspekten sicherlich dumm, das mag sein, aber ich habe irgendwann für mich entschlossen, dass ich in meiner sportlichen Zeit und vielleicht jetzt auch in der Zeit danach – ich werde den Leuten nicht in Erinnerung bleiben, weil ich mit ihnen dreimal Deutscher Meister, fünfmal die Champions League oder andersrum und gehen wir einfach mal die Titelsammlung von Basti durch, Schweinssteiger. Der bleibt auf ewig in Erinnerung, aber auch wegen seiner Art und Weise. Andere Spieler verbindest du nur mit den Titeln. Mir war – und das habe ich bei St. Pauli dann einfach gelernt – wichtig, dass ich natürlich meinen Job als Fußballprofi ausübe und in erster Linie ist es ja auch das, was ich getan habe, aber darüber hinaus vielleicht auch Dinge bewegt, mitgetragen oder in irgendwelcher Form auch immer Fußstapfen oder Fingerabdrücke auf irgendwas hinterlassen habe, an die man vielleicht auch neben dem Fußball einfach gerne denkt. Und ich glaube, dass ich mir sehr, sehr vieles, wenn nicht sogar alles, was ich in den sieben Jahren – und ich will nicht sagen ich, sondern wir alle – in dem Bereich aufgebaut haben, umgestoßen hätte. Ich hätte sehr vieles unglaubwürdig gemacht. Ich hätte sehr viele Aussagen ja obsolet gemacht.
Und hast du auch mit der Begründung bei Leipzig dann abgesagt? Haben die das verstanden?
Ich habe einfach nur abgesagt. Ich habe gesagt, dass das für mich kein Thema ist und ich gerne beim FC St. Pauli bleiben würde. Obwohl zu dem Zeitpunkt noch nicht klar war, dass ich bleiben darf. Glücklicherweise ja, nach dem Gespräch mit André Schubert. Ja, wir verlängern um ein Jahr. Und hatte dann das Jahr verlängert. Aber mir war durchaus bewusst, dass es jetzt unter Schubert schwer wird, viel und häufig zu spielen. Was ja dann auch der Fall war, ich habe zwar 9 Spiele, oder waren es sogar 12, aber davon irgendwie… Ja, 11-12. Aber davon waren es auch, weiß ich nicht, fünf Auswechslungen oder so was, bzw.
ein Wechselspiele waren es.
12 Spiele und wie oft eingewechselt? Fünf Spiele waren es, also fünfmal eingewechselt von diesen 12. Es war halt nicht mehr zu vergleichen wie noch die Jahre vorher. Und dann war es im Winter so, dass ich ein Gespräch wieder mit dem Trainer hatte im Trainingslager in Valencia oder in der Nähe von Valencia und ja, wir müssen mal gucken, wie das im Sommer aussieht und also Perspektivgespräch auch, aber nichts halbes, nichts ganzes. Vielleicht auch, weil sie es nicht konnten. Wir hatten fünf Innenverteidiger und wussten selber nicht, wie es weitergeht. Aber zeitgleich erfahre ich dann, dass zu dem Zeitpunkt schon Gonta und Mohr zugesagt haben, die dann aus Palabon gekommen sind, die beiden Innenverteidiger. Und da war für mich dann klar, gut, da brauche ich mir jetzt nicht große Hoffnung machen, dass mein Vertrag noch verlängert wird. Und eigentlich ohne, ohne dass wir dann aktiv auf die Suche gegangen sind – also für mich kam ein Vereinswechsel eigentlich nicht in Frage – kam der Anruf von Harald Gärtner. Seinerzeit dann Geschäftsführer Sport beim FC Ingolstadt und der kam am 29. Januar. Dann ist ja nicht mehr so viel Zeit. Und dann rief mich mein Berater an, bzw. das war dann Sonntagmorgen nach dem letzten Testspiel gegen keine Ahnung, irgendeine spanische Mannschaft, haben wir Sonntagmorgen Training gehabt und ich hatte vier oder fünf Anrufe in Abwesenheit von meinem Berater und dann wusste ich, irgendwas ist. Ich ihn zurückgerufen, ja Ingolstadt hat angerufen, die wollen dich. Ich so, jetzt oder im Sommer? Jetzt. Ich so aufs Datum geguckt. Du brauchst jetzt aber nicht jetzt eine Antwort.
Naja, halbe Stunde.
Jetzt überleg mal, siebeneinhalb Jahre mit allen Aufs und Abs, das hat natürlich extrem zusammengeschweißt. Du hast dir viel aufgebaut und musst dann quasi auf Knopfdruck entscheiden. Ich sage, pass auf, wir legen jetzt auf, ich fahre nach Hause, Fahrzeit, rund um 20 Minuten. Gib mir mal ein paar Minuten. Lass mich zumindest die Fahrzeit überlegen. Komm nach Hause, steht meine damalige Freundin in der Haustür und guckt mich schon so an, so wartend. Dein Vater hat mich angerufen. Ich weiß es nicht. Ich wusste es. Also was willst du denn? Also so schnell, so eine Entscheidung, das ist ja eine gravierende, das ist eine einschneidende Entscheidung. Was willst du in dem Moment machen? Und habe wirklich zu Hause gesessen und ich wusste es einfach nicht. Ich habe meinen Vater angerufen, habe dann meinen Berater angerufen. Ich sage, pass auf, Trainer soll mich bitte mal anrufen. Der damals Thomas-Oral-Trainer gewesen. Ich möchte kurz mit dem Trainer sprechen. Die hatten ein Testspiel gegen Hoffenheim. Ja, der ruft dich danach an. Dann habe ich 20 Minuten mit Thomas-Oral telefoniert und es war wirklich eine unglaublich schwere Entscheidung. Es war sehr, sehr schwer für mich, diese Zeit einfach zu beenden. Aber da kommt dann der Realist in mir durch, wo ich dann aber auch weiß, okay, die Zeit ist in einem halben Jahr hier zu Ende. Das wird nicht weitergehen. Also da muss schon sehr, sehr viel passieren, damit es weitergeht. Mach das. Es ist schwer, aber wer weiß, ob du in einem halben Jahr wieder so eine durchaus interessante, attraktive Möglichkeit bekommst. Ja, Ingolstadt war zu dem Zeitpunkt im Abstiegskampf. Aber es war halt wieder auch dieses Gefühl, wir wollen dich haben. Wir brauchen deine Qualität. Du sollst die Abwehr stabilisieren und und und. Also wieder dieses Gefühl, gebraucht zu werden, eine wirkliche Aufgabe an die Hand zu bekommen. Und dann haben wir dem Verein Bescheid gesagt, also St. Pauli, und dann saß ich mit Schulter am nächsten Morgen – das war ein Montag – zusammen im Büro und so ein bisschen hin und her. Und dann sagte der Ralph, pass auf, du hast dich hier immer korrekt verhalten und wir wollen dir da jetzt auch keine Steine in den Weg legen. Wir haben die Lösung gefunden – klassische Fallaufhebungsvereinbarung – und dann musste ich schon nach München fliegen. Das war jetzt mal auch aus privater Sicht gesprochen, das war halt nicht leicht, weil du hast ja dann auch eine Freundin zu Hause sitzen, der musst du dann sagen, ich bin jetzt mal von jetzt auf gleich weg. Es gab keine Möglichkeit, dass sie mitkommt. Wann sehen wir uns wieder? Keine Ahnung. Ich wusste es ja wirklich nicht. Ja, und wann? Weil sie war halt Polizistin und war halt gerade im Einsatz, ganz normale Tagesschreife. Und wann? Ich fahre jetzt zum Flughafen. Ohne Tschüss zu sagen oder sowas. Ja, gut, dann haben wir uns kurz in der Stadt getroffen. Sie halt in ihrer Polizeieuniform. Wie willst du dich da groß… Ja, schön dich zu sehen. Und wann sehen wir uns wieder? Mal gucken, wann es passt. Das nur als kleine private Randnotiz, das spielt da trotzdem alles irgendwie mit rein, weil die Situation keine leichte ist. Ja, und dann bin ich nach Hause, habe zwei Taschen gepackt, wirklich so mit zwei Jeans, ein bisschen Unterwäsche, Socken, T-Shirts, Pullover, Winterjacke, Fußballschuhe eingepackt und nach München geflogen. Und war dann in München. Musste dann die sportmedizinische machen und am nächsten Tag trainiert. Ich habe in den zwei Tagen 2, 5 Kilo abgenommen, weil das so viel Stress war und auch so viel hin und her. Das war halt eine krasse Geschichte, aber es ging zu dem Zeitpunkt nicht anders. Wenn ich geblieben wäre, wäre ich ein halbes Jahr später da gestanden und hätte möglicherweise gar nichts gehabt.
Hat bei der Entscheidung nach Ingolstadt zu gehen die Struktur des Vereins auch eine Rolle gespielt. Ich meine, du hattest natürlich viel weniger Zeit und das ist nochmal eine ganz andere Ecke als Leipzig. Aber es gibt natürlich genügend Fans, die das schon über einen Kamm scheren. Also das Verhältnis von Audi zu Ingolstadt ist ein anderes. Auch sehr viel reduziert und der Verein existiert quasi nicht, um ein Produkt zu bewerben. Aber hat das eine Rolle gespielt bei den Überlegungen?
Darüber habe ich mir auch Gedanken gemacht, ja. Ich bin aber genau zu dem Entschluss einfach gekommen, dass ich da schon noch Unterschiede sehe und muss sagen, mir sind auch keine negativen Reaktionen von St. Pauli-Fans bekannt, was den Wechsel angeht. Ich habe natürlich sehr viele Reaktionen über meine sozialen oder zu dem Zeitpunkt war es nur Facebook bekommen, aber da war nichts Negatives im Sinne von Söldner oder irgendwas in die Richtung. Insofern glaube ich, dass die allermeisten da schon differenzieren können.
Ja, das wäre, glaube ich, bei Leipzig definitiv anders gewesen. So, jetzt bist du in Ingolstadt. Ich habe kaum zu glauben, dass wir jetzt bei deiner letzten Profistation angekommen sind. Wie kannst du die Jahre zusammenfassen, die Zeit da?
Also das erste halbe Jahr, das war ja dann die Rückrunde, war, ja, ich wurde geholt einfach, um die Klasse zu halten. Wir haben auch, glaube ich, sechs, sieben, acht Spiele zu Null gespielt. Duftig konnte ich meinen, ja, ihr guckt jetzt bitte wieder nach und korrigiert mich.
Eine Frage, man sieht das im Saisonverlauf ganz gut, dass es wirklich so ab der Winterpause dann stetig nach oben ging und letztendlich dann so auf einem stabilen 13.12.
Platz geendet ist. Für mich persönlich war es insofern schwer, dass ich – ich habe zuerst im Hotel gelebt, ich bin kein Mensch, der dauerhaft im Hotel leben kann – plus der Druck war enorm. Weil wir saßen dann, als ich angekommen bin, abends saßen wir dann im Restaurant und da waren Thomas Oral da und Thomas Linke plus der damalige Chefscout und meine Wenigkeit und mein Berater und Thomas Linke sagte, Ralf, wir brauchen da hinten jemanden, der den Laden zusammenhält mit Billys Kopf, der die Jungs heiß macht, der – du hast Erfahrung, kannst du das? Also schon wirklich ganz offensiv mir klargemacht, was da von mir erwartet wird und das habe ich immer wieder auch gespürt, gar nicht mal im negativen Sinne, aber ich habe es gespürt und ich habe es immer wieder gesagt und gezeigt bekommen, dass da viel verlangt wird und das war nicht leicht, weil die Mannschaft sehr, sehr verunsichert war. Wir haben es dann auch wieder da, nicht mit schönem, aber mit zumindest erfolgreichem Fußball, auch vielen zu Nullergebnissen geschafft, ganz unten rauszukommen und endgültig klargemacht haben wir es, glaube ich, im Heimspiel gegen den KSC und da war allen bewusst, rechnerisch noch nicht, aber hey, wir brauchen noch einen Punkt aus drei Spielen oder irgendwie sowas war die Konstellation. War es so, dass ich mich nicht freuen konnte. Ich bin nach dem Spiel, ich konnte mich nicht wirklich freuen, ich musste, ganz im Gegenteil, ich musste sogar aufpassen, nicht auf den Platz loszuholen, weil in dem Moment so viel abgefallen ist, sportlich und auch privat. Alles, was du quasi auf dich genommen hast, das war dann der Moment, wo du sagst, ok, jetzt hat es sich, dafür hat es sich gelohnt, aber du kannst dich nicht freuen, weil dann nur Leere da ist. Keine Erfüllung, sondern Leere, dass du diesen Ballast abwerfen konntest. Ich bin rein in die Kabine und habe mein Handy genommen und bin unseren Gang komplett nach hinten durch. Da war so ein Seitenausgang, da sind wir vor dem Spiel, kommst du da mit dem Bus rein und gehst dann in die Kabine. Da bin ich einfach nur in die Ecke gesetzt und habe mich, glaube ich, eine halbe Stunde nicht bewegt, weil ich einfach runterkommen musste, einfach alleine sein und mit der Situation erstmal klarkommen, weil es für mich schon eine sehr, sehr außergewöhnliche Situation war. Ich habe dann die Saison vernünftig zu Ende gespielt und dann hatten wir den Wechsel zu Marco Kurz. Das war so eine Konstellation, die hatte halt nicht hundertprozentig gepasst aus verschiedenen Gründen. Er hat eine ganz eigene Auffassung, was das Trainingskonzept angeht, was die Trainingsbelastung, Trainingssteuerung angeht. Es war eine unglückliche Konstellation, sagen wir es mal so. Mehr muss man dazu auch gar nicht verlieren. Genau, wir haben jetzt ein Jahr mit Thomas Oral übersprungen.
12.13 war noch, das war so ein bisschen eine doch wachsende Saison. 13.14 war dann noch mal so abstiegsgefährdet.
Das war unter Kurz. Ja, die zweite Saison mit Thomas Oral war ganz normale Saison.
Was ich ganz interessant finde, ist, es wirkt ein bisschen so, als ob diese Momente der Leere und die Wand anstarren und dass sich das Ganze eher als Belastung anfühlt. Das nimmt ja so ein bisschen zu in den letzten Jahren. Liegt das nur an den sportlichen Situationen, was da jeweils um Abstieg ging? Oder ist es auch, dass man, wenn man in einem höheren Alter ist, du weißt ja, deine Karriere wird nicht mehr ewig dauern, so eine gewisse Leichtigkeit ist weg. Gleichzeitig hast du vorhin ja schon beschrieben, dass sich auch das Verhältnis zum Körper da verändert. Man steckt nicht mehr alles so leicht weg. Wird die Last einer Profi-Karriere nach hinten hin schwerer?
Ich glaube, es ist eine Kombination aus allem. Wenn du am Anfang nur mitläufst, ist das eine Geschichte oder die andere Geschichte. Du trägst das Ganze mit, bist auch mit in der Verantwortung. In dem Moment, wo du mit in der Verantwortung bist, hast du einen ganz anderen Bezug zur Aufgabe. Und das ist es plus die Erfahrung, die du einfach gesammelt hast, weil du den Grad der Auswirkungen in beide Richtungen besser einschätzen kannst als jemand, der noch nie abgestiegen ist und das mit 19, 20 erlebt und dabei zwei Spiele in der Saison gemacht hat. Für den ist das kein riesen Weltuntergang. Das war zum Beispiel der Abstieg aus Mainz. Der tat mir leid. Ich war auch traurig. Aber wenn ich gesehen habe, wie ein Marco Rose oder ein Dimo Wache, die schon Jahre das mitgetragen haben und die Erfahrung haben, die hat das viel mehr mitgenommen. Das ist einfach naturgemäß eine Frage von mehreren Komponenten. Später war es ja dann eher so, dass ich auch eher eine mittragende Figur war. Nicht unbedingt die zentralste, aber eine mittragende, eine wichtige Figur in dem Ganzen. Und du dementsprechend auch den Druck viel mehr spürst. Und mit dem musst du lernen, umzugehen.
Welche Techniken hast du da entwickelt, um damit umzugehen?
Was eint alles, was ich erzählt habe, was ich gemacht habe? Alleine sein und Ruhe. Ich bin da jemand, der gar nicht groß erzählen und reden muss. Es ist auch nicht so, dass ich das in mich reinfresse, aber ich verarbeite es für mich. Mir geht unheimlich viel durch den Kopf und ich lasse einfach den Kopf denken, ich lasse den Kopf arbeiten. Das ist wie so ein ganz hoher Berg mit ganz vielen Bausteinen, wo du eine Mauer oder ein kleines Häuschen basteln musst. Das ist ein großer Berg und irgendwo musst du anfangen und dann fängst du an und nimmst das Steinchen und das passt dann dazu und das passt dann dazu. Und irgendwann wird aus dieser großen Unordnung ein systematisches Mäuerchen der Struktur her.
Ist das auch eine der Situationen, in denen du dann Videospiele spielst?
Nein, Videospiele, ein großer Freizeitvertreib von mir, eine große Beschäftigung, aber nicht in solchen Momenten. Nein, da bin ich wirklich, weil in der Zeit kann ich keine Struktur schaffen, weil da bin ich aufs Spiel fokussiert, das ist vielleicht als Ablenkung, aber ich schaffe es nicht, dann Struktur und Ordnung reinzubringen, sondern da brauche ich dann einfach die Zeit für mich und habe das dann immer so gehandhabt.
Du hast jetzt vorhin selber schon vorwärts geskippt, zur Zeit unter Phasenhütteln. Was war da so am einprägsamsten? Es gibt ja auch ein paar Trainer, die sind der Hotshit aktuell in der Liga. Ist er es denn zu Recht?
Also da habe ich jetzt eher so ein, zwei spaßige Dinge zum erzählen, um mal wieder ein bisschen humorvoller zu werden. Zunächst mal von Anfang an jemand, der immer versucht hat, den Spaß am Fußball zu vermitteln, der auch entwickeln kann. Der ist zu uns gekommen und hat gesagt, okay, ich kann jetzt nicht von jetzt auf gleich die ganze Mannschaft auf den Kopf stellen und hier alles verändern. Sondern wir gehen jetzt einfach mal einen Schritt zurück. Wir stärken die Defensive. Wir sind, wir standen extrem kompakt. Es war unheimlich schwer, gegen uns ein Tor zu schießen. Und von da aus, wir haben die Spiele auch nicht hoch gewonnen, aber wir haben sie gewonnen. Wir haben viele 1-0 über die Zeit gerettet, weil es halt schwer war, gegen uns ein Tor zu erzählen. Und das hat er dann sehr, sehr gut geschafft. Wollte dann im Jahr drauf, bzw. hat die Mannschaft dann komplett stabilisiert. Und hatte dann auf der Innenverteidigerposition auch ein paar andere Ideen. Also ich war, die Anfangszeit haben Marvin und ich, Marvin Martip und ich, die Innenverteidigerposition gebildet. Ich war auch zum Teil Kapitän. Marvin und ich haben uns das quasi aufgeteilt. Und ich weiß noch, dass er nach dem zweiten Heimspiel, glaube ich, zu mir kam. Ich bin kein Vertreter der Innenverteidiger, die über zehn Kilometer pro Spiel laufen. Ganz im Gegenteil. Die Strecke war jetzt nie meine große Stärke. Da spielt dann natürlich auch die Erfahrung ein Stück weit eine Rolle. Ich habe einfach gemerkt, so mit 28, 29 spätestens dann in Ingolstadt, auf dem Platz, mich kannst du da gar nicht mehr nervös machen, weil ich die Situation viel… Du bekommst einen ganz anderen Blick auf den Fußball, wenn du mit einer gewissen Ruhe und Erfahrung auf den Platz gehst und Situationen antizipierst, dass du schon sehr, sehr viel im Vorwege quasi vorbereiten kannst, dass du nachher nicht mehr diesen 40 Meter sprint, sondern jetzt musst du nur noch 15 Meter laufen und spielst den Ball, weil du halt weißt, dass er genau in die Ecke kommt, gehst halt hin und spielst den Ball zu deinem Rechtsverteidiger, weil du ihn abgelaufen hast. Also das hat sich auch extrem verändert im Laufe der Zeit. Und dann kam er zu mir und sagte, Ralph, warum läufst du denn so wenig? Ich sagte, Trainer, nur eine Gegenfrage. Haben Sie das Gefühl, dass ich in irgendeiner Situation gefehlt habe? Ich dachte, nein, das war auch gar nicht als Vorwurf gemeint. Aber ich finde das immer wieder spannend. Er sagte, ich habe immer einen Spieler gehabt, der hat das genauso gelöst. Das war ein Ahlen Benjamin Hübner, der halt auch nicht unbedingt so das große Laufgenie ist. Aber Benny ist halt auch ein unfassbar intelligenter Fußballer, der sehr zweikampfstark ist, sehr, sehr kopfballstark, jetzt auch eine geile Entwicklung in Hoffenheim genommen hat, aber der halt auch sehr gut antizipiert. Und wenn du das kannst, verbunden mit Erfahrung, dann musst du halt auch nicht neun Kilometer laufen. Das war immer sehr interessant zu sehen. Wir haben ja immer die Auswertung nach dem Spiel bekommen. Wenn ich bei Standards eingeteilt war, bei Ecken und Freistößen nach vorne mitzugehen, war ich immer über neun Kilometer, weil der Wert wird auch gemessen. Wenn der Ball auch im Out ist, werden die vollen 90 Minuten gemessen. Wenn du dann von hinten nach vorne läufst, das sind halt mal eben 50, 60 Meter, plus zurück 70 Meter bis über 120, 130, drei Freistöße, vier Ecken, dann bist du auch mal eben bei 700, 800, 900 Meter und dann kommst du über neun Kilometer. Ansonsten war das nicht der Fall. Das war das eine und das andere. Großartige Geschichte, ich weiß, dass es keine Absicht war, hatte er dann auch später gesagt, ich habe es ihm mal erzählt. Wir haben bei Union gespielt, ich saß auf der Bank und dann hat sich Marvin Martip nach vier Minuten, fünf Minuten, sechs Minuten das Schlüsselbein gebrochen. Und bei Union ist es so, dass die Ersatzbänke sind so zwei Stufen runter, ähnlich wie in England und ich guckte, drehte sich um und Michael Henke sagte, mach dich warm oder mach dich fertig, ich war ja noch warm vom Warmmachen vor dem Spiel, mach dich fertig und ich ziehe so, mach so den rechten Fuß auf die obere, auf den oberen Treppenabsatz und bind mir die Schuhe, mach den Schiemannschuhener rein und dann dreht sich der Trainer zu mir, Hasenhüttl und sagt so über meinen Kopf hinweg, aber ich stehe halt einen Meter vor ihm oder knieder, sagt er, das ist das Schlimmste, was uns passieren konnte. Und ich gucke ihn an und ich gucke Daniela Costa an und er so mit großen Augen, hat er das jetzt wirklich gesagt? Ich weiß, wie er es gemeint hat. Natürlich ist das komplett beschissen, wenn dein Kapitän und Säule in der Innenverteidigung sich nach vier Minuten das Schlüsselbein bricht. Natürlich ist das das Schlimmste, was passieren kann. Aber jetzt stehst du vor deinem Innenverteidiger, den du einwechselst und sagst das laut. Mir persönlich mit 30 Jahren war das völlig scheißegal, weil ich natürlich wusste, wie er es meint und ich auch sehr gut damit umgehen kann. Aber jetzt lasst doch mal einen 20-jährigen Nachwuchsspieler stehen. Den brauchst du gar nicht einwechseln. Dem schlottern doch komplett die Knie. Danny sagte selber – da Costa war zu dem Zeitpunkt sehr jung – weil er hat das zuerst nicht so verstanden, weil er es in meine Richtung gesagt hat. Also er hat mich mehr oder weniger angeguckt und hat das gesagt. Danny hat das so verstanden, als hätte der Trainer mich gemeint. Wo ich dem nachher auch gesagt habe, Danny, pass auf, bei solchen Aussagen, Trainer während des Spiels nicht ernst nehmen, das passt dann schon. Und ich habe es ihm dann ein paar Wochen später, habe ich gesagt, Trainer, wissen Sie eigentlich, was Sie da gesagt haben? Nee, was denn? Ja, so und so. Und dann, ja, nee, so war es nicht gemeint. Ich sage ja, ich weiß das, aber wenn da halt ein 19- 20-Jähriger spielt, der vielleicht noch nicht die Erfahrung hat, das ist nicht die beste Motivation für so ein Bundesligaspiel für den Jungen. Aber ansonsten zu Hasennütten und zur Frage, relativ kurz, er schafft es wirklich, die Spieler dahin zu bringen, dass sie am Samstag, am Sonntag, am Freitagabend 100 Prozent abrufen. Und erinnert euch an die Spiele der Ingolstädter in unserem Aufstiegsjahr, auch in dem ersten Bundesligajahr, wo man den Klassenhalt geschafft hat. Die Mannschaft hat immer Vollgas gegeben, die Mannschaft hat immer voller Leidenschaft gespielt. Und man kann jetzt, wir bleiben jetzt mal beim Sportlichen, das kannst du den Leipziger nicht vorwerfen, dass sie, oder du kannst den Leipziger nicht absprechen, dass sie nicht, dass sie da nicht zu 100 Prozent auf dem Platz stehen und die Mannschaften, die Mannschaften wirklich überrennen.
Das ist halt die Frage, ob man es auch mit dem Drei-Tages-Rhythmus schafft, aber das werden wir ja beobachten können.
Eben, das ist eine andere Frage, ja.
So, jetzt gehen wir ja langsam aufs Karriereende hin. Hast du denn, und ich weiß jetzt schon, dass du ja jetzt schon in Richtung Trainer denkst und und so weiter, hast du das schon so am Ende deiner Karriere auch schon, hast du deine Trainer da schon anders beobachtet, bist du anders zum Training gegangen oder hat sich dieser Gedanke erst danach geformt?
Also der Gedanke Trainer zu werden, den hatte ich schon was länger, habe zum Schluss aber auch immer versucht, Dinge zu verstehen im Hinblick auf, ich mache nicht nur die Übung, weil der Trainer mir sagt, wir machen jetzt diese Übung, sondern auch den Sinn dahinter zu sehen und den Sinn vor allem in einem größeren Kontext zu sehen, weil das baut ja auch alles aufeinander auf, so eine Trainingswoche. Es ist nicht einfach nur, die stehen da morgens nicht und überlegen, was haben wir heute, was machen wir morgen, morgen machen wir mal ein bisschen Torschuss und übermorgen ein bisschen Flanken und mal schauen, vielleicht können wir uns auch noch um die Abwehr, sondern da steckt ein Prinzip hinter, da steckt, ich will nicht sagen, es ist auch eine Wissenschaft, aber da steckt ein Konzept dahinter und das immer wieder zu erkennen. Dann war es halt so, durch meinen Kreuzbandriss, also zunächst mal, um das kurz zu beleuchten, ich habe mir am 2.4. das Kreuzband gerissen und auch da wieder, realistischer Idealist oder andersrum, ich wusste genau, was es bedeutet. Ich wusste, dass das Ding jetzt durch ist und das war das, was mir einfach so wirklich auch wehgetan hat, weil da könnt ihr auch alle Reha-Trainer oder alle, die in der Reha mit mir zu tun haben, fragen. Zu keiner Sekunde gab es den Moment, dass ich weniger gemacht habe oder dass ich nicht zu 100 Prozent versucht habe, zurückzukommen. Aber – und das ist der realistische Part – ich bin lang genug im Geschäft gewesen, um zu wissen, was es heißt, mit 32 aus einem Kreuzbandriss rauszukommen. Mit auslaufendem Vertrag, mit einer Mannschaft, die sehr wahrscheinlich in die erste Bundesliga aufsteigen wird. Dafür kenne ich das Geschäft so gut, dafür habe ich zu viel erlebt, im positiven wie auch im negativen Bereich. Insofern war der Moment der Diagnose für mich sportlich mit das Schlimmste, was ich persönlich erlebt habe, weil die Frau, die Radiologin, sie sagte wortwörtlich, Herr Gunesch, ich habe keine guten Nachrichten für Sie, Ihr vorderes Kreuzband ist gerissen. Das hat sie wortwörtlich gesagt, für mich hat sie gesagt, ihre Karriere ist vorbei. Und dieser Moment war mit das Schlimmste, was ich in meinem sportlichen Leben je erlebt habe, weil ich es mir gerne selbst ausgesucht hätte und ich hätte gerne auch noch weiter gespielt. Trotzdem bin ich sofort hin und habe noch am selben Tag Abend versucht, die bestmögliche medizinische Betreuung, die bestmögliche Rehabilitationsbetreuung und einfach auf die Beine zu stellen, um nachher sagen zu können, du hast es probiert. Weil da bin ich halt keiner, und das siehst du ja auch hier, da bin ich halt keiner, der da aufgibt. Das mag jetzt vielleicht für den einen oder anderen komisch klingen, weil man sagt, ja, aber wenn du schon mit so einer Einstellung rangehst, dann kann das ja nichts geben. Da halte ich persönlich gegen, weil ich mich natürlich kenne und wenn dann Oliver Schmidlein zu dir kommt, der beim FC Bayern gearbeitet hat, der bei der deutschen Fußball-Nationalmannschaft gearbeitet hat, der jetzt eine Rehapraxis in München hat, bei dem ich dann die weiterführende Rehabilitation gemacht habe und sagt, Ralf, das, was du hier abgeleistet hast, das habe ich lange nicht mehr von einem Profisportler erlebt, kann das halt nicht so falsch gewesen sein. Ich wollte es auf jeden Fall um jeden Preis versuchen, habe mich aber von Anfang an auch im Kopf darauf vorbereitet, dass es nichts mehr wird. Alles andere wäre auch meiner Meinung nach fahrlässig gewesen. Wenn ich hingegangen wäre, hätte ich mich nur auf die Rea konzentriert und hätte sowieso einen Verein und einen Berater gehabt, der mir das noch erzählt hätte und ich finde etwas und und und, dann wäre ich ziemlich hart gefallen. Und ich glaube nicht, dass das was, also nicht nur ich glaube nicht, das hätte nichts an meiner Situation verändert.
Was mich gerade ein bisschen überrascht hat, du hast gesagt, ich habe dann die bestmögliche Betreuung organisiert. Ist das was, was man in so einer Situation als Profi-Spieler deshalb auch selber macht, weil man die bestmögliche Lösung will? Ist das was, was normalerweise der Verein machen würde?
Sowohl als auch. Sowohl als auch. Also grundsätzlich wollen ja alle die bestmögliche Lösung für diesen Fall haben. Ich hätte auch von Vereinsseite aus zu Doktor oder Professor, weiß ich gar nicht, Böhnisch gehen können in Augsburg, der ja auch kurz vorher Kidira operiert hat. Da gab es auch den Kontakt. Aber ich habe gesagt, dass ich in Hamburg operiert werden möchte, weil ich da die Mannschaftsärzte von St. Pauli noch kannte, die ausgewiesene Knie-Experten sind. Da spielt auch einfach das persönliche Gefühl eine Rolle. Und das war auch abgesprochen mit dem Verein. Und der Mannschaftsarzt sagte auch, normalerweise entscheiden wir das. Aber bei einem Spieler in deinem Alter und mit der Erfahrung, da vertrauen sie halt auch darauf, dass ich auch weiß, was für mich gut ist. Die Ärzte sind jetzt keine Baxalber, sondern es ist bekannt, dass das gute Ärzte sind. Insofern gab es da überhaupt kein Problem. Das Einzige, was halt war, dann die Reha. Da habe ich die ersten Wochen in Hamburg gemacht. Nur als es dann tatsächlich ans Körperliche ging, an die körperliche Arbeit, dann war ich hier in München bei Olli Schmidlein dreimal die Woche. Also Montag, Mittwoch, Freitag. Und Dienstag, Donnerstag, Samstag beim Verein. Weil da dann die ganz enge Abstimmung zwischen Verein und Schmidlein war. Zwischen dem Athletiktrainer und Oliver Schmidlein. Und das ist dann nur eine Frage der Koordination.
Und dann war es vorbei. Es hat sich ja so ein bisschen für dich angekündigt. Wir haben vorhin ein O-Ton gehört. Das war bei einem Hallenturnier im Winter, glaube ich, dann. Und ich glaube, hast du es nicht bei Bundesliga selbst dann irgendwann verkündet? Ich glaube, das habe ich sogar gesehen.
Ja, es war ja so, an dem Tag, wie schon mal 2. April, am 4. April war die OP. Am 2. April rief abends noch Thomas Lincoln und sagte, du machst dir keinen Kopf. Dein Vertrag wird auf jeden Fall verlängert. Das ist dann meistens so von Vereinsseite aus. Der Verein hat natürlich da kein Risiko, aber lässt den Spieler auch nicht im Stich stehen, im Regen stehen. Kein Risiko bedeutet in dem Fall, wir sind ja nach sechs Wochen, sind wir ja dann auf Versicherungsfälle. Das heißt, der Verein hat keine Kosten mehr mit uns. Erst, wenn wir wieder gesund geschrieben werden, kosten wir wieder was. Ich bin dem Verein auch dankbar, weil die Versicherung hätte zum Beispiel nicht weitergezahlt, wenn ich keinen Vertrag gehabt hätte. Die zahlen immer nur für die Vertragsdauer. Das heißt, wenn der Verein dann sagt, nee, du kriegst keinen Vertrag mehr, wir verlängern trotzdem nicht, bist du ab 30. und 30. auch von Versicherungsseite aus nicht die Private, sondern von der BG, also der Berufsgenossenschaft, stehst du quasi mit leeren Händen da. Die private Auffang ist halt die Frage, wie man versichert ist. Ich bin dann im Oktober zurückgekommen, nee, Mitte November. Ich habe dann mein erstes Testspiel gemacht, war dann auch mit der Mannschaft im Trainingslager, war die Rückrunde schon noch Teil des Ganzen, aber ich war nicht einmal im Kader, bis auf den letzten Spieltag und irgendwann im März, glaube ich, haben sie mir dann mitgeteilt, dass der Vertrag nicht verlängert wird und dann ging es schon darum, ob ich nochmal irgendwo einen Verein kriege, aber es war tatsächlich so, dass der zweiten und dritten Liga wirklich nur Absagen haben zu alt. Das war halt die Aussage. Dann geht halt die neue Saison los, oder die Vorbereitung geht los und du hast halt keinen Verein und alle spielen und dies und das und du bist wirklich von jetzt auf gleich interessiert sich einfach keiner mehr dafür.
Hilft einem da irgendjemand bei diesem recht harten Cut? Ich meine, du hast ja deine Beschäftigung gesucht. Um dich muss man sich ja keine Sorgen machen. Also es gibt jetzt auch, glaube ich, ganz viele Themen, auf die werden wir jetzt nicht mehr kommen können. Aber wir hatten ja unter anderem die Folge zu deiner Tätigkeit bei der Zone. Das ist ja schon das letzte Tribünengespräch. Aber du hast ja deine Beschäftigung gesucht. Du bist ja, glaube ich, jetzt so dem Anschein nach nicht in ein Loch gefallen. Aber gibt es da irgendjemand, der sich bei einem meldet und sagt, Herr Gunesch, wenn Sie möchten, wollen wir uns mal zusammensetzen und mal ein bisschen gucken, wie es jetzt weitergehen könnte?
Nö, eigentlich nicht. Nein. Das gab es gar nicht.
Macht ein Berater sowas nicht vielleicht noch?
Ja, er hat natürlich gefragt, wo er helfen und unterstützen kann. Aber war zu dem Zeitpunkt schwierig. Und ich bin da wirklich – es ist eine schwierige Situation. Und ich verstehe jeden Fußballer, der große Probleme hat bei der Umstellung. Aber da hilft es mir, dass ich mich halbwegs darauf vorbereitet habe – zumindest mental. Und ich war dann auch ganz normal auf dem Arbeitsamt oder auf der Agentur für Arbeit. Hab mich arbeitssuchend gemeldet.
Was bieten die Änder an?
Ja, das war dann – ja, was haben sie denn?
Ich kann Löcher stopfen.
Wollen sie Klemsner werden? Was haben sie denn gelernt? Ich so, ja, ich bin mit 17 viel geworden. Hm, haben sie eine Ausbildung? Nein. Ja, dann müssen wir einmal gucken. Dann kriegst du so – ich glaube, das sind so Bewerbungsseminare, wo du lernst, irgendwie Bewerbungen zu machen und dann Probearbeiten und Praktika. Und als die Dame das dann alles gesagt hat – ich weiß halt, dass das – versteht mich da nicht falsch. Das ist auch alles gut, dass es das gibt und es sind auch sicherlich zum Teil zumindest sinnvolle Angebote. Aber ich behaupte einfach mal so im durchschnittlichen Arbeitsumfeld bin ich da eher oder komme ich aus einer Ausnahmesituation. Im Fußball, in dem Geschäft läuft vieles einfach anders. Und dann war ich – ich weiß nicht – da war irgendein Termin, wo ich hin musste. Ich weiß es wirklich nicht mehr. Ich war nicht da und dann haben sie mir dann ein paar Euro vom Arbeitslosengeld gestrichen, wo ich dann aber nach der ersten Zahlung gesagt habe, nein, du liegst dem Staat nicht auf der Tasche und habe mich sofort selbstständig gemeldet. So und habe dann durch das Selbstständigmelden – fällst du ja dann auch aus aus diesem Arbeitssuchendenpool, musst dann auch keine Seminare mehr etc. besuchen. Und habe dann – es hat ein bisschen gedauert. Ich will nicht sagen, dass ich in einem Loch war, aber es war keine einfache Zeit. Und habe dann im Prinzip so, wie es dann häufig einfach läuft, über das Netzwerk, über Beziehungen, über Leute, die man kennt. Das war ein blöder Zufall, wirklich ein ganz blöder Zufall, dass ich irgendwann mal bei den Rocket Beans gelandet bin. Und bei dieser Launch-Party zu Black Ops 3 war es damals. Auf einmal neben André Schöle vor der Kamera saß und mich dann nicht so schlecht geschlagen habe, dass die gesagt haben, ey warte mal, du solltest vielleicht öfter kommen, weil das macht hier ziemlich großen Spaß mit dir und die Leute mögen dich. Da bin ich nur hingekommen, weil vorher Christian Görnd, den ich übers Internet kennengelernt habe, Online-Gott, ein Online-Gott bei Twitter, mich irgendwann mal angeschrieben hat.
Bester Händel überhaupt.
Er war auch selbst verwundert, dass er noch frei war. Aber er hat mich angeschrieben und sagte, Ralph, hier, großer St. Pauli-Fan, blablabla, komm doch mal zu mir in die Sendung. So, und dann war ich bei ihm in der Sendung und dann hat er mich in eine zweite Sendung eingeladen und dann wurde dort Call of Duty gespielt und dann war der damalige Community Manager von Activision, das ist der Publisher des Spiels, auf mich aufmerksam, sind in Kontakt geblieben, der hat mich dann zu den Rocket Beans gebracht, zu dem Black Ops 3 Event und da haben die Rocket Beans gesagt, ey, warte mal, du kannst ruhig mal wiederkommen. Also auch da wieder ganz viele Zufälle, die einfach eine Rolle spielen und so hatte ich zumindest eine gewisse Beschäftigung bei den Rocket Beans für einen gewissen Zeitraum. Das hat auch großen Spaß gemacht, dass irgendwann hat das dann aus Gründen einfach nicht mehr funktioniert, weil…
Allein die Distanz ist ja schon mal, wenn du… so viele Tätigkeiten hast.
sagen wir es mal so, dieser Sender oder dieses Projekt ist ein sehr, sehr spannendes Projekt und das hat immer wahnsinnig viel Spaß gemacht, aber ich habe halt keinen einzigen Cent verdient. Ganz im Gegenteil, ich habe halt eher ganz viele Kosten gehabt und wir haben dann schon irgendwann eine Lösung gehabt, um zumindest die groben Reisekosten abzudecken, aber selbst die waren nicht zu 100 Prozent abgedeckt, sodass ich irgendwann an dem Punkt war, dass ich sagte, Leute, ich mache das zwar gerne, aber ich kann jetzt nicht dauerhaft quasi immer auf Kosten sitzen und es war dann von der anderen Seite halt, was ich verstehen und nachvollziehen kann, wie schon gesagt, die haben halt auch keinen Geldspeicher im Hinterhof. Es war nicht möglich, das zu erhöhen oder das dahingehend zu bringen, dass wir kostendeckend arbeiten oder dass ich vielleicht sogar ein Stück weit für meine Arbeit und meine Mühe auch entlohnt werde und vielleicht auch mal mit ein paar Euro Plus aus dem ganzen rausgehe. Und wir deswegen dann halt sagen mussten, okay, dann lassen wir es jetzt erst mal sein. Aber es passiert nicht im Streit. Das war kein Problem zwischen uns, sondern es war halt eine vernünftige Entscheidung, weil es für mich irgendwann halt nicht mehr sinnvoll tragbar war. Plus hätte ich dann zusätzlich einfach auf einen Namen verzichten müssen, weil ich dann bei The Zone angefangen habe und ich dann auch Montagsspiele kommentiert habe. Und dann ist es halt, also auf der einen Seite verzichtest du auf Geld, das du quasi verdienen kannst und mussten an der anderen Seite aber auch noch Geld ausgeben, um da zu sein. Ich habe dann gesagt, Leute, pass auf, so funktioniert oder so geht das halt wirklich nicht mehr auf Dauer. Von der anderen Seite, anders geht es von uns aus momentan nicht. Okay, das ist schade und dann legen wir das jetzt erstmal auf Eis. Also das war das Einzige, da gab es überhaupt keinen Beef, keinen Ärger zwischen mir und irgendeinem der Jungs. Ich bin heute noch in der WhatsApp-Gruppe drin und wir diskutieren immer noch trefflich über Fußball.
Da rein zu gucken, da würde ich ja ein paar Euro zahlen.
Gerade am Wochenende.
Ralph, was du – ja, vor allem, wenn jetzt vielleicht gewisse Frankfurter zum HSV wechseln – was du bei The Zone machst, das haben wir ja echt im letzten Tribünengespräch noch unter anderer Kulisse etwas besprochen, deswegen würde ich fast sagen, das skippen wir mal. Und ich stelle dir die einzige wichtige Frage, wo siehst du dich in fünf Jahren? Auf der Bank eines Bundesligisten.
Das wäre natürlich schön. Mir macht der Job heute so einen ganz großen Spaß, muss ich sagen. Ich darf mir zum größten Teil tolle Spieler aus der Premier League anschauen. Premier League ist die Liga, die ich am häufigsten mache. Darf meine Expertise dazu abgeben, darf meine Meinung dazu kundtun. Möchte aber immer auf dieser Experten-Schiene einfach bleiben, weil ich jetzt parallel an meinen Trainer-Lizenzen arbeite.
Ich werde Ende September mit der Jugend-Elite-Lizenz anfangen. Das ist die dritthöchste, danach folgt die A-Lizenz und dann der Fußball.
Das kannst du natürlich genauso wenig planen wie die Spieler-Karriere. Du kannst nicht sagen, ich bin jetzt in fünf Jahren Trainer. Du kannst als 15-Jähriger nicht sagen, in fünf Jahren bin ich Fußballprofi.
Wie lange dauert die Ausbildung jeweils?
Na ja, die Jugend-Elite geht relativ schnell. Das sind zehn Lerneinheiten, also zehn Tage, Montag bis Freitag, Montag bis Freitag und dann ist Montag bis Mittwoch Prüfung.
Sind die auch in Köln?
Nee, die sind in verschiedenen Sportschulen hier in der Ecke in Oberhaching. A-Lizenz dauert, glaube ich, sechs Wochen und der Fußball-Lehrer dauert halt elf Monate. Der ist sehr, sehr intensiv. In den Fußball-Lehrer reinzukommen, das dauert auch. Jugendelite und A-Lizenz, das kann man relativ zeitnah machen. Vor allem, wenn man Ex-Profi ist, dann kannst du über die VDV, über die Spieler-Gewerkschaft da, weil die nochmal so ein paar Plätze geblockt, reserviert haben, also zusätzliche Plätze. Es ist nicht so, dass dann irgendwelche rausfallen, sondern die werden einfach zusätzlich geschaffen. Kommst du da ganz gut rein und mit der A-Lizenz wirst du schon relativ ernst genommen in dem Geschäft. Sprich, ein Co-Trainer-Job im bezahlten Fußball ist in Aussicht, aber auch da. Du musst dann schon irgendwie auch Leute kennen. Es sind viele glückliche, unglückliche Umstände, die da zusammenkommen. Wenn du Florian Bruns nimmst, der war halt mal, der hat dann zum Abschluss bei Bremen U23 gespielt, war dann spielender Co-Trainer und auf einmal wird sein Chef hochgezogen und er zieht ihn mit. Dann ist Florian Bruns Co-Trainer bei Werder Bremen, wird der Vertrag nicht verlängert, aber dadurch, dass Florian jetzt schon so ein bisschen in dem Kosmos unterwegs ist, ruft Christian Streich an und sagt, du als alter Freiburger Jung, komm doch mal und mach hier meinen Co. Jetzt ist er beim SC Freiburg Co-Trainer und ist international unterwegs. Wie du siehst, ist Markus Krösche, hat unter Schmidt noch in Paderborn gespielt und ist auf einmal Co-Trainer in der Champions League. Dann fliege ich nach London und schaue mir Leverkusen an und treffe mich vorher mit Markus Krösche, den gegen den ich zigmal in der zweiten Liga als Gegenspieler hatte und der ist jetzt Co-Trainer.
Du machst deinen A-Trainer-Schein oder vielleicht machst du gleich noch deinen Fußball-Lehrer und dann ruft noch mal Hasenhüttel an.
Ist er dann noch in Leipzig?
Er ist dann noch in Leipzig, aber alle wissen schon, in zwei Jahren ist er bei den Bayern. Dann wird es auch schwieriger.
Ich habe das schon unter der Woche im Millanturn gesagt. Es gibt gewisse Prinzipien und Werte, die man einfach hat. Je höher du kommst, desto schwieriger wird es. Wenn du mir jetzt erzählst, dass der Trainer des HSV wäre, dann kennst du die Antwort, glaube ich. Nein, er hat ja Zukunft. Ganz ehrlich, das Thema Leipzig habe ich jetzt gar nicht mehr auf dem Schirm. Das ist für mich keine Distanz. Nein, das habe ich null auf dem Schirm. Deswegen überrascht du mich jetzt mit dieser Frage ein bisschen.
Hagen Hüttl ist ein sehr interessanter Trainer. Ich finde, es gibt so eine neue Generation von Trainern. Und da du ja zu ihm schon einen persönlichen Bezug hast, wöchert er sich an.
Ja, aber ich glaube, er kommt, dass er mich anrufen wird. Das kann ich mir nicht vorstellen. Aber grundsätzlich ist das eine Schiene, die ich mir sehr, sehr gut vorstellen kann. Kannst du aber nochmal natürlich nicht planen. Ich bin jetzt schon dabei, da so ein bisschen vorzuarbeiten. Ich habe das große Vergnügen und da muss ich mich auch nochmal bei Verein und vor allem bei Stefan Leitl bedanken, dass ich noch bei der U21 des FC Ingolstadt tagtäglich mittrainiere. Positiver Nebeneffekt, ich bleibe fit und sportlich. Aber es sind gerade dieses Jahr extrem viele junge Leute, die sind alle zwischen 18 und 21, bis auf zwei, drei Ausnahmen und wollen eigentlich dahin, wo ich 14, 15 Jahre lang war. Und da hilft es, ich glaube den Jungs hilft es auch, da Erfahrung weiterzugeben. Es hilft Stefan, ihn zu unterstützen und darüber hinaus kümmere ich mich um die Videoanalysen der kommenden Gegner. Das heißt, da hat Stefan natürlich noch die Unterstützung von meiner Seite, dass er im Prinzip Anfang der Woche oder spätestens Anfang der Woche eine vorgefertigte Analyse bekommt mit stärken Schwächen des kommenden Gegners und dahingehend auch seine Mannschaft einstellen kann. Das ist halt auch praktische Übung für den Trainerjob, weil das nimmt auch einen ganz großen Teil ein. Das heißt, ich setze mich dann sonntags abends hin und schaue mir Buchbach gegen Memming an und analysiere einen der beiden Vereine, wo man dann angreifen könnte.
Ja, Buchbach ja nicht allzu unerfolgreich geraten. Ja, ich sehe schon, wir werden definitiv ein Folgetribünengespräch zu dem hier machen, wenn du dann Bundesligatrainer bist. Das wird dann auch der große Durchbruch des Rasenfunk. Endlich nach mehreren Jahren dann wahrscheinlich. Deswegen beeil dich bitte mit dem…
Ich mach schnell, ja.
Mit deiner weiteren Karriere. Auch wenn es schwerfällt nach so vielen Stunden, glaube ich, Frank Reif, wir müssen uns langsam voneinander trennen. Wir haben über einige Aspekte jetzt nicht reden können, das ist kaum zu glauben. Das sage ich am Ende von jedem Tribünengespräch. Aber wir haben definitiv einen guten Eindruck bekommen, wie deine Karriere verlaufen ist und was für ein Typ du so bist. Wir konnten es vorher schon ahnen, aber jetzt wissen wir es in aller Ausführlichkeit.
Ich würde vielleicht zum Abschluss ganz gerne nochmal so ein Fazit von dir hören, wenn du jetzt rückglückst auf deine Karriere, Schule mehr oder weniger hart gekuttet. Das ist jetzt natürlich weitersgehend erfolgreich verlaufen, darum kann man wahrscheinlich das schlecht bereuen. Aber so jetzt einfach mal als persönliches Fazit als Rückblick auf eine Profi-Karriere, wie siehst du das heute nach Abschluss?
Also ganz generell, was alle Vereine eint, bei denen ich war, wenn ich zurückkomme oder wenn ich in irgendeiner Form Kontakt mit dem Verein oder mit den Fans habe, gibt es immer ein positives Feedback. Also man freut sich, mich zu sehen. Ich bin immer positiv in Erinnerung geblieben. Das heißt, das sage ich jetzt mal so, ich kann nicht alles falsch gemacht haben. Ich kann jederzeit am Middellentor auflaufen und die Leute würden sich freuen, mich zu sehen. Ich kann jederzeit am Bruchweg – das habe ich auch gemerkt, als ich bei einem Benefits Spiel vor einigen Monaten da war – auflaufen. Und die Leute freuen sich, mich zu sehen. Dasselbe jetzt auch hier in Ingolstadt und auch wenn ich in Aachen nicht wirklich Profifußball gespielt habe, trotzdem mit meinen Spielen dann in Aachen immer freundlich begrüßt worden. Das ist zum einen eine Sache, die mich sehr freut, weil es mir natürlich auch wichtig ist. Ich habe euch ja sehr mitbekommen, dass ich da immer auch bedacht war, einen guten Draht zu den Leuten zu haben. Nicht nur, um gut dazustehen, sondern einfach auch – oder nicht nur auch, sondern einfach, um den Leuten das Gefühl zu geben, dass sie Teil des Ganzen sind. Vielleicht nicht ganz so aktiv, wie wir halt auf dem Platz. Wir müssen den Ball ins Tor schießen bzw. verhindern, dass er bei uns reingeht. Aber wir arbeiten trotzdem immer in dieselbe Richtung. Ich glaube einfach, dass die Leute so etwas honorieren und sich so etwas häufiger wünschen. Wobei ich weiß, dass es sehr vielen Spielern so geht, die aber vielleicht nicht diese Intention oder diese Aktivität haben, das dann auch aktiv anzugehen. An alle Nachwuchs-Fußballer, wenn Holzfüße wie ich Bundesliga spielen können, dann müsstet ihr das auch hinkriegen.
Das geht raus in den TK-Schlamm.
Ob es zu mehr gereicht hätte oder nicht, weiß ich nicht. Vielleicht, wenn ich in der oder in der Situation – das ist schwer zu sagen. Ich bin froh über jede einzelne Erfahrung, die ich machen durfte. Ich bin wahnsinnig froh über die allerallermeisten Mitspieler, die ich hatte, weil ich von vielen sehr viel mitnehmen konnte, gerade auch von meinen Trainern. Ich möchte mich beileibe nicht über meine Karriere beschweren, denn ich hatte die Möglichkeit, über all die Zeit ein wahnsinnig privilegiertes Leben zu führen. Das habe ich mir damit ermöglicht. Bei allem Ehrgeiz und bei allem Streben nach mehr sollte man unterm Strich dann aber auch – und da ist wieder der Realist – seine Situation vernünftig, sinnvoll und vor allem auch in einem größeren Kontext einordnen können. Da habe ich schon verdammt viel Glück gehabt.
Das ist ein schönes Schlussfazit. Das entlässt uns auch in die – wer hätte das gedacht – in die Nacht. Damit hätte ich nicht gerechnet, als wir heute angefangen haben. Warum eskalieren diese Tribünengespräche immer so? Diesmal bin ich wenigstens nicht mit 28 Seiten Vorbereitung gekommen und trotzdem. Dafür sind sie gemacht. Ich kann nicht anders als dir sehr, sehr herzlich zu danken, Ralph. Das hat echt großen Spaß gemacht. Es war sehr interessant. Ich hoffe auch für die Hörerinnen und Hörer da draußen. Ralph Gunesch, Ed Felgenralle auf Twitter, aber dir folgt ja sowieso schon jeder. Alle anderen Leute kann ich ja eh nicht ernst nehmen. Vielen, vielen Dank, dass du hier mit dabei warst. Vielen Dank auch dir, Frank, und auch vielen Dank allen Hörerinnen und Hörern. Ihr könnt uns unterstützen. Stützen auf rasenfunk.de slash unterstützen, könnt ihr dem Rasenfunk-Supporters Club beitreten. Vielleicht können wir dann viel, viel mehr Tribünengespräche dieser Art machen. Und die dauern ja anscheinend immer fünf Stunden, egal wie viel wir uns vornehmen. Ralph, vielen Dank dir und hoffentlich bis bald irgendwann mal wieder im Rasenfunk.
Ganz bestimmt.
Und danke auch dir, Frank.
Das war das Rasenfunk – Tribünengespräch.
Wir gehen nun zurück in die angeschlossenen Funkhäuser.